♪
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
♪
>> THE GAME OF THE WEEK TAKES
YOU TO ST. PETERSBURG, FLORIDA.
THE TAMPA BAY RAYS GETTING SET
TO HOST THE BALTIMORE ORIOLES.
THE WEST COAST OF FLORIDA, A
NICE SUNNY DAY IN FLORIDA.
AS WANDER FRANCO AND THE RAYS
INNING SET TO HOST JOHN MEANS,
JUST ACTIVATED OFF THE IL.
HE HAS BEEN ON THE I.L. SINCE
EARLY JUNE.
THE ORIOLES TOOK THE FIRST GAME
OF THE SERIES AGAINST TAMPA AND
LOOKING TO WIN AGAINST TAMPA FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE 2017 IN
SENSE PETERSBURG.
ORIOLES LOOKING TO WIN THEIR
FOURTH STRAIGHT GAME IN THIS
MATCHUP TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
I AM HEIDI WATNEY.
THIS IS LAUREN GARDNER.
WE WILL BE WITH YOU FOR THE NEXT
HALF-HOUR, GETTING YOU SET FOR
THE GAME.
IN CASE YOU DID NOT PUT THAT
TOGETHER, THAT IS FIVE WOMEN
CALLING THIS GAME FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MLB HISTORY.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT, BUT FOR ME
IT IS JUST ANOTHER DAY OF WORK.
I LOVE DOING THESE YOUTUBE
BROADCASTS.
THEY ARE HIGH ENERGY AND I HAVE
DONE QUITE A FEW OF THEM.
I HAVE WORKED IN BASEBALL WELL
OVER A DECADE.
ARE YOU EXCITED FOR THIS?
LAUREN: I AM SO EXCITED.
YOU ARE WELL-QUALIFIED, SO ARE
THE OTHER THREE WOMEN ON THE
CALL.
THE GRAVITY OF THE SITUATION HAS
NOT BEEN LOST ON ME, WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR ALL OTHER WOMEN IN
SPORTS AND IN MALE-DOMINATED
INDUSTRIES, BUT FOR YOUNG GIRLS
AND BOYS TO SEE THIS AS
COMMONPLACE.
I'M SO HONORED TO BE PART OF
HISTORY.
DON'T MAKE ME CRY.
WE WILL MOVE ON.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M NOT CRYING, YOU ARE CRYING.
HEIDI: ANYONE CAN DO ANY ROLE,
HOST, ANALYST, PLAY-BY-PLAY,
SIDELINE REPORTER.
THAT IS THE GREAT THING ABOUT
BASEBALL.
EVEN THOUGH THE TAMPA BAY RAYS
DOMINATE THE A.L. EAST, THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES WON GAME ONE.
HERE IS A LOOK AT HOW IT WENT
DOWN LAST NIGHT.
>> RYAN MOUNTCASTLE PLAYING
FIRST BASE TODAY.
THIS ONE INTO RIGHT FIELD.
A FAIR BALL.
AWAY FROM AROZARENA.
A LONG WAY AWAY.
AUSTIN HAYS IS IN.
>> HE HIT SEVEN SINGLES.
THIS IS INTO RIGHT FIELD FOR
HAYS.
A FAIR BALL.
THE ORIOLES ADD ANOTHER ONE.
IT'S 6-0.
AND IT'S STRIKE THREE SWINGING.
WELLS WITH A COUPLE K'S IN A
SCORELESS NINTH.
HEIDI: OUR PRODUCER, ABSOLUTE
GENIUS.
HE GAVE US THE NAME OF THE
SEGMENT, ON BOXING THE MATCHUP.
WE PREVIEW THE GAME WITH THE TWO
LADIES CALLING THE GAME, MELANIE
NEWMAN AND SARAH LANGS.
WELCOME AND CONGRATULATIONS.
MELANIE: YOU GET THAT ADRENALINE
AND EXCITEMENT.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT ATMOSPHERE
TO BE CALLING A GAME IN THAN THE
LAST TWO YEARS.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS TODAY
THAT DOOR OPENS.
WHILE WE WILL CELEBRATE THAT
EXCITEMENT OF THE FIRST, THE
DOOR IS STAYING OPEN.
THIS BECOMES NORMAL FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD.
THIS IS WHERE WE GET TO TAKE
THOSE NON-QUALIFIERS OUT FROM
THE PLACE THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO BE QUALIFIERS FOR SO LONG AND
JUST HAVE AN OPEN INDUSTRY.
LAUREN: YOU SAID EARLIER THIS
WEEK, GENDER DOES NOT DETERMINE
YOUR PASSIONS.
SARAH, YOU ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE SABERMETRICS OF THIS GAME.
TAKE ME INTO YOUR EMOTIONS RIGHT
NOW.
SARAH: I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
MELANIE JUST SAID.
IT IS COOL TO KNOW THIS IS AN
HISTORIC MOMENT.
I APPRECIATE THE OUTPOURING WE
HAVE GOTTEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
EVERYONE ACKNOWLEDGING THE
MOMENT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
THERE ARE GOING TO BE SO MANY
MORE OF THESE AFTERWARDS.
WE ARE JUST GETTING THAT BALL
ROLLING.
LAUREN: SO ENOUGH OF THE
FEEL-GOOD STUFF, WE WILL GET
INTO THE GAME.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE O A SECOND.
THEY HAVE TO BE HAPPY GETTING
THEIR LEFTY ACE BACK IN THE
ROTATION.
MELANIE: HE IS THE ACE.
HE IS STILL YOUNG, BUT SO MANY
OF THESE PITCHERS LOOK UP TO HIM
BECAUSE THEY ARE EVEN YOUNGER
THAN HE IS.
THE FOCUS FOR ALL OF MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL IS PITCHING.
EVERYBODY IS SHORT RIGHT NOW.
WHILE BULLPENS ARE BEING PACKED,
HAVING A STARTER GIVING YOU SIX,
SEVEN INNINGS EVERY TIME, JOHN
MEANS STANDS ALONE FOR THE
ORIOLES ROSTER.
HE GOT PICKED UP IN HIS LAST TWO
STARTS.
THERE IS A FRESHER BULLPEN
TONIGHT.
WHEN HE RUNS OUT OF GAS, THEY
WILL NOT KEEP A HARD LIMIT ON
HIM.
GREAT TO SEE HIM GET THE BALL
ROLLING.
HEIDI: NOT LOOKING FOR A
COMPLETE GAME FOR HIM TONIGHT.
THERE IS A TRICKLE-DOWN EFFECT
HAVING THE ACE BACK ON THE
STAFF.
WHAT CAN WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEE
THAT MEANS IS BACK?
SARAH: ONE THING I'M LOOKING FOR
IS HIS FIRST PITCH STRIKE RIGHT.
HE LEADS THE MAJORS IN ALL
QUALIFIED STARTERS.
IF HE IS GETTING AHEAD OF
BANNERS, YOU KNOW IT IS GOING
RIGHT FOR HIM.
HE SET A RECORD FOR FIRST PITCH
STRIKE RATE IN A NO-HITTER
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THAT IS WHAT I WILL BE KEEPING
AN EYE ON, THAT FIRST PITCH.
HEIDI: YOU HAVE BEEN KEEPING AN
EYE ON THE RAYS.
THREE WEEKS, IT DOES NOT SEEM
THAT LONG, BUT IT HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE FOR THE RAYS, FOUR
BACK OF THE RED SOX.
NOW THEY ARE JUST A GAME AND A
HALF BACK.
MELANIE: THEY HAD THAT
OUTSTANDING MAY.
WHERE THEY ARE RIGHT NOW IS A
TRIBUTE TO THAT.
THEY HAVE BEEN .500 IN EVERY
GAME NOT PLAYED IN MAY.
THEY HAVE LOOKED BETTER LATELY.
THE OFFENSE IS VERY UP AND DOWN.
SINCE JUNE 1, IT IS NOT AMONG
THE LEADERS.
WEIGHTED RUNS CREATED PLUS IS
ONE OF THE ALL-ENCOMPASSING
STATS.
I THINK THAT COULD BE THE STEP,
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE LATELY.
LAUREN: THE AL EAST SUCH A TOUGH
DIVISION.
YOU HAVE THE BLUE JAYS MAKING
NOISE, THE RED SOX AND THE RAYS
AT THE TOP.
THE YANKEES HAVE SURPRISED
PEOPLE IN THAT THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN AS GOOD AS IN YEARS PAST.
THE ORIOLES MADE NOISE BY
BEATING THE RAYS YESTERDAY.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS DIVISION
SHAKING OUT?
MELANIE: EVEN IN A SOFTER YEAR,
THEY ARE ALWAYS GOING TO EAT
EACH OTHER ALIVE.
IT HAD BEEN LOOKED OVER
INITIALLY BEFORE THE SEASON WITH
THE NL EAST, BUT THE A.L. EAST
COMES BACK TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
HOW DID IT FEEL TO WATCH THE
ORIOLES DRAFT AHEAD OF US THIS
YEAR?
[LAUGHTER]
, IT WAS A SURPRISE BUT HERE YOU
COME INTO THIS WONKY WEEK OUT OF
THE SECOND HALF WHERE THE RED
SOX GET BEAT UP BY A STRUGGLING
YANKEES CLUB AND THE ORIOLES
TAKE ONE FROM THE RAYS.
YOU GO DOWN THE STRETCH AND YOU
WILL SEE A LOT MORE OF THAT
ACTION COME TO FRUITION,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE JAYS SAW
THE ORIOLES LATER THAN ANYONE IN
THE SEASON.
IT WILL GET INTERESTING.
LAUREN: THE JAYS CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE RAYS AND THE
RED SOX AND YANKEES PLAYING OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS.
ALL SUCH EXCITING TEAMS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, LADIES.
WE WILL LET YOU GET READY FOR
THE GAME BROADCAST IN A COUPLE
MINUTES.
GOOD LUCK AND HAVE FUN.
MELANIE: I THINK WE WILL ALL
HAVE FUN.
HEIDI: LIFE IS GOOD.
THAT BRINGS US TO TO POLL -- TO
OUR POLL QUESTION TONIGHT.
WHO WILL WIN TONIGHT'S GAME, THE
ORIOLES OR THE RAYS?
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR ANSWERS FOR
OUR POLL QUESTION.
WE WILL HAVE THOSE RESULTS A
LITTLE BIT LATER BEFORE FIRST
PITCH.
WE WILL TAKE A QUICK BREAK, BUT
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE WILL TALK
WITH AUSTIN MEADOWSWE WILL ALSOR
FOR OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
STAY WITH US.
♪
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> THERE IS A LITTLE LIFE TO THE
RAYS NOW.
AND HE SWINGS.
HITS IT HIGH AND DEEP.
AND GONE!
HOME RUN.
FRANCO'S FIRST OF THE BIG
LEAGUES WILL TIE THIS GAME.
FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HOME RUN.
TIE GAME.
CURTAIN CALL.
>> DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
ON ITS WAY.
HIS FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT.
THREE RUN HOMER.
IT'S 5-5.
>> WANDER FRANCO>> MAKING
HIMSELF AT HOME IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
A THREE RUN HOMER AND IT IS A
BRAND-NEW GAME.
♪
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
HEIDI: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
HERE IS A LOOK AT THE STARTING
LINEUP FOR THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
YANDY DIAZ IS BACK AFTER COMING
OUT OF LAST NIGHT'S GAME.
WANDER FRANCO AT THIRD.
AUSTIN MEADOWS THE DH.
BATTING THIRD.
RANDY AROZARENA IS CLEANUP.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE GOING TO TALK
TO THE GUY BATTING THIRD IN THIS
LINEUP, AUSTIN MEADOWS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US ON OUR
YOUTUBE PREGAME SHOW.
YOU ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED ORIOLES
PITCHING.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT FACING THIS
ORIOLES TEAM THAT YOU SEEM TO
SALIVATE WHEN YOU GET IN THE
BOX?
AUSTIN: I THINK IT JUST COMES
DOWN TO SEEING THE BALL WELL AND
PUTTING TOGETHER GOOD AT-BATS.
I THINK I SEE THEIR GUYS PRETTY
WELL.
FOR ME, IT IS TRYING TO
CONTRIBUTE EVERY NIGHT, EACH AND
EVERY TEAM, AND TRYING TO DO MY
PART IN THE LINEUP AND SCORE
SOME RUNS.
HEIDI: YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT
SIMPLIFYING YOUR SWING.
I HEARD A STORY ABOUT YOU GOING
OUT NIGHT FISHING TO GET THIS
THING BACK ON TRACK.
WHAT IS THE DEAL?
WE NEED TO HEAR THE STORY.
AUSTIN: THERE ARE A COUPLE
FRIENDS THAT LIVE HERE IN SAINT
PETE ON THE WATER.
I FELT LIKE I NEEDED TO GET OUT.
IT WAS LIKE MY THERAPY AWAY FROM
THE FIELD.
WAS ABLE TO GET SOME FISH AND
GET MY MIND OFF BASEBALL.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU HAVE A BAD
GAME, YOU SULK AND GO HOME AND
THINK ABOUT IT.
BEING ABLE TO USE THE BOAT AS AN
OUTLET HAS BEEN GOOD FOR ME.
HEIDI: IS THAT WHY YOU ARE
PUTTING THE BALL MORE IN PLATE
THIS YEAR?
IT SEEMS LIKE LATELY YOU HAVE
BEEN A POWER DRAFT.
YOU ARE NOT STRIKING OUT AS
MUCH.
AUSTIN: YEAH, LIKE I SAID
EARLIER, FOR ME, THE ALL-STAR
BREAK REALLY HELPS.
BEING ABLE TO COME BACK AND FEEL
FRESH, ESPECIALLY COMING OFF OF
LAST YEAR.
60 GAMES, SPRINT TO THE FINISH,
NOT PLAYING A SUPERLONG SEASON
THIS YEAR.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT ALL-STAR
BREAK AND GET MY LEGS BACK UNDER
ME, I FELT PRETTY GOOD.
LAUREN: YOU PROBABLY WANT TO HIT
THE RESET BUTTON AGAINST JOHN
MEANS, 0-6 CAREER AGAINST HIM.
WHAT IS THE KEY TO GETTING A HIT
AGAINST HIM TODAY?
AUSTIN: HE HAS BEEN GOOD ALL
YEAR.
FOR ME, IT'S JUST GOING BACK TO
SIMPLIFYING IT.
HE HAS A GOOD FASTBALL.
WE WILL SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
AGAINST HIM.
AS A TEAM, PUT TOGETHER GOOD
AT-BATS AND SCRAP AWAY.
HEIDI: AFTER HITTING THE RESET
BUTTON OVER THE ALL-STAR BREAK,
YOU GOT TO FACE THE BRAVES.
YOU HAD 100 FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THERE.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE FOR YOU?
AUSTIN: IT WAS A BIT
OVERWHELMING, BUT IN A GOOD WAY.
BEING ABLE TO SEE MY FAMILY IN
THE STANDS, THAT WAS MY FIRST
TIME PLAYING ATLANTA.
BEING ABLE TO SEE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WITH SMILES ON THEIR
FACES, REGARDLESS OF HOW I DID,
BEING ABLE TO SEE THEIR SUPPORT
MEANT A LOT.
IT WAS A QUICK TRIP, BUT I GOT
TO ENJOY IT AS MUCH AS I COULD.
LAUREN: I MET YOUR MOM TWO YEARS
AGO IN CLEVELAND AT ALL-STAR
WEEK.
SHE IS AN ABSOLUTE GEM.
MAKE YOUR CASE FOR THE RAYS TO
WIN THE A.L. EAST.
AUSTIN: FOR US, WE ARE NEVER OUT
OF GAMES REGARDLESS OF WHO WE
ARE PLAYING.
WITH OUR PITCHING AND HITTING
AND DEFENSE, IT IS LIGHTS
OUTDATE IN AND DAY OUT.
WE ARE THE TOUGHEST TEAM TO BEAT
IN BASEBALL.
WE HAVE TO KEEP DOING OUR THING,
KEEP CLICKING ON ALL CYLINDERS.
WE KNOW WHEN WE DO THAT, WE STAY
HEALTHY, WE ARE ONE OF THE TOP
TEAMS IN BASEBALL.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP THAT
GOING.
HEIDI: YOU'VE GOT A BOBBLEHEAD.
IT IS YOUR BOBBLEHEAD NIGHT AT
TROPICANA FIELD.
DOES IT LOOK LIKE YOU?
DID YOU POSE FOR IT?
AUSTIN: IT IS MY FIRST ONE.
IT LOOKS PRETTY GOOD, I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE A BOBBLEHEAD
IS PRETTY COOL, REGARDLESS OF
WHERE YOU ARE AT.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT, IT'S
COOL TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THAT OUT
TO FAMILY AND ENJOY THIS NIGHT
AS MUCH AS I CAN.
THE BEARD IS A LITTLE BIT BROWN,
BUT IT BLENDS IN NICE.
THEY DID A REALLY GOOD JOB ON
IT.
LAUREN: THAT IS AWESOME.
YOU KNOW YOU MADE IT WHEN YOU
ARE IMMORTALIZED WITH A
BOBBLEHEAD.
HEIDI: GOOD LUCK TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
AUSTIN: THANK Y'ALL FOR HAVING
ME.
APPRECIATE IT.
♪
LAUREN: OUR SPOTLIGHT TONIGHT IS
ARATI PATEL, SENIOR PRODUCER OF
OUR YOUTUBE CHANNEL "THE
FUMBLE."
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
HOW DID YOU GET INVOLVED AS
BEING ONE OF THE PRODUCERS?
ARATI: I KIND OF HAVE BEEN DOING
SPORTS NEWS MY WHOLE LIFE, IN
COLLEGE AND POST COLLEGE.
WHEN THE JOB CAME ABOUT, I KNEW
I HAD TO DO IT.
I HAVE WORKED THERE FOR FIVE
YEARS NOW.
I WORK WITH A BUNCH OF OTHER
FEMALE CRATERS AND WE DO CONTENT
EVERY DAY.
-- CREATORS AND WE DO CONTENT
LAUREN: ARE THERE ANY FEMALE
PRODUCERS OR BROADCASTERS THAT
HAVE INSPIRED YOU ON YOUR
JOURNEY?
ARATI: I AM A DIEHARD DODGER
FAN.
ALANA HAS ALWAYS BEEN ON THE
AIR.
IT IS COOL TO ACTUALLY BE WITH
HER RIGHT NOW.
SHE IS SUCH A BIG INSPIRATION
FOR ME.
THERE ARE ALSO OTHERS IN THE
NBA, LIKE DORIS, ALL THESE WOMEN
HAVE SHAPED THE WAY FOR WOMEN,
WHO I ASPIRE TO BE.
LAUREN: WE LOVES OURSELVES SOME
ALANNA RIZZO.
WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE TO
GIRLS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
BROADCASTING OR CREATING
CONTENT?
ARATI: THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE
OF ADVICE IS JUST KEEP GOING.
THIS IS NOT AN EASY THING TO DO.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR GOAL AND
DIRECTION AND CONSTANTLY WORK AT
IT.
DOORS WILL CLOSE AND OPEN.
IF YOU HAVE A GOOD MINDSET AND
CONTINUE TO WORK, THERE IS
NOTHING THAT IS OFF LIMITS.
ALL THE DOORS CAN OPEN FOR YOU
IF YOU JUST KEEP GOING.
>> THERE ARE 70 DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS YOU CAN LEARN AND DO.
-- ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE PART OF
ALL-STAR WEEK?
ARATI: I HAVE TO GO WITH TREY
MANCINI IN THE HOME RUN DERBY.
THE WHOLE BUILDUP TO ALL OF
THAT, AFTER THE YEAR HE HAD,
THAT HE DID IT FOR HIS FRIEND,
YOU COULD SEE IT WHEN IT
HAPPENED.
HE KILLED IT.
IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL THING TO
WATCH AND IT BROUGHT EVERYONE
TOGETHER.
FOR SURE SOMETHING THAT WILL GO
DOWN IN HISTORY FOREVER.
>> STORIES LIKE THOSE ARE
EXACTLY WHY WE LOVE OUR JOBS.
TONIGHT'S GAME COMING UP IN JUST
A BIT.
CAN THE RAYS TAKE THE AL PENNANT
FOR THE SECOND TIME STRAIGHT?
ARATI: I DON'T THINK THE RED SOX
HAVE IT IN THE BAG YET.
THEY HAVE A STRETCH AGAINST THE
YANKEES IN A COUPLE DAYS.
IF THEY ARE ABLE TO HOLD THEM
OFF, THEY WILL BE ABLE TO SECURE
A MORE DEFINITE SPOT IN GETTING
THE PENNANT.
AT THIS POINT, I THINK IT IS
ANYONE'S GAME.
IT WILL BE FUN TO WATCH HOW THIS
PLAYS OUT IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> I LIKE THAT PREDICTION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
BEST OF LUCK DOWN THE ROAD.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
ARATI: THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> COMING UP NEXT, ALANNA RIZZO
WILL JOIN US FOR PICKS TO CLICK.
WANDER FRANCO, MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
WOULD YOU EXPECT ANY LESS?
>> OH, HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> HIGH FLY BALL CENTER FIELD.
IT'S DEEP.
BACK, AND OUT OF HERE.
MOUNTCASTLE.
TOUCH A BALL.
THERE IS A LINE DRIVE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
AND THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
JUST GOT OUT.
THERE IS A SHOT DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
RYAN MOUNTCASTLE WITH THREE HOME
RUNS.
1-2 PITCH.
THAT IS A BASE HIT TO CENTER
FIELD.
>> WAY BACK.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
CEDRIC MULLINS HAS LEFT THE
BUILDING.
MULLINS WITH A SHOT DEEP RIGHT.
IS IT ENOUGH?
YES IT IS.
HE HAS GOT HIMSELF ANOTHER HIT.
A FOUR HIT GAME FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
HE'S 5-5.
CENTRIC MULLINS, THEY CAN'T GET
HIM OUT.
♪
>> LOVING THE SIGN FROM THE
TROP.
WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
HERE IS A LOOK AT THE O'S
STARTING LINEUP.
CEDRIC MULLINS LEADING OFF.
THE SKIPPER SAID HE NEEDED THE
DAY OFF YESTERDAY AFTER GOING
0-5 ON SUNDAY.
STARTING IN CENTER FIELD.
AUSTIN HAYS AT THE SECOND SPOT.
TREY MANCINI THIRD.
MOUNTCASTLE HITTING CLEANUP.
HOW ABOUT PAT VALAIKA?
TWO R.B.I. NIGHT LAST NIGHT
AFTER A 6-1. VICTORY
LET'S BRING IN ALANNA RIZZO,
REPORTING LIVE FROM THIS GAME.
HOW ARE YOU?
ALL THE ATTENTION AND FANFARE
OVER THE PAST 24 HOURS.
ARE YOU EXHAUSTED YET?
ALANNA: IT HAS BEEN A BIG
WHIRLWIND, BUT ALSO A LOT OF FUN
IN TERMS OF THE POSITIVITY AND
RECEPTION OF THIS HISTORIC
EVENT.
IN MY 15, 16 YEAR SPORTS
TELEVISION CAREER, I'VE NEVER
HAD AS MUCH INTEREST IN ANY
OTHER STORY THAN THIS GAME
TONIGHT, SO IT HAS BEEN NICE.
>> AND IT IS WELL-DESERVED.
SOMEONE WHO DESERVES A LOT OF
CREDIT IS CENTER FIELDER CEDRIC
MULLINS.
ALANNA: CEDRIC MULLINS WAS THE
LOAN REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME FOR THE ORIOLES.
TREY MANCINI PARTICIPATED IN THE
HOME RUN DERBY.
CENTRIC MULLINS CONTINUES A
TRADITION FOR BALTIMORE OF BEING
THAT HOMEGROWN TALENT THAT IS
REPRESENTED AT THE MID-SUMMER
CLASSIC.
HE JOINS JOHN MEANS, MANNY
MACHADO, JONATHAN SCHOOP IN
TERMS OF BALTIMORE ORIOLES IN
THE ALL-STAR GAME IN RECENT
YEARS THAT HAVE COME UP THROUGH
THE BALTIMORE SYSTEM.
HE CHANGED HIS CAREER SINCE
BEING DEMOTED IN JULY OF 2019.
HE HAS ABANDONED SWITCHHITTING
AND GONE BACK TO HIS LEFT SIDE.
IN N24 MORE AT-BATS, HE HAS 23
MORE HITS OFF OF LEFTIES THIS
SEASON THAN ALL OF THE THREE
PAST YEARS.
CEDRIC MULLINS HAS KINDA FIGURED
IT OUT.
THEIR SKIPPER SAID HE SIMPLIFIED
THINGS FOR HIMSELF.
NOT AS MUCH PRESSURE.
NOT TRYING TO DO MUCH FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE PLATE.
>> HE WILL BE FACING A LEFTY IN
SHANE MCCLANAHAN, WHO REALLY
THROWS HARD.
HE IS ONE OF THE HARDEST
THROWERS IN THE LEAGUE.
ALANNA: WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS SITUATION IS HE'S A
BALTIMORE NATIVE.
HE GREW UP ROUGHLY 13 MINUTES.
WHY DO I KNOW IT IS 13 MINUTES,
I'M NOT SURE.
13 MINUTES FROM CAMDEN YARDS.
HE CREDITS CAL RIPKEN SENIOR --
OR CAL RIPKEN JR. WITH THE FACT
THAT THAT IS WHY HE LOVES
BASEBALL.
WE KNOW WHAT CAL RIPKEN JR. HAS
MEANT TO THIS GAME.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS A ROOKIE.
BUT THIS IS AGUY WHO THROWS
INCREDIBLY HARD.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF ALE
STARTERS THAT THROW AS HARD AS
HE DOES, THERE IS ONLY ONE GUY
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE THAT HAS
THROWN FASTBALLS MORE THAN 100
MILES PER HOUR, AND THAT IS
GERRIT COLE.
THIS GUY IS SOMETHING TO BE
RECKONED WITH.
IMAGINE A STEADY DOSE OF
FASTBALLS TONIGHT.
COMING UP FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HIS CAREER, WILL FACE HIS
HOMETOWN TEAM.
>> LUCKILY FOR HIM, AT LEAST THE
GAME IS IN TAMPA BAY, SO HE
WON'T HAVE THE HOMETOWN NERVES.
>> IS ONLY 13 MINUTES.
[LAUGHTER]
TOO CLOSE TO HOME.
>> GOOD LUCK TONIGHT.
ALANNA: THANKS.
>> IT IS TIME FOR PICKS TO CLICK
, PRESENTED BY FANDUEL SPORTS
BOOK.
OUR FIRST PICK, WHO IS GOING TO
WIN THE AL EAST?
LAUREN: WE KNOW THEY ARE BEASTS
IN THE EAST.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY
SPOILER.
FOR ME , IT'S THE TAMPA BAY
RAYS.
THE TYLER GLASNOW INJURY IS
TOUGH.
KEVIN CASH CAN GET THE MOST OUT
OF THE PIECES HE HAS BEEN GIVEN.
HE PLAYS THE CARDS HE HAS BEEN
DEALT.
FOR ME, IT'S TOUGH TO GO AGAINST
THE RAYS.
HEIDI: I LIKE SEEING THOSE ODDS
AT PLUS 800 FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
IF I WAS A BETTING WOMAN, I
WOULD PUT CASH DOWN ON THAT.
I LIKE WHAT WE SEE FOR THE YOUNG
TEAM.
MY PICK HAS TO BE THE BOSTON RED
SOX.
I SPENT FOUR YEARS AS PART OF
RED SOX NATION.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE ALEX CORA
BACK, CHRIS SALE JUST HAD A
REHAB START, THAT'S BASICALLY
GETTING ONE OF THE BEST PITCHERS
AT THE TRADE DEADLINE WITHOUT
GETTING -- WITHOUT TRADING
ANYTHING FOR HIM.
THAT IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO WATCH OVER THE NEXT 10 DAYS,
WHAT LEADS UP TO THE TRADE
DEADLINE?
THE TAMPA BAY RAYS WENT TO THE
WORLD SERIES LAST YEAR.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE SNEAKY GOOD
PITCHING, EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE HUGE
HEADLINERS.
I'M GOING TO GO A THREE TEAM
RACE.
I KNOW YOU CAN'T COUNT OUT THE
YANKEES, BUT I DON'T THINK THEY
HAVE IT THIS YEAR.
THEY SEEM TO BE FLOUNDERING.
THEY GO ON A STREAK AND THEN GO
DOWN.
LAUREN: IT IS INTANGIBLE.
HEIDI: I WILL GO WITH THE BOSTON
RED SOX.
LAUREN: YOU HAD TO.
OUR NEXT PICK TO CLICK, WHO WILL
BE YOUR PICK FOR THE AL PENNANT?
THIS IS A SNEAKY HOT PICK.
ROSS ATKINS GOING INTO THE
DEADLINE SAID HE DOES NOT WANT
TO PICK UP A RENTAL PLAYER.
JOSE BERRIOS, WE HAVE SEEN
RUMORS THEY COULD PICK THEM UP.
THEY HAVE AN M.V.P. AND TRIPLE
CROWN CANDIDATE IN VLAD GUERRERO
JR..
EVER HEARD OF HIM?
HEIDI: THEY ARE YOUNG.
THEY LOVE THE GAME.
THEY LOVE TO HAVE FUN.
BY THE WAY, THEY WILL BE
RETURNING TO THEIR HOME BALLPARK
IN TORONTO.
MY PICK, THIS IS A SPICY PICK,
IT'S NOT CALLED #SAFEPICK.
I'M GOING WITH THE BLUE JAYS.
LAUREN: I LIKE THEM AT PLUS
1000.
IF I'M A BETTING WOMAN, I MIGHT
TAKE THAT.
BECAUSE I PICK THE RED SOX TO
WIN THE EAST, I WILL SAY RED SOX
FOR THE PENNANT AS WELL.
I THINK THE WHITE SOX WILL PUT
UP A FIGHT.
THAT WHITE SOX ROTATION IS
SNEAKY GOOD.
THEY HAVE THE OFFENSE.
THEY WILL GET PIECES BACK LATER
IN THE YEAR.
I WILL NOT COUNT OUT THE WHITE
SOX.
I GO RED OR WHITE SOX.
I'M GOING SOX.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
YOUR FINAL PICK ON OVER-UNDER
RUN SCORED AND TONIGHT'S GAME.
LAUREN: I THINK IT IS AT 7.5.
I WILL GO UNDER.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT TO EXPECT
FROM JOHN MEANS.
AND SHANE MCCLANAHAN PLAYING
AGAINST HIS HOMETOWN TEAM.
13 MINUTES, NOT 10 MINUTES.
WE HAD SEVEN TOTAL RUNS LAST
NIGHT IN THAT VICTORY FOR THE
O'S IN GAME ONE.
I'M GOING UNDER.
HEIDI: YOU DON'T NEED ANY EXTRA
JUICE TO GO UP AGAINST THIS RAYS
TEAM, BECAUSE THEIR OFFENSE IS
SNEAKY GOOD.
JOHN MEANS COMING OFF THE IL,
YOU DON'T KNOW WHEN YOU GET FROM
A PITCHER COMING OFF THE IL.
IN ONE OF HIS LAST TWO STARTS
BEFORE HE WENT ON THE I.L. WAS
AGAINST THE RAYS, HE GAVE UP
FOUR RUNS.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE OVER
JUST BECAUSE YOU PICKED THE
UNDER.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
I LIKE THE ORIOLES OFFENSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE CAN EXPECT
FROM MEANS.
YOU HAVE SHANE MCCLANAHAN AND
THE RAYS.
BULLPEN IS REALLY GOOD.
I WILL GO WITH THE OVER.
LAUREN: I LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE TO BALANCE EACH OTHER
OUT.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING AT HOME,
WE'VE GOT NOTHING.
THAT IS ALL WE'VE GOT FOR YOU.
LET'S GET TO THE POLL RESULTS.
HARD-HITTING QUESTION, WHO WAS
GOING TO WIN THIS GAME?
LOOKS LIKE THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
70%.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
THE O'S WON 6-1 LAST NIGHT.
HEIDI: THE O'S DID TAKE THE
FIRST GAME.
MAYBE WE HAVE MORE RAYS FANS
WATCHING THIS.
BUT RAYS ARE IN SECOND PLACE IN
THE DIVISION.
I DON'T THINK -- I THINK PEOPLE
ARE JUST GOING WITH THE
RANKINGS.
BUT YOU CAN'T COUNT OUT THE
ORIOLES.
THEY GOT OFF TO A HOT START IN
THE SEASON.
IT IS A TOUGH DIVISION.
THEY'VE GOT SO MANY GREAT YOUNG
PLAYERS, RYAN MOUNTCASTLE,
CEDRIC MULLINS, THEY WILL BE
COMING UP IN THE NEXT COUPLE
YEARS.
THESE RAYS MAN, THEY ARE
EXCITING.
LAUREN: THEY KEEP FINDING WAYS
TO WIN.
WE ARE A MINUTE AND 17 AWAY FROM
FIRST PITCH.
HEIDI: TH -- THIS WILL BE AN
EXCITING GAME.
THOSE WOMEN ARE SEASON VETERANS.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY HAVE EARNED THEIR SPOT
HERE.
GOOD LUCK TO THEM IN THE GAME.
WE WILL TAKE ONE MORE LOOK AT
THE AL EAST STANDINGS.
THE TAMPA BAY RAYS LAST NIGHT
FELL TO A GAME AND A HALF BACK
BEHIND THE RED SOX.
BLUE JAYS SEVEN GAMES BACK.
THE ORIOLES ARE IN THE BASEMENT.
WITHIN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE EAST,
YOU CAN'T PUT A FINGER ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT.
THE YANKEES TOOK 2-3 OVER THE
RED SOX ON THE WEEKEND.
THEY COULD PROVE ME WRONG.
[LAUGHTER]
LAUREN: WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
JUST BECAUSE OF THAT.
HEIDI: THIS HAS BEEN A FUN
BROADCAST, BRINGING YOU THE
PREGAME SHOW.
JOHN MEANS, SHANE MCCLANAHAN.
THE LEFTY-LEFTY MATCHUP.
RANDY AROZARENA OUT THERE.
ANTHONY SANTANDER FOR THE
ORIOLES.
EVERYONE IS GETTING HOT IN THE
SECOND HALF.
ENJOY THE GAME.
MELANIE NEWMAN, SARAH LANGS,
ALANNA RIZZO ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF TUTUBE TV BROADCAST.
HAVE A GOOD ONE.
♪
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY!
♪
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH MY!
♪
>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE BEAUTIFUL DAY
IN ST. PETERSBURG, FLORIDA.
YOU CANNOT DRIVE THROUGH WITHOUT
SEEING THE BIG TROPICANA FIELD
DOME.
THE YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
PRESENTED BY TUBE SHORTS.
IT WILL BE A BIG ONE TODAY.
THE BALTIMORE ORIOLES GAME TWO
TAKING ON THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
AFTER THE ORIOLES HAD THEIR WAY
BEHIND A ROOKIE YESTERDAY IN
SPENSER WATKINS TO SILENCE THE
RAYS, A 6-1 WIN FOR THE
ORIOLES.
A WONKY START TO THE SECOND HALF
IN THE AL EAST.
MELANIE NEWMAN, SARAH LANGS.
WE WILL LATER BE JOINED BY
ALANNA RIZZO AS WELL.
SARAH, THE AL EAST HAS ALWAYS
BEEN FOR LOVE SURPRISES.
WHAT DID YOU TAKE AWAY FROM
YESTERDAY AND NOW THE RETURN OF
JOHN MEANS?
SARAH: YESTERDAY WAS A CRAZY DAY
IN BASEBALL AND THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE EAST.
IT IS HARD TO KNOW WHAT WE WILL
SEE FOR THE REST OF THE YEAR,
BUT I'M EXCITED TO SEE HOW THIS
GAME LEADS TO EVERYTHING ELSE.
MELANIE: THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
EXCITEMENT TODAY.
SOME THINGS YOU SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT THE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE.
IT IS ON THE YOUTUBE CHANNEL
GLOBALLY AND IT IS FREE.
THERE ARE OVER 3 MILLION OTHER
FANS WHO HAVE SUBSCRIBED TO IT.
CLICK THE BELL ICON AND IT WILL
NOTIFY YOU PRIOR TO UPCOMING
GAMES.
YOUTUBE TV CUSTOMERS, THOSE
GAMES ARE STREAMING LIVE IN THE
MLB POP-UP CHANNEL GUIDE AS
WELL.
TAKE A LOOK, BECAUSE THE RAYS
HAVE BEEN MAKING WAVES, DESPITE
THE SMALL PAYROLL, WITH SOME
REALLY BIG PROSPECTS THROUGH
THEIR SYSTEM.
AND WHAT A SPLASH THOSE
PROSPECTS HAVE MADE IN MAY, TO
SAY THE LEAST.
THAT IS WHERE THEY GOT THE
BIGGEST JUMP IN THE AL EAST.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE REST OF
THE YEAR OUTSIDE OF IT AND THEY
ARE STILL TRYING TO CLIMB TO THE
TOP SPOT.
SARAH: THE RAYS HAD A WEIRD
SEASON.
A LOT OF TEAMS HAVE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FROM THEM HAS
BEEN SO EXCITING, CALLING UP THE
NUMBER ONE PROSPECT IN ALL OF
BASEBALL, WANDER FRANCO.
THESE ARE THE SCOUTING GRADES.
THAT A.B. HIT TOTAL GRADE, THE
OTHER ONE GIVEN OUT WAS TO
VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR.
HE'S SO EXCITING.
I'M EXCITED FOR A NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL STAGE TO GET TO SEE HIM
TONIGHT.
HE'S SUCH AN ELECTRIC PLAYER.
YOU SAW THE HOME RUN HE HIT IN
HIS FIRST GAME.
MELANIE: A LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
RESUME NODS BEFORE HIS CALL UP
TO TAMPA BAY.
2018, APPALACHIAN LEAGUE PLAYER
OF THE YEAR.
THE NUMBER ONE OVERALL PROSPECT
BETWEEN THE 2020 AND 2021
SEASON.
WE GOT TO TALK TO MANAGER KEVIN
CASH EARLIER.
HE SPOKE TO THIS CORE OF
SHORTSTOPS.
THE RAYS HAVE AN ABILITY TO MOVE
THEM ANYWHERE AROUND THE FIELD.
FOR THE ORIOLES, IT IS A BIT OF
A DIFFERENT STORY.
THE MIDDLE INFIELD HAS LOOKED
DIFFERENT.
THEY CHANGED SOME THINGS, BUT IT
COMES TO A VETERAN PRESENCE FOR
THE STAFF, SOME GUYS WHO HAVE
COME AROUND TO LEAD A TEAM, EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE YOUNG.
SARAH: IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ORIOLES, ONE THING THAT IS
EXCITING IS HOW MANY GREAT
MOMENTS THEY HAD.
HERE IS RYAN MOUNTCASTLE.
A THREE HOMER GAME LAST MONTH.
36TH OVERALL PICK IN 2015,
SECOND MOST R.B.I.'S ON THE
TEAM.
JOHN MEANS IS COMING BACK
TONIGHT, THREW A NO-HITTER AT
THE MARINERS.
THAT WAS SUCH A GREAT MOMENT.
CEDRIC MULLINS HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE BEST STORIES IN BASEBALL.
HE'S ALREADY GOT TWO FIVE HIT
GAMES.
NOT A LOT OF GUYS HAVE HAD THREE
FIVE HIT GAMES IN A SEASON.
SECOND THE AMERICAN LEAGUE IN
HITS.
TREY MANCINI IS A GREAT BASEBALL
AND PERSONAL STORY, COMING BACK
FROM CANCER.
HE'S LEADING THE TEAM IN HOME
RUNS AND R.B.I.'S.
HE LOOKS EXACTLY HOW HE HAS
LOOKED AT THE PLATE.
HE PUT ON A GREAT SHOW IN THE
HOME RUN DERBY LAST WEEK.
MELANIE: THAT IS MMM MMM GOOD.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE PLAYERS
FROM THE ORIOLES, WHO HAPPENED
TO HAVE LAST NAMES THAT BEGIN
WITH AN M.
MANCINI, MULLINS, MOUNTCASTLE,
AND MEANS.
ALANNA RIZZO JOINED THE FIRST
ONE, TREY MANCINI, AT THE TROP.
ALANNA: ON MARCH 12, 2020, TREY
MANCINI HAD A TUMOR REMOVED FROM
HIS COLON, THEN BEGAN BIWEEKLY
CHEMOTHERAPY SESSIONS TO FIGHT
STAGE THREE CANCER.
HE ULTIMATELY BEAT IT.
TREY MANCINI IS HAVING A GOOD
YEAR FOR THE ORIOLES.
I ASKED HIM TO REFLECT ABOUT THE
ROAD HE TRAVELED TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
TREY: IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT LONGER
THAN IT HAS BEEN.
AT THE SAME TIME, I'M SO
THANKFUL TO BE PLAYING BASEBALL
AGAIN.
I WAS NOT SURE THAT WOULD ALWAYS
BE THE CASE.
ALANNA: A LOCK FOR THE COMEBACK
PLAYER IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
I DID NOT HEAR WHAT YOU DID IN
THE HOME RUN DERBY, BUT HE PUT
ON A PERFORMANCE.
-- YOU PUT ON A PERFORMANCE.
TREY: I WAS SO EXCITED TO BE OUT
THERE, BUT I WANTED TO PERFORM
WELL.
I DID NOT WANT TO BE SEEN AS A
COURTESY INVITE OR ANYTHING.
I KNEW I COULD DO WELL.
LUCKILY I DID.
IT WAS GREAT HAVING MY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS THERE.
IT IS A MEMORY I WILL CHERISH.
SARAH: YOU CREDIT THE BALTIMORE
ORIOLES FOR HELPING YOU GET
DIAGNOSED WITH COLON CANCER.
HOW MUCH CAN YOU APPRECIATE THE
EARLY DIAGNOSIS AND WHAT THE
MEDICAL STAFF DID FOR YOU?
TREY: THEY WERE INCREDIBLE.
IT IS TOUGH TO TELL BY BLOOD
TESTS ALONE WHEN SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
THEY WERE PROACTIVE AND GOT ME A
COLONOSCOPY.
THAT IS HOW WE FOUND OUT.
I AM FOREVER INDEBTED TO THEM
FOR HELPING ME OUT.
ALANNA: YOU GUYS ARE
PROFESSIONALS.
YOU ARE COMPETITORS.
IT HAS BEEN AN INTERESTING
SEASON FOR THE ORIOLES.
WHAT IS IT IN THE SECOND HALF
THAT YOU WANT?
TREY: IT IS A HUGE SECOND HALF.
THAT IS WHAT I HAVE BEEN TELLING
THE GUYS.
THE SECOND HALF IS HUGE,
ESPECIALLY GOING THROUGH A
REBUILD LIKE WE ARE.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO START
PUTTING WINS TOGETHER AND
WINNING CLOSE GAMES.
WE HAVE GOTTEN OFF TO A GREAT
START IN THE SECOND HALF.
I'M HOPING WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THAT FOR THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS.
ALANNA: YOU HEARD TREY MANCINI
SAY A LOT OF GUYS ON THIS TEAM
WILL BE HERE NEXT YEAR.
LAST TIME THE ORIOLES HAD A
RELEVANT SEASON WAS 2016, WHEN
THEY LOST THAT AL WILD-CARD GAME
TO THE BLUE JAYS.
AT THAT TIME, BASEBALL AMERICA
RANKED THEIR FARM SYSTEM 27TH
OUT OF THE 30 CLUBS.
FAST-FORWARD TO 2021, THEY ARE
RANKED SEVENTH AS FAR AS THEIR
FARM SYSTEM, THE HIGHEST EVER
GIVEN TO THE ORIOLES BY BASEBALL
AMERICA.
THEY HAVE THAT YOUNG CORE OF
TALENT THAT WILL BE HERE NEXT
YEAR.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE MORE
REINFORCEMENTS COMING.
MUCH MORE AHEAD ON THE YOUTUBE
GAME OF THE WEEK.
WE ARE EXCITED TO BRING YOU THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES AND TAMPA BAY
RAYS.
AND FIRST PITCH COMING
UP NEXT.
♪
>> MULLINS CRANKS THIS ONE DEEP
TO CENTER FIELD.
THAT BABY IS GOING TO GO.
A SOLO SHOT.
>> THIS BALL IS CRUSHED.
ON A LINE TO RIGHT FIELD.
A TWO HOMER GAME FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
>> MULLINS DRIVES IT RIGHT FIELD
AND DEEP.
THIS ONE OUT OF HERE.
A LEADOFF HOME RUN FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
>> THIS IS LINED INTO CENTER
FIELD.
MULLINS SAVES A RUN.
>> 1-2 PITCH SLICED OUT TO LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
RUN IS OVER.
HE DIVES!
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE CATCH.
CEDRIC THE ENTERTAINER.
>> BREAKING BALL INTO THE AIR
DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
GOING BACK, CEDRIC MULLINS
IMMEDIATELY GIVES THE FANS
SOMETHING TO CHEER ABOUT.
A SWING AT A HIGH FLY BALL.
RIGHT FIELD.
IS THIS ONE OUT?
YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
SWINGS FIRST BALL.
CRACKS IT TO DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
GRICHUK IS AT THE WALL.
WE'VE SAID IT BEFORE, WE'LL SAY
IT AGAIN, A HOME RUN FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
♪
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO MLB'S
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A FUN ONE DOWN
AT TROPICANA FIELD IN ST.
PETERSBURG, FLORIDA.
MIDDLE GAME OF A THREE-GAME
SERIES.
ORIOLES TAKING ON THE RAYS.
LET'S TAKE ON THE BALTIMORE
ORIOLES LINEUP.
CEDRIC MULLINS BACK IN THE
LEADOFF SPOT.
AUSTIN HAYS BEHIND HIM.
TREY MANCINI HAS BEEN ON FIRE.
HE'S BACK AT FIRST BASE, BATTING
THIRD.
RYAN MOUNTCASTLE THE CLEANUP
HITTER.
ANTHONY SANTANDER IN THE MIDDLE
SPOT.
RAMONA REYES BATS -- RAMON URIAS
SIXTH.
PAT VALAIKA AND KELVIN GUTIERREZ
ROUND OUT THE LINEUP FOR THE
ORIOLES.
THEY WILL BE FACING LEFTY SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
THE FIRST PITCH TO CEDRIC
MULLINS IS A FASTBALL, FOULED
OFF.
AT 7:10, WE ARE UNDERWAY.
SARAH: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
SHANE MCCLANAHAN.
I AM EXCITED TO SEE THIS
VELOCITY.
HE HAS ONE OF THE FASTEST
AVERAGE FASTBALL VELOCITIES
AMONG ALL STARTERS.
CHANGEUP MIGHT BE THE BEST
PITCH.
MELANIE: HE WAS REALLY PROUD OF
HIS CHANGEUP.
WE GOT TO TALK TO SOME OF THE
RAYS BROADCASTERS.
WHAT THEY HAVE REALLY LOVED AND
FIND MOST EFFECTIVE FOR HIM IS
THE SLIDER.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW A YOUNG KID CAN BALANCE THE
CHANGEUP AND KNOWING WHAT WORKS
FOR HIM.
HE'S GOT CEDRIC MULLINS IN A 0-2
COUNT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT SHANE
MCCLANAHAN BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
WE JUST DISCUSSED IT, THE
SLIDER.
FOUR SEAM FASTBALL, CURVE AND
CHANGEUP COMING IN AROUND 10%.
ESPECIALLY IN A TIME WHEN TYLER
GLASNOW IS STILL ON THE I.L.,
MCCLANAHAN LOOKS LIKE AN
ABSOLUTE FLAMETHROWER COMPARED
TO SOME OF THE SOFT HURLERS FOR
THE RAYS.
SARAH: THE NEXT HIGHEST AVERAGE
FASTBALL BLESSED HE ON THIS TEAM
IS 93.2 FILE --  FAST BALL
VELOCITY ON THIS TEAM IS 93.2
MILES PER HOUR FOR MICHAEL
WACHA.
HE IS IN THIS ACE ROLE BECAUSE
OF THE GLASNOW INJURY.
MELANIE: MULLINS FINDS THE GAP
IN THE RIGHT SIDE.
THAT IS A LEADOFF BASE HIT.
CEDRIC MULLINS HAD THE DAY OFF
YESTERDAY BECAUSE BRANDON HYDE
SAID HE DID NOT GET MUCH OF A
BREAK PLAYING IN THE ALL-STAR
GAME.
A BREAK DID HIM SOME GOOD.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
HE MAKES CONTACT.
HE GETS SO MANY HITS.
HE'S SECOND IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE IN HITS RIGHT NOW.
MELANIE: DO YOU RECALL AT ANY
POINT RECENTLY WHERE YOU SAW TWO
HITTERS IN VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR.
AND CEDRIC MULLINS GOING BACK
ALMOST NIGHTLY FOR THE HIT LEAD?
ONE WOULD TAKE A NIGHT OFF AND
YOU GO, OH NO, THEY WILL EASE
THE LEADOFF SPOT.
SARAH: MICHAEL BRANTLEY IS ALSO
UP THERE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
BATTING AVERAGE.
IT IS COOL.
PEOPLE SAY THIS IS SUCH AN ALL
OR NOTHING GAME THESE DAYS.
BUT WE ARE ALSO SEEING A LOT OF
GOOD CONTACT AND PURE HITTERS.
MELANIE: HOW BIG IS THAT, TO SEE
THESE ARE NOT THE SAME PERENNIAL
NAMES BASEBALL IS USED TO EVERY
YEAR?
THERE ARE NAMES COMING OUT OF
THE WOODWORK NOW.
YOU PICKED DAVID FLETCHER AND
PEOPLE LAUGHED AT YOU.
YOU ARE GETTING THE LAST LAUGH.
SARAH: THIS IS WHAT IS SO GREAT
ABOUT BASEBALL.
I THINK IT DIFFERENTIATES IT
FROM EVERY OTHER SPORT.
THE FACT THAT CEDRIC MULLINS CAN
BE SECOND OR THIRD IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE IN HITS, YOU
DON'T GET THE EQUIVALENT IN THE
NBA, THE NFL.
YOU DON'T GET PLAYERS COMING OUT
OF THE WOODWORK IN THE SAME WAY.
IT IS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
SOME ANY PLAYERS THAT CYCLE
THROUGH AND SO MUCH MORE.
IT IS SOMETHING I LOVE ABOUT
THIS SPORT.
MELANIE: MCCLANAHAN FACING
AUSTIN HAYS.
A FASTBALL AT 97.
FOUL TIPS IT INTO THE GLOVE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE DEFENSE SET UP
FOR THE RAYS.
FRANCISCO MEJIA IS THE BETTER.
LIKES AND YOU KNOW STILL DEALING
WITH --  MIKE ZUNINO STILL
DEALING WITH HIP TIGHTNESS.
KEVIN KIERMAIER IN CENTER FIELD.
THAT GOLD GLOVE THAT NEVER
CEASES TO IMPRESS.
RANDY AROZARENA AND BRANDON LOWE
AT THE CORNERS.
AUSTIN HAYS WITH A BIG DRIVE,
BUT RIGHT AT THE TRACK.
RANDY AROZARENA HAS IT.
HE WILL CHASE MULLINS BACK TO
FIRST.
LET'S LOOK AT THE KEYS TO THE
GAME, BROUGHT TO YOU BY YOUTUBE
SHORTS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE FOR THE RAYS?
SARAH: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
MCCLANAHAN BRINGING THE HEAT.
AVERAGE FASTBALL VELOCITY,
FOURTH IN STARTERS.
HE GETS A TON OF SWING AND MISS
ON EVERY PITCH THAT IS NOT HIS
FOUR-SEAMER.
THAT SPARKLING OUTFIELD DEFENSE.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT A MOMENT
AGO, BUT THEY LEAD THE MAJORS IN
STATCAST DEFENSE METRICS FROM
OUTFIELDERS.
THEY HAVE 20 OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE
THERE.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE SEE YEAR IN
AND YEAR  FROM THEOUT -- AND YE
AR OUT FROM THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY INCONSISTENT
OFFENSIVELY.
IF YOU LOOK AFTER MAY, MAY WAS
GOOD FOR THEM.
THEY ARE 17TH IN WEIGHTED RUNS
CREATED PLUS.
THEY ARE JUST NOT GENERATING
CONSISTENT OFFENSE.
IF THEY DO THAT, USUALLY THEY
ARE ABLE TO WIN THE GAME.
MELANIE: IT SOUNDS SIMPLE IN THE
GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS, BUT IT
NEVER IS IN BASEBALL.
TREY MANCINI HAS AN 0-2 COUNT.
THE RUNNER UP IN THE HOME RUN
DERBY THIS YEAR.
BEATS CANCER.
0-2 FROM MCCLANAHAN.
MANCINI GETS A PIECE OF IT TO
STAY ALIVE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE TOTAL
RUNS ODDS PRESENTED BY FANDUEL
SPORTS BOOK.
OVER-UNDER, 7.5 TONIGHT.
THEY HIT SEVEN LAST NIGHT.
TWO TEAMS HERE WHO HAVE BEEN
BACK AND FORTH AFTER THE RAYS
HAD A DOMINANT BEGINNING AGAINST
BALTIMORE.
BALTIMORE FOUGHT BACK LAST
NIGHT.
SARAH: I DON'T KNOW I'M
EXPECTING MUCH OFFENSE TONIGHT.
WE HAVE TWO OF THE BEST HITTERS.
I'M NOT SURE.
MELANIE: MANCINI.
AND MCCLANAHAN COMES OUTSIDE.
BALL ONE.
MANCINI, WITH HIM BEING ABLE TO
BE CANCER LAST YEAR, HE MISSED
THE 2020 SEASON.
IF YOU TALK TO ANYONE IN THE
ORIOLES CLUBHOUSE, IT COMES BACK
TO HOW MUCH HE WAS MISSED AS A
PERSON, HIS ABILITY TO BE A
LEADER.
THE PERSONALITY THAT COMES
THROUGH REGARDLESS OF WHETHER HE
IS ON THE FIELD.
HE WILL FIGHT OFF MCCLANAHAN
HERE AGAIN.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT MANCINI
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO.
THIS GOES BACK TO HOW GOOD OF A
PLAYER HE IS, INCLUDING THE
STORY THAT HE HAS BUILT FOR
HIMSELF AGAINST LEFT-HANDED
PITCHERS.
30 R.B.I.'S.
HE HAS CEDRIC MULLINS ABOARD AT
FIRST BASE.
ORIOLES STRUCK FIRST YESTERDAY.
THEY HAD A TWO RUN FIRST INNING.
HE GETS MANCINI TO CHASE A
FASTBALL UP AND AWAY.
FIRST STRIKEOUT FOR SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
TWO AWAY.
SARAH: YOU SAW IT 98 THERE.
THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING TO SEE FROM
MCCLANAHAN.
THOSE ELEVATED FASTBALLS IS WHAT
WE SEE THESE DAYS.
THEY CERTAINLY WORK.
MELANIE: MCCLANAHAN LOOKS IN AT
RYAN MOUNTCASTLE.
MOUNTCASTLE AND MANCINI HAVE
BEEN IN TANDEM.
51 R.B.I.'S.
HE MOVED UP IN THE ORIOLES
RANKINGS.
MULLINS TAKES OFF ON THE PITCH.
THEY TAG HIM OUT.
A 2-4.
CEDRIC MULLINS, A RARE CAUGHT
STEALING.
SHANE MCCLANAHAN GETS OUT OF THE
FIRST INNING.
A HEADS UP PLAY BY FRANCISCO
MEJIA.
RARE CAUGHT FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
PLENTY MORE, BOTTOM OF THE FIRST
WHEN WE COME BACK.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
>> IT WILL BE A LEFT-HANDER.
>> FASTBALL.
THERE IS A SLOW BREAKING BALL.
STRIKE THREE CALLED.
A BIG CUT AND A MISS.
AND A CUT AND A MISS.
A LITTLE CUTTER THERE.
HE STRIKES OUT CHAPMAN.
10 STRIKES OUT ON THE NIGHT FOR
HILL.
>> A CHOPPER.
THE THROW OVER TO FIRST FROM THE
SEAT OF HIS PANTS.
>> RICH HILL SET TO GO TO WORK.
A CUT AND MISS.
>> GREAT ADJUSTMENT MADE BY
HILL.
HIS CURVEBALL GETS A LOT OF
SWEEPING ACTION AND DEPTH.
HE STARTED IT OFF A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO MULLINS AND WAS ABLE
TO GET THIS.
>> HE'S OVERPOWERED.
AND A CUT AND A MISS.
HE STRIKES OUT THE SIDE.
AND THERE IS A WAV AN -- IS A
WAVE AND MISS.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER 13.
>> IT HAS BEEN IMPRESSIVE WHAT
HE HAS BEEN DOING TONIGHT.
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK OUT.
ORIOLES IN ST. PETERSBURG,
TAKING ON THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
LET'S LOOK AT THE RAYS
LINEUP.
RANDY AROZARENA MOVES INTO THE
LEADOFF SPOT.
VIDAL BRUJAN BATTING SECOND.
WANDER FRANCO, THE NUMBER ONE
PROSPECT, THE CLEANUP MAN THIS
EVENING.
THE CATCHER IS FRANCISCO MEJIA.
JI-MAN CHOI FIRST BASEMAN WILL
BAT SEVENTH.
TAYLOR WALLS BATTING EIGHTH.
KEVIN KIERMAIER, THAT GOLD GLOVE
CENTER FIELDER, ROUNDS OUT ONE
THROUGH NINE FOR THE RAYS.
THEY WILL FACE JOHN MEANS.
AROZARENA ATTACKING FIRST PITCH
FROM MEANS.
HE FOULS IT OFF.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
SARAH: WE HAVE NOT SEEN HIM
PITCH SINCE JUNE 5.
THOSE FIRST FEW STARTS AFTER THE
INJURY WERE NOT AS GOOD, BUT
THIS IS THE TEAM'S ACE.
MELANIE: MEANS COMES INSIDE TO
AROZARENA.
HIS DISCOVERY WAS HE DOES NOT
NEED TO THROW GAS THE WAY
MCCLANAHAN DOES.
HE IS BUILT TO BE A TRADITIONAL
PITCHER.
AROZARENA GETS A HOLD OF A
BREAKING BALL FROM MEANS.
AUSTIN HAYS ON THE RETRIEVAL.
AROZARENA ROUNDING OUT AS HE
HEADS IN FOR SECOND.
A STANDUP DOUBLE.
AROZARENA GETS THE RAYS STARTED
IN A BIG WAY IN THE FIRST.
READING THAT CHANGEUP THAT MEANS
HAS PRIDED HIMSELF ON.
SARAH: AROZARENA HAS KIND OF
STRUGGLED AGAINST NON-FASTBALLS
THIS YEAR.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE HIM JUMP
ON THIS.
MELANIE: HE'S ALREADY PUTTING IT
INTO PLAY FOR YOU.
.310 OFF OF FASTBALLS, .189 OFF
OF NON-FASTBALLS.
SARAH: 110 MILES AN HOUR OFF THE
BAT FROM THAT ONE.
MELANIE: IT IS A LITTLE SMOKED.
SARAH: JUST A BIT.
MELANIE: VIDAL BRUJAN, SWITCH
HITTER FOR THE RAYS.
A SERIES OF SHORTSTOPS THAT ARE
CAPABLE OF PLAYING ANYWHERE
AROUND THE FIELD.
KEVIN CASH HAS SPOKEN HIGHLY
ABOUT THEIR PLAYER DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
JOHN MEANS DELIVERS A FASTBALL.
IT'S ELEVATED INTO FOUL
TERRITORY.
IT WILL LAND INSTEAD IN FRONT OF
HIS TEAMMATES.
SARAH: TO THE POINT OF THE
PLAYER DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM, IT'S
AMAZING TO CALL UP WANDER FRANCO
AND HAVE MORE EXCITING
PROSPECTS.
HE SAW HIS PROSPECT RANKING,
NUMBER 33 ACCORDING TO MLB.COM.
IT IS AMAZING THE COLLECTION OF
PLAYERS THEY HAVE PUT TOGETHER
THROUGH PLAYER DEVELOPMENT.
MELANIE: THE SCARIEST COMMENT
WAS SEEING HOW CONSISTENT THE
RAYS HAVE BUILT THEMSELVES AND
HEARING FROM PEOPLE IN THE
ORGANIZATION, THE TRIPLE A
TALENT IS BETTER.
IT KNOCKS YOU BACK A LITTLE BIT.
SARAH: IT'S SUCH AN EXCITING
GROUP.
MELANIE: JOHN MEANS.
A PITCH DRIVEN OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
IT WILL SPLIT THE DEFENSE.
RANDY AROZARENA FLYING IN.
THE THROW TO SHORT.
RAYS JUMP OUT.
A 1-0 LEAD OFF AN VIDAL BRUJAN
R.B.I.
HE TRADES PLACES WITH RANDY
AROZARENA.
IT'S 1-0 TAMPA BAY.
SARAH: MEANS MAYBE NOT QUITE AS
SHARP.
NOT GETTING AHEAD OF HITTERS THE
WAY WE WOULD EXPECT THUS FAR.
MAYBE IT IS THE RUST COMING
BACK.
MELANIE: YOU SEE THE READ FROM
RANDY AROZARENA.
HE'S CHARGING IN, SLIDING IN.
YESTERDAY HE WENT FACE FIRST.
HE ACTUALLY SLID THROUGH THE
DIRT.
HE LOST SOME SKIN UNDER HIS
NOSE.
THIS TIME KIND OF PROTECTING
HIMSELF.
AUSTIN MEADOWS STARES AT A
FASTBALL STRIKE FROM JOHN MEANS.
JOHN MEANS NOT GOING TO BE AS
SHARP TONIGHT.
WE ASKED BRANDON HYDE, WHERE
THERE HARD LIMITS FOR MEANS?
HE SAID YOU CAN HAVE ONE MILLION
MINOR LEAGUE REHAB APPEARANCES,
BUT IT WILL BE DIFFERENT WHEN
YOU GET BACK TO THE BIGS.
SARAH: HE ALSO MENTIONED, NO
HARD LIMITS, BUT HE WILL KEEP AN
EYE ON INNINGS WITH TRAFFIC.
YOU DO WONDER HOW THIS AFFECTS
HOW MUCH OF JOHN MEANS WE WILL
SEE TODAY.
MELANIE: HE HASN'T BEEN TOO
HAPPY WITH THIS FASTBALL IN HIS
REHAB APPEARANCES.
MEADOWS READS A FASTBALL.
CEDRIC MULLINS HEADING BACK TO
THE TRACK.
OVERHEAD CATCH.
CEDRIC MULLINS, WHAT CAN'T HE
DO?
NOW THE THROW GOES OVER THE TIP
OF THE GLOVE.
AND THE RAYS GET VIDAL BRUJAN ON
TO ADVANCE REGARDLESS.
YOU CAN SEE CEDRIC MULLINS A
LITTLE IRRITATED ON THE PLAY
AFTER HE ABSOLUTELY CHARGED OUT
TO MAKE THAT CATCH.
SARAH: GREAT CATCH BY MULLINS.
ALL OF THE BEST OUTFIELDERS IN
TERMS OF OUTS ABOVE AVERAGE ARE
IN THIS LEAGUE.
SOMETHING THE RAYS DO VERY WELL
IS TAKING EXTRA BASES.
THOSE LITTLE THINGS IN DEFENSE,
ALL THAT BASE RUNNING.
YOU SEE SOME OF THAT HERE.
BRIAN KENNY WOULD BE GLAD TO SEE
THE EXTRA-BASE TAKEN.
I'M THINKING OF HIM.
MELANIE: BRUJAN WITH AN
EXCELLENT READ.
PAY ATTENTION TO THE SMALL
STUFF.
THE RUNNER AT THIRD.
ONE OUT.
WANDER FRANCO WAS SUCH A HIGHLY
ANTICIPATED PROSPECT.
RATED NUMBER ONE OVERALL.
THE VIDEO OF HIM ARRIVING AT THE
PARK, I THINK HE WAS IN A
ROLLS-ROYCE.
IT WAS LIKE BIG PAPI WAS
WHEELING HIMSELF INTO THE
BALLPARK, BUT HE'S DESERVED IT.
HE'S GOT A FASTBALL.
A DRIVE RIGHT TO ANTHONY
SANTANDER.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE IS NOT
IN TIME.
VIDAL BRUJAN, IT'S 2-0 RAYS.
SARAH: THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT
THE BEST CASE SCENARIO THAT THE
ORIOLES FANS WANTED TO SEE FROM
JOHN MEANS.
HOPEFULLY HE CAN SETTLE DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
ONLY 11 PITCHES SO FAR.
WE WERE EXPECTING SOME SORT OF
RUSTING US, EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
OK -- OF RUSTINESS, EVEN THOUGH
HE WAS OK IN HIS MINOR LEAGUE
REHAB STARTS.
MELANIE: IT IS A FRESH BULLPEN
FOR BALTIMORE.
MEAANS DOES HAVE SUPPORT BEHIND
HIM.
-- MEANS DOES HAVE SUPPORT
BEHIND HIM.
BRANDON LOWE, WHO HAS BEEN
PICKING THINGS UP LATELY,
BATTING JUST .211.
HE HAS A CAREER-HIGH 21 HOME
RUNS THIS YEAR.
SARAH: HE'S REALLY BEEN HITTING
BETTER LATELY.
WE ASKED KEVIN CASH ABOUT THAT.
HE SAID HE'S NOT REALLY SEEING
ANYTHING DIFFERENT, THAT THE
DIFFERENCE HAS BEEN MAKING
BETTER CONTACT ON THE SWINGS HE
HAS BEEN TAKING.
I DID NOT GET A CHANCE TO DIG
INTO THE STATCAST, BUT IT IS
INTERESTING THAT MAYBE HE NEEDED
TO STAY WITH HIS APPROACH AND
IT'S FINALLY STARTING TO PAY OFF
FOR HIM AGAIN.
MELANIE: A LOT OF
INTERCONNECTIONS BETWEEN THESE
TEAMS.
LOWE A PRODUCT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF MARYLAND.
MEANS WORKS BACK INTO THE COUNT.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS NUMBERS.
THAT FIRST 53 LAST 33 SPLIT.
FINDING A WAY TO GET LOCKED IN.
SARAH: IT'S INTERESTING, BECAUSE
THAT FIRST 53 INCLUDES THAT
GREAT MAY.
THAT INCLUDES THE TIME WHEN THE
TEAM WAS PLAYING PRETTY WELL.
HE WAS NOT NECESSARILY THE
DRIVING FORCE OFFENSIVELY THERE,
WHEREAS THOSE LAST 33 IS MUCH
MORE RECENTLY.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN PLAYING QUITE
AS WELL.
I THINK HE IS A PLAYER THEY CAN
USE TO STEADY THIS OFFENSE
POTENTIALLY.
MELANIE: HE READS A FASTBALL.
MULLINS PLAYS IT OFF THE WALL.
LOWE COMES IN WITH A STANDOFF
DOUBLE.
IT HAS BEEN AN EXTRA-BASE PARADE
FOR THE RAYS IN THE FIRST.
SARAH: THAT IS A 400 PLUS FOOT
DOUBLE.
WELL HIT FOR SURE, 105.6 MILES
PER HOUR OFF THE BAT.
WE ALREADY HAD FOUR HARD HIT
BALLS OFF JOHN MEANS.
IN LOOKING TO SEE WHETHER HE IS
FULLY BACK, THAT IS SOMETHING WE
CAN ASSESS.
HE'S USUALLY NOT GIVING UP THIS
KIND OF HARD CONTACT.
THAT IS SOMETHING HE CHANGED
THIS YEAR.
NOT THE CASE SO FAR IN THIS
FIRST INNING.
MELANIE:-- THREE OUT OF FIVE BAS
HAVE HAD A FIRST PITCH STRIKE
FROM MEANS.
SARAH: HIS NORMAL RATE IS 73% OR
SO.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE.
MELANIE: YEAH.
FIRST PITCH ON THE CURVE.
IT'S RIGHT INTO THE GLOVE OF
ANTHONPLENTY MORE WHEN WE COME .
MLB'S GAME OF THE WEEK ON
YOUTUBE BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
♪
>> TIMEOUT CASTLE.
PLAYING FIRST BASE TODAY.
RIGHT FIELD.
THIS WILL GET DOWN.
FOUL BALL FROM AROZARENA.
A LONG WAY AWAY.
>> AUSTIN HAYS.
TOP SIDE THE LINEUP.
CENTER FIELD.
KIERMAIER CLOSES.
HE GOT IT.
KIERMAIER REACHING DOWN ON THE
TURF FOR THE LITTLE SLIDE.
>> MALINKE INTO CENTER FIELD.
DOWN TO BASE.
SCORING AT LEAST ONE.
HERE'S HERE YES.
SECOND BASE BEHIND THE PLATE.
TWO RUN SINGLE.
JUST HIS SECOND WILL PIE R.B.I.
GAME OF 2021 AND HE MIGHT SCORE
HERE.
GUTIERREZ SINGLED.
AROZARENA SOWS.
SEVEN SINGLES.
THIS IS INTO RIGHT FIELD FOR THE
A'S.
THAT'S A FAIR BALL.
>> ORIOLES BULLPEN.
GREAT SHAPE.
>> FASTBALL.
GOT HIM LOOKING.
STRIKEOUT NUMBER SIX.
WATKINS IS THROUGH.
SIX INNINGS OF ONE RUN BALL
AGAINST THE DEFENDING AMERICAN
LEAGUE CHAMPS.
♪
MELANIE: WE WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO GIVE A TIP OF THE CAP TO THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE COME BEFORE US.
GAIL ROBIN, LESLIE VISSER, SO
MANY ABSOLUTE PILLARS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
YOU CAN'T OVERLOOK ANDREA KRAMER
AS WELL.
WE CAUGHT TO DISCUSS HER
THURSDAY NIGHT APPEARANCE WITH
HANNAH STORM EARLIER TODAY.
AND SUZYN WALDMAN, A FACE ACROSS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
JESSICA MENDOZA CURRENTLY OUT IN
TOKYO, GETTING READY TO COVER
THE OLYMPICS.
FOR ALL OF THE WOMEN WHO ARE OUT
THERE COVERING THE GAME FOR US
THAT OPENED UP THE DOOR FOR
MYSELF, SARAH, AND ALANA, JUST
REALLY AN AWESOME DAY.
SARAH: IT HAS BEEN SO GREAT TO
BE A PART OF THIS.
SO GREAT TO HEAR THE ENERGY THAT
WE HAVE GOTTEN.
SO MANY POSITIVE VIBES.
THIS IS IN THE LAST.
WE ARE STARTING AT AND THIS IS
WHERE WE GO FROM HERE.
MELANIE: ALANA, FOR YOU --
ALANNA: THE BIGGEST THING IS
THAT WE WERE THE FIVE THAT WERE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE CHOSEN TO DO
THIS BROADCAST.
THERE ARE SO MANY MORE WOMEN YOU
HAVE TO -- BEEN DOING WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING FOR SO LONG.
SO MANY WOMEN COULD DO THIS
BROADCAST.
HAPPY TO BE A PART OF IT.
WE RECOGNIZE THE MOMENT.
ABOVE ALL, IT'S BASEBALL.
WE ARE HAPPY TO BE GIVING THIS
BROADCAST TO THE AUDIENCE.
MELANIE: YOU SAID IT BEST.
I THE END OF THE DAY, YOU GET
THE FIRST PITCH AND IT'S A
BASEBALL GAME.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE LOVED,
GETTING TO PURSUE IT IN OUR
CAREERS.
RECOGNIZING THAT IT ALWAYS
HASN'T BEEN THE CASE FOR OTHERS.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
CHANGE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE STIGMA THAT
HAS TO BE DISCUSSED FOR SO MUCH
LONGER.
SARAH: I THINK THAT IF WE CAN
CHANGE THE MIND OR OPEN UP AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A YOUNG LADY OR
ANY YOUNG PERSON OUT THERE,
WHETHER IT'S GENDER, RACE,
CREED, RELIGION, SEXUAL
ORIENTATION, IF WE CAN SHOW THEM
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE, WE'VE DONE
OUR JOB.
MELANIE: I COULD NOT AGREE MORE.
MCCLANAHAN PICKS UP A STRIKE UP.
BLISTERING 99.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO SEE
FROM HIM, ESPECIALLY WITH HIM
BEING THERE.
MOUNTCASTLE IS AN INTERESTING
ONE.
WE'VE SEEN HIM GET SOME HITS.
NOT TODAY.
NOT RIGHT NOW.
MELANIE: WE TALK ABOUT BULLPEN
SET UPS THE TIME.
ONE ARM AND A VERY DIFFERENT ARM
AFTER.
MCCLANAHAN DELIVERS TO ANTHONY
SANTANDER.
FIRST PITCH DRIVE OUT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
READ ALLOW BACK.
SANTANDER AROUND FIRST.
HE SETTING AND FOR SECOND.
THE ORIOLES WITH A DOUBLE OF
THEIR OWN.
EXTRA-BASE HIT.
ANTHONY SANTANDER WAS HITLESS IN
LAST NIGHT'S GAME.
THE SECOND KNOCK OF THE BALLGAME
FOR THE ORIOLES.
THEY TRY TO COME BACK FROM THAT
2-0 DEFICIT.
SARAH: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
OUTFIELD DEFENSE.
BASEBALLS HEADING OVER
OUTFIELDERS HEADS.
NOT THAT THIS WAS CATCHABLE.
JUST A FUNNY STORYLINE ALREADY.
MELANIE: SANTON THERE HAS BEEN
COMING INTO FORM.
HE HAD ABOUT A GO FOR A WHILE
THAT AFFECTED HIS BATTING STANCE
AND SPEED.
IT'S ON DISPLAY IN EVERY SENSE
OF IT RIGHT THERE.
UP IS RAMON ARIAS.
FASTBALL.
YOU STACK BULLPEN RELIEVERS
AGAINST EACH OTHER WHEN THEY
COME INTO THE GAME SO THAT THEY
ARE DIFFERENT, SO THAT THE
BATTERS ARE THROWN OFF.
HOW IS IT WHEN YOU SEE STARTERS
THAT ARE SO DIFFERENT?
FROM YARBROUGH WHO'S A SOFT TOSS
OR TO A SHANE MCCLANAHAN.
TEAMS GET THE BOOKS.
IT IS STILL DIFFERENT TO ADJUST
ON THAT DAY-TO-DAY.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S ANOTHER REASON THAT THIS
PITCHING STAFF IS SO SUCCESSFUL.
THE DIFFERENCE IN THEIR STARTERS
, MICHAEL WACHA WITH THE
SECOND-FASTEST AVERAGE FASTBALL
VELOCITY.
THIS IS WITH TYLER GLASNOW OUT.
THAT'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
FROM DAY-TO-DAY, PREPARING FOR
THAT IS NOT EASY.
MELANIE: HE ROSE ONE ON THE
GROUND AND TOSSES ACROSS TO
JI-MAN CHOI.
THEY WILL HOLD SANTANDER AT
SECOND.
UREAS RETIRES.
TWO DOWN.
ORIOLES TRYING TO ANSWER TAMPA
BAY EARLY AFTER THE RAYS JUMPED
OUT AGAINST JOHN MEANS.
HIS FIRST START BACK.
IN COMES BIRTHDAY BOY, PEDRO
SEVERINO.
A COUPLE WORDS TO FRANCISCO
MEJIA.
ZERO FOR FOUR YESTERDAY.
SOMEBODY WHO WE GOT TO DISCUSS
WITH THE STAFF EARLIER TODAY,
HOW HE HAS COME INTO FORM AFTER
BEING A CATCHER FOR THE
ESTABLISHED NATIONAL STARTERS.
STRASBURG AND SCHERZER WILL TELL
YOU WHAT TO THROW.
SEVERINO HAD TO LEARN HOW TO
COMMAND YOUNG PITCHERS AND TELL
THEM WHAT TO THROW.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S NOT EASY.
IT'S A DIFFERENT JOB DEPENDING
ON THAT TENURE OF THE PITCHING
STAFF AND EXACTLY WHO YOU'RE
DEALING WITH.
THAT REALLY CHANGE THE CHARACTER
OF EXACTLY WHO WAS IN THIS.
MELANIE: BREAKING BALL GETS
UNDERNEATH ME HE HAS.
SANTANDER ADVANCES.
SARAH: IT'S INTERESTING.
BRANDON HYDE WAS SAYING HOW
SEVERINO'S DEFENSE HAS NOT BEEN
GREAT.
HE IS HIT A LITTLE BETTER
LATELY.
HE WAS CONNECTING THE TWO.
HIS OFFENSE WASN'T GREAT WHEN
HIS DEFENSE WASN'T GREAT.
PUTTING IT ALL TOGETHER AT ONCE.
THOSE ARE COMPLETE LEAD
DIFFERENT SKILLS.
MELANIE: FRANCIS, HE COMING IN
BEHIND MIKE ZUNINO WHILE HE IS
STILL OUT.
HE TWEAKED HIS HIP A LITTLE BIT
TRYING TO RUN OUT A GROUND BALL
YESTERDAY.
SEVERINO.
LINE DRIVE INTO LEFT FIELD.
BASE HIT.
SANTANDER SCORES EASILY.
ORIOLES ANSWER.
THEY CUT THE LEAD TO-ONE IN THE
SECOND.
SARAH: I SHOULD TAKE BACK MY
COMMENT ABOUT A LOW-SCORING
GAME, RIGHT?
MELANIE: THE ODDSMAKERS HEARD
WHAT YOU WERE SAYING.
SARAH: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
MUST'VE HAPPENED.
I LOVE THAT.
ESPECIALLY ON THE BIRTHDAY.
GLAD TO SEE A BIRTHDAY BOY
R.B.I..
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SLIDER AND THE READ THAT
SEVERINO HAD ON IT.
NO DAYS OFF CHAIN AROUND HIS
NECK.
THE LINK IN.
HE BROKE IT -- A ZERO FOR 16
SKID.
HE SAID, I'M NOT GOING TO LIE TO
YOU.
IT'S A CHALLENGING SEASON.
HE DEALT WITH THE LOSS OF HIS
FATHER-IN-LAW.
HE DEDICATED THE SEASON TO HIM.
THAT GUY HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
UTILITYMAN FOR THE ORIOLES.
2-1 TAMPA BAY IN THE SECOND.
AS YOU SAID, THEY ARE TRYING TO
PUT THE RUNS ON AGAINST YOU
RIGHT NOW.
SARAH: THEY ARE.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING.
WITH MCCLANAHAN, THERE IS THAT
ELEMENT.
HE'S A YOUNG PITCHER WHO'S
LOOKING FOR MORE RAW SPOTS
ABILITY OTHER THAN THE
DAY-TO-DAY.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE HIM
DEALING WITH THIS.
WE WILL SEE HOW DEEP HE GOES
INTO THIS GAME.
IT'S THAT TYPE OF ADVERSITY THAT
THE FINES WHO YOU ARE GOING TO
BE.
YOU EXPECT A VETERAN PITCHER TO
BATTLE BACK IN THIS INNING.
WE WILL SEE WHERE HANDS UP ON
THAT.
MELANIE: I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED
WITH MCCLANAHAN SO FAR.
A SLEW AFFORDING PERFORMANCES.
HE HAS STRETCH THOSE FIVE AND
SIX SO FAR.
HE SAID LAST YEAR AT THE
ULTIMATE SITE, IT WAS LIKE
PLAYING IN AN ALL-STAR GAME
EVERY DAY.
SARAH: THAT'S THAT GREAT FARM
SYSTEM YOU WERE REFERRING TO.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S A HISTORICAL NOTE BUT HE'S
MADE HIS MAJOR LEAGUE DEBUT IN
THE PLAYOFFS LAST YEAR.
IT ONLY HAPPENS THREE TIMES
BEFORE LAST YEAR.
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES, IT WAS A
DIFFERENT SET UP.
REALLY INTERESTING TO THINK
ABOUT THAT MINDSET.
MELANIE: IT IS.
IT'S ONE THAT YOU WISH YOU COULD
CRACK OPEN AND READ FOR
YOURSELF.
THE LINK A DRAWS A WALK.
IT WILL ADVANCE SEVERINO TO
SECOND BASE.
THE ORIOLES COOKING HERE WITH
TWO OUTS IN THE SECOND INNING.
TAKE A PAUSE HERE FOR A MOUND
FISH IT.
MCCLANAHAN HAVING TO STEP UP
AFTER CHARLIE MORTON OPTION WAS
NOT EXERCISED.
THEY DEALT BLAKE SNELL TO SAN
DIEGO.
TYLER GLASNOW IS NOT -- STILL
NOT WORKING OFF OF THE INJURED
LIST.
SOME ROOKIES HAVE ABSOLUTELY
STEPPED UP TO THE CAUSE.
LOOK THERE.
MANAGER KEVIN CASH.
HE HAS EARNED THAT COIN OF BEING
A PLAYERS MANAGER.
THE GUY THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY
RALLY AROUND.
HE BECAME FAMOUS LAST YEAR
TALKING ABOUT HIS GUYS IN THE
STABLE WHO ALL THROW 98.
THEY'VE BEEN IN THE HUNT FOR THE
POSTSEASON MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
WITH CASH.
FIRST PITCH TO GALVAN GUTIERREZ.
IT'S A STRIKE.
THIS IS THE ONLY BATTER IN THE
LINEUP WHO HAS ANY PRIOR TIME
SEEING SHAME HANRAHAN.
THAT WAS BEFORE HE BECAME A PART
OF THE ORIOLES ORGANIZATION FROM
KANSAS CITY.
SARAH: THAT'S FASCINATING.
THAT'S ANOTHER INTERESTING
WILD-CARD COME FACING A GUY
WHO'S A ROOKIE LIKE THIS.
HAS GOTTEN SUCH LITTLE
EXPERIENCE OVERALL.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HE MIGHT HAVE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THAT.
98-99.
IT'S NOT EASY TO TAKE THAT.
MELANIE: WHEN A PITCH COMES IN,
GUTIERREZ WOULD ARGUE THAT IT
HIT HIS CLEAT.
HE WINS THE ARGUMENT.
A SINGLE WALK AND A HIT BY
PITCH.
BASES LOADED BY SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
TWO OUTS IN THE SECOND.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO FEEL GOOD
FOR ANYBODY.
NOT ONLY DID IT SKIM THE FOUGHT
-- GUTIERREZ FOOT, IT CAME OFF
OF HIS MASK.
SARAH: CEDRIC MULLINS IS PRETTY
GOOD IN HIS CAREER WITH BASES
LOADED.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE
LOT OF PLAY DIFFERENTIALS.
14 PLATE APPEARANCES.
WE WILL TAKE IT.
PRETTY GOOD AVERAGE.
MELANIE: HE TAKES AFTER AN
OFFSPEED.
WE HEARD THAT YOU GOT THE SCOOP
ON GLASNOW EARLIER TODAY.
ALANNA: WHEN I WAS HERE, TYLER
GLASNOW WAS THROWING NL SCREEN
DURING THE PREGAME ROUTINE.
I TALKED TO KEVIN CASH ABOUT IT
IN TERMS OF WHEN HE'S GOING TO
COME BACK.
HE SAID THAT THERE IS NO
DEFINITIVE TIME.
IT TAKES TILL THE END OF THE
MONTH TO GET HIM THROWING OFF OF
THE MOUND.
THE INFLAMMATION IS DOWN.
I ASKED HIM, DO YOU HAVE TO SAVE
TYLER FROM HIMSELF?
WHEN HE WAS WALKING BY ME, HE
SAID, I WISH I COULD BE OUT
THERE TONIGHT.
KEVIN CASH LAUGHED.
HE SAID, I WISH YOU COULD BE OUT
THERE TONIGHT AS WELL.
HE APPRECIATES THE HONESTY.
THE ISSUE AGAINST THE WHITE SOX.
THEY ARE FEARING -- BEING VERY
CAUTIOUS WITH THEIR ACE.
MELANIE: IT SEEMS TO BE ON THE
OPPOSITE THERE.
LOOK AT THIS PITCH HERE.
THE WORD WITH JACOB DEGROM IS
HOW HE HIDES HIS INJURIES.
GLASNOW HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT.
MCCLANAHAN OUTSIDE AND 99.
MULLINS HAVE -- HAS EVEN THE
COUNT.
MULLINS HAD THE DAY OFF FROM
YESTERDAY'S GAME.
HIS MANAGER JUST TRIED TO MAKE
UP FOR THE FACT THAT HE DIDN'T
HAVE AN ALL-STAR BREAK.
THE POOR.
SARAH: YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE GOT A PRETTY GOOD THING
INSTEAD.
MELANIE: HE ABSOLUTELY DID.
HE STAYS ALIVE, FOULING OFF TO
THE OFFERING FROM MCCLANAHAN.
TAKE A LOOK HERE.
THE REASON WHY HE STARTED TO
EXCEL.
THIS IS HIS CAREER AS A
LEFT-HANDER.
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED PITCHERS.
.311 AVERAGE.
PRIOR TO THAT, THE NUMBERS WERE
PLUMMETING.
HE SWITCHED THIS YEAR TO BEING
LEFT-HANDED ONLY.
THOSE ARE ALL NUMBERS FROM THE
RIGHT SIDE PRIOR.
HE GETS MULLINS TO CHASE AN
ELEVATED FASTBALL.
MCCLANAHAN IS LIVING ON IT.
ORIOLES CUT THE LEAD IN HALF.
TO JOHN MEANS TO
HOLD IT DOWN AS HIS REHAB
CONTINUES.
YOU ARE WATCHING ORIOLES ANDRES
-- AND RAYS ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> AND SINE SWINGS AND GROUNDS
IT PAST THE DIVE.
EVERS.
>> NICE TURN FOR TREY.
HIS FIRST HIT SINCE 2019.
>> SWINGS AND DRIVES ONE TO DEEP
RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
GOODBYE.
OIL PARK AND CAMDEN YARDS IS
GOING BANANAS.
MANCINI'S FIRST HOME RUN OF THE
YEAR COMES IN FRONT OF THE HOME
FAITHFUL.
>> CENTER FIELD.
LAGARES BACK.
TREY MANCINI SENDS IT ONTO THE
BERM BE ON CENTERFIELD WALL.
>> FLY BALL.
DEEP RIGHT CENTER.
THIS IS WAY BACK AND WAY GONE.
, ON THE FLY.
THE ORIOLES BULLPEN, ABSOLUTE
PRESSURE FROM TREY MANCINI.
HIS EIGHTH HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON.
THE ORIOLES ARE LOUDLY INTO THE
LEAD.
1-0 IN THE FIRST.
>> HI FALL -- HIGHBALL DEEP INTO
CENTER.
IT'S GONE.
TREY MANCINI.
THE BATTERS UP.
431 FEET.
6-3 BIRDS IN THE FIFTH.
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK HERE AT
SOME BREAKOUT PERFORMERS TAKING
OVER MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
DAVID FLETCHER, ADAM FRAZIER,
ADOLIS GARCIA, CEDRIC MULLINS.
ALL HANGING OUT THERE AND HAVING
A BLAST.
TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
RESPECTIVELY KIDS.
LEADERS IN FLETCHER AND FRASER.
GARCIA AND MULLINS ARE NOT FAR
BEHIND.
THE FIRST FAN POLE OF THE
EVENING.
WHO IS YOUR OFFENSE BREAKOUT
PLAYER OF THE YEAR?
FLETCHER, GARCIA, FRAZIER, OR
MULLINS?
I'M NOT ALLOWED TO VOTE.
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO PUT IN
WHAT THEY'VE GOT GOING ON IN
THEIR HEADS RIGHT NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
REALLY COOL PLAYERS STEPPING UP
IN A BIG WAY THIS YEAR.
JOHN MEANS COME HOME.
FIRST STRIKE TO JI-MAN CHOI.
SARAH: IF HE CAN START GETTING
BACK TO THOSE, IT'S ONLY TWO
RUNS.
HE COULD STILL PUT TOGETHER A
GOOD START AND PUT THAT INTO
THAT -- GET INTO THAT RANGE.
MELANIE: HE REACHED 70 PITCHES
WITH AAA NOR FOLK.
TOOK HIM 113 FOR HIS COMPLETE
GAME NO-HIT PERFORMANCE AGAINST
THE MARINERS.
CHOICE SWINGS AND POP THIS ONE
OUT PAST THIRD BASE.
TEAR IS IN SEVERINO.
GUTIERREZ WITH THE POP-UP CATCH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ORIOLES
KEYS TO THE GAME AGAINST THE
RAYS THIS EVENING.
SARAH: A LOT OF THESE ARE GOING
TO BE ABOUT JOHN MEANS.
THAT FIRST PITCH STRIKE.
HE LEADS ALL STARTING PITCHERS
IN FIRST PITCH STRIKE RATE.
WE SEEN A HANDFUL TODAY BUT
NODDED HIS NORMAL RATE.
WE WILL SEE IF HE CAN GET BACK
INTO THAT.
HOW MUCH LENGTH ARE THEY GOING
TO GET FROM HIM?
THE ORIOLES HAVE THE FISTS --
FIFTH WORST BULLPEN E.R.A..
THEIR BULLPEN HAS BEEN TAXED BUT
NOT LATELY.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT CAN ACTUALLY
GET DEEP ENOUGH FOR THEM.
CONTRIBUTIONS UP AND DOWN THE
ORDER.
DURING THE WINNING STREAK, 11
DIFFERENT ORIOLES PLAYERS HAVE
AT LEAST ONE R.B.I..
NOBODY HAS MORE THAN FOUR SO
IT'S BEEN A TEAM EFFORT.
INTERESTED TO SEE IF THAT CAN
CONTINUE.
MELANIE: YOU KNOW, YOU DO GOOD
WORK WHEN THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
TO ADD TO THAT.
SO SPOT ON.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SHORTSTOP
PROSPECTS.
THIS IS ANOTHER ONE FOR THE
RAYS.
HE GOES AFTER THE OFFERING FROM
MEANS AND FALLS BEHIND.
THE SWITCH HITTER, A ZERO FOR
EIGHT RIGHT NOW.
ROOKIES HAVE TO HAVE TIME TO
REALLY FIND THEIR FEET.
HE IS STILL BATTING .224.
SARAH: WHEN THE RAYS WENT AND
TRADED WILLY ADAMES, TAYLOR
WALLS WAS CALLED UP IN HIS
PLACE.
EVERYBODY WAS EXPECTING THIS WAS
WANDER FRANCO TIME.
IT WASN'T QUITE YET.
EVERYBODY WHO COVERS PROSPECTS,
PEOPLE WHO KNOW THAT WERE
SAYING, DON'T BE DISAPPOINTED
THAT IT'S NOT WANDER FRANCO YET.
TAYLOR WALLS IS A FUN PROSPECT.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THAT HE'S WITH
THE TEAM AND GETTING A CHANCE TO
PLAY.
MELANIE: JOHN MEANS PICKS UP A
BIG STRIKEOUT OF TAYLOR WALLS,
HIS FIRST BACK IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
THE FIRST TWO IN THE SECOND
RETIRED.
BEAUTIFUL BREAKING BALL.
MALLS CHASING AFTER A SLIDER.
FOR MEANS, MIXING AND THAT
FASTBALL CHANGE CURVE AND
SLIDER.
HE GETS KIERMAIER AFTER THE
FIRST PITCH.
YET AGAIN, ALL THREE BATTERS
HE'S FACED IN THE SECOND, FIRST
PITCH STRIKE.
SARAH: WE'VE GOT THE PITCH
SEQUENCE UP THERE FOR YOU.
THIS HAS STARTED ME ON A LOT OF
PROSPECTS.
I LOVE THAT WE CAN SEE THIS AND
KEEP TRACK OF THIS.
WE ARE HERE TRYING TO WRITE
THINGS DOWN AND KEEP TRACK OF
THINGS.
I LOVE THAT YOU CAN BE SITTING
AT HOME AND SEEING THE VELO.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO LEARN HOW
TO PICK THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
UP, WHICH PEOPLE TRY TO DO, THIS
BROADCAST GIVES YOU A CHANCE TO
MATCH WHAT YOUR SKIN TO WHAT THE
ANSWER IS.
MELANIE: IT'S ONE OF THOSE.
I'VE GIVEN YOU SO MUCH CREDIT
BECAUSE YOU BRING THOSE REALLY
FAR DEVELOPED NUMBERS AND MAKE
THEM TANGIBLE FOR EVERYBODY EVEN
IF THERE A NEWCOMER TO THE GAME.
OF ALL THE NEW THINGS WE'VE
INTRODUCED, THIS IS ONE OF THE
EASIEST TO GRASP.
KIERMAIER SENDS A BALL TO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT'S A 1-2-3 INNING.
ANTHONY SANTANDER WITH THE
CATC MEANS IS CLEAN.
2-1 TAMPA.
WE WILL BE BACK WITH THE THIRD
ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> ALONG ONE.
HIGH AND DEEP.
OUT OF HERE.
HOME RUN FOR AUSTIN MEADOWS.
THE RAYS GET THE LEAD.
TOP OF THE INNING.
ONE SWING OF THE BAT FOR MEADOWS
GIVES THE RAYS THE LEAD.
>> THAT WAS ME GETTING HERE.
>> THAT WILL BE COP I MEADOWS.
-- CAUGHT BY MEADOWS.
MEADOWS COMING IN TO THE RIGHT.
GOES DOWN AND GRABS THAT ONE TO
RETIRE HEDGES.
THERE'S A SHOT, WELL TAGGED.
INTO RIGHT AND THAT BABY IS
GOING TO GET OUT OF HERE.
HOME ROSS -- HOME RUN FOR AUSTIN
MEADOWS.
THE RAYS GRAB THE LEAD HERE IN
THE FIRST INNING.
15TH HOME RUN OF THE YEAR.
THAT WILL GIVE HIM AN EVEN 50
RUNS BATTED IN.
THAT'S GOING TO GO.
HOME RUN FOR AUSTIN MEADOWS.
MEADOWS STAYS HOT AND LINES IT
OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> [CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
-- >> [INAUDIBLE]
ALANNA: AUSTIN HAYS PLAYING
AROUND WITH ANTHONY SANTANDER.
20 TATERS.
HE GOT SOME GOOD ADVICE BEFORE
THAT AT BAT THAT WORKED OUT
REALLY WELL FOR HIM, IT SEEMS
LIKE.
MAYBE WE SHOULD GIVE CREDIT TO
AUSTIN HAYS.
SARAH: THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
I LOVE ABOUT WHEN WE MAKE UP
PLAYERS.
WE LEARN WHO THOSE IN DUGOUT
COACHES ARE.
YOU FIND OUT ABOUT THOSE
MOMENTS.
I LOVE THIS.
MELANIE: THE HITTING COACH NOW
AT THE PLATE.
AUSTIN HAYS.
HE TAKES THE STRIKE FROM SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
MCCLANAHAN GAVE UP THE LEADOFF
HIT TO CENTER COLONS IN THE
FIRST, SETTLED DOWN, RAN INTO IT
WITH THE ORIOLES IN THE SECOND.
GOT OUT OF A BASES-LOADED JAM.
WORKING OFFSPEED TO HAYES.
HE PUTS HIM BACK IN THE 0-2
COUNT.
JUST TO SAVE GAVE ADVICE ABOUT
MCCLANAHAN.
HE TOOK ADVICE FROM CENTER
COLONS AS WELL.
HAYES WAS ON AN INJURED LIST
EARLIER THIS YEAR VERY BRIEFLY
WHEN HE CAME BACK AND COULD NOT
GET INTO THE GROOVE.
CEDRIC TOLD HIM, SLOW DOWN.
SLOW DOWN THE GAME FOR YOUR
SELF.
ANOTHER FOUL BALL OFF OF
MCCLANAHAN.
SARAH: THAT SEEMS LIKE GREAT
ADVICE FOR ANYTHING.
CERTAINLY BASEBALL.
A LOT OF TIMES, A PLAYER FINDING
THEIR WAY IS WHAT YOU HEAR.
I HEARD SOMETHING THE OTHER DAY.
I THINK IT WAS KEVIN CASH.
THAT'S WHAT VAUGHN JUNIOR DID
WHEN HE WAS, HOW HE HAS GOT TO
THE POINT HE IS NOW.
THE TRIPLE CROWN CONTENDER AFTER
HIS FIRST TWO YEARS NOT QUITE AT
THE SAME TOP PROSPECT LEVEL.
MELANIE: HAYES CALLS TIME AND HE
WILL TAKE A SWEEP OF DIRT IN
BETWEEN HIS HANDS.
HE DOESN'T BAT WITH BATTING
GLOVES.
THEY ARE TWO OF 11 PLAYERS WHO
DON'T.
WHEN HAYES WAS A LITTLE LEAGUER,
HE RIPPED THROUGH GLOVES SO
OFTEN HE TOLD HIS MOM, STOP
SPENDING YOUR MONEY.
HE LEARNED HOW TO BAT WITHOUT
THEM.
FASTBALL SALES AND HIGH.
WHAT A GREAT KID.
HEY MOM, I'M TEARING UP MY
GLOVES.
I'M JUST NOT GOING TO DO IT.
SARAH: I LOVE THAT.
HOW MANY LITTLE KIDS HAVE THAT
KIND OF FORESIGHT?
HELP THE PARENTS OUT.
IT'S COOL.
WE DON'T SEE MANY GUYS DO THAT
THESE DAYS, AS YOU MENTIONED.
MELANIE: MCCLANAHAN.
HAYES RIPS A BREAKING BALL FOUL.
COMING UP IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
THIRD, RICH HILL IS GOING TO
JOIN US LIVE DURING THE GAME.
VERY INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT HE
HAS TO SAY ABOUT THE CLUB THIS
YEAR.
1-2.
HAYES GETS A HOLD OF IT BUT IT'S
A SHARP BOUNCE TO CHOI.
HE THROWS IT TO MCCLANAHAN BUT
IT'S NOT IN TIME.
HE'S BEATS IT OUT.
CHOI GOT PRETZEL BETWEEN HIMSELF
TRYING TO COME UP WITH A SHORT
SHOP FROM HAYES.
SHARP BOUNCE.
PIN BAWLING AROUND BETWEEN HIS
LEGS.
MCCLANAHAN TRYING TO COME OVER.
THE TEAM EFFORT TO BEAT HAYES.
THAT'S A BANG-BANG PLAY RACE.
SARAH: I'M STARING AT MY
COMPUTER WAITING TO TELL YOU.
FIRST THING I THINK WHEN I SEE A
PLAY LIKE THAT.
MELANIE: HAYES IS KNOWN FOR THE
SPEED.
ORIOLES HAVE SEVERAL WITH SOME
PRETTY GOOD FEET UNDERNEATH
THEM.
SARAH: 28.3 FEET PER SECOND.
MELANIE: I'M TIRED ALREADY.
SARAH: 27 HIS MAJOR LEAGUE
AVERAGE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT WERE
DEALING WITH.
30 IS THE REALLY ELITE.
WHEN YOU GET ABOVE THAT 27, I'M
IMPRESSED BY THE NUMBERS.
ESPECIALLY ON A PLAY LIKE THAT.
MELANIE: TREY MANCINI STANDS IN.
LET'S TAKE ANOTHER LOOK HERE.
AUSTIN HAYS FLASHING THE DAD
SPEED.
MCCLANAHAN COMING OFF OF THE
RAGA AND.
JUST A LATE BREAK COMING INTO
BACK IT UP, JI-MAN CHOI ON THE
PLATE.
HE WAS A LATE ADDITION TO THE
ROSTER TODAY.
90 DIAZ WAS ORIGINALLY THE FIRST
BASEMAN THIS EVENING.
HE WAS SCRATCHED WITH NEXT
PLASM'S.
JI-MAN CHOI STANDS IN INSTEAD.
SARAH: JI-MAN CHOI IS SUCH A FUN
PLAYER.
I KNOW HE'S NOT BATTING RIGHT
NOW.
HE HIT A HOME RUN LAST YEAR CAP
-- BATTING FROM THE OPPOSITE
SIDE.
HE BECAME THE FIRST GUY TO TAKE
AS MANY PLATE APPEARANCES FROM
ONE SIDE AND DO THAT FROM THE
OTHER SIDE.
THESE ARE THE FUN THINGS IN
BASEBALL FOR ME.
MELANIE: I'LL NEVER FORGET,
THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL MOMENTS
HE'S HAD WITH THE RAYS.
IT'S NO LONGER JUST ONE.
THE WALKOFF SITUATIONS, THE JOY
THAT HE EMULATES FROM HIS ENTIRE
BODY.
YOU CAN'T NOT SMILE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT, WHETHER IT'S A
REPLAY OR STILL PHOTO.
HE REALLY LOVES BEING A PART OF
THE CLUB.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
I'M THINKING OF BRETT PHILLIPS.
THIS TEAM HAS A TON.
FOR ALL THEY DO WITH SCOUTING
AND PLAYER DEVELOPMENT, THEY
SEEM TO HAVE REALLY PERFECTED
ACQUIRING THAT JOY AS WELL.
THAT'S NOT A QUANTIFIABLE THING
OR IT STAT.
THEY HAVE A TON OF THAT.
IS BEEN FUN TO SEE THEM IN
POSTSEASON SITUATIONS LATELY.
MELANIE: MANCINI FINDS THE GAP.
HE DRILLS THIS ONE INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
BASE HIT.
HAYES HOLDS UP AT SECOND.
THE ORIOLES FINDING ANSWERS OFF
OF SHANE MCCLANAHAN HERE IN THE
THIRD.
SARAH: 101 MILES PER HOUR OFF OF
THE BAT.
GOOD CONTACT.
ANYTHING 95 PLUS IS GOING TO BE
HARD HIT.
YOU'VE SEEN A HANDFUL OF THOSE
FROM BOTH SIDES ALREADY.
MELANIE: HAYES GETS JUST BEHIND
THAT DRIVE INTO RIGHT.
HAYES REACHES.
MANCINI SINGLES.
RUNNERS ON FIRST AND SECOND.
NOBODY OUT FOR RYAN MOUNTCASTLE.
MOUNTCASTLE TO COME JUNE HONORS
IN HIS ROOKIE CATEGORY.
IT WAS HARD TO ARGUE AGAINST HIM
COMPARED TO ANYBODY ELSE.
THAT'S DESPITE SOME OTHER
AMERICAN LEAGUE ROOKIES HAVING
SOME PRETTY BIG OUTBURSTS.
HE REALLY FOUND A GROOVE.
THE MANAGER AGAIN SAID, THIS IS
A KID WHO TORE UP THE LEAGUE IN
A SHORT 2020.
AT THAT POINT, THE BOOK HAD COME
OUT.
HE HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THE BOOK.
SARAH: IT'S FUNNY.
WE HAD AT BULLIS GARCIA ON OUR
POLL QUESTION AND HE HAD AN
AMAZING MAY.
MOUNTCASTLE HAD AN AMAZING JUNE.
THEY'VE HAD REALLY HOT JEANS.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHO'S GOING TO GET ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR AT THE END OF THE SEASON.
MELANIE: MCCLANAHAN COMES HOME
AND BRINGS BACK TO BACK
STRIKEOUTS.
SARAH: I MENTIONED BEFORE, HE
GETS A LOT OF HITS.
THAT MEANS HE'S CHASING A LOT.
HE IS SWINGING A LOT.
WE SEE IT HERE AGAIN.
GETTING THE HITS ON THOSE IS
REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
MAYBE TOO MANY SWINGS THERE.
MELANIE: ELEVATED FASTBALL AT 99
IN THE SECOND.
A CHANGEUP LOW.
STILL TRYING TO REEL IN THAT
PHASE.
SANTANDER DOUBLED TO GET THINGS
STARTED FOR THE ORIOLES.
NOW HE FREE SWINGS.
SANTANDER REALLY PUSHED HIMSELF
WITH THE ORIOLES LAST SEASON
BEFORE HE ULTIMATE LEAGUE GOT
SIGNED LINED FOR THE FINAL DOZEN
OR SO GAMES.
HE'S BEEN TRYING TO FIND THAT
GROOVE AGAIN THIS YEAR.
HE TWISTED HIS ANGEL PRETTY --
ANKLE PRETTY BAKLEY.
HE LOST A LOT OF HIS RHYTHM EVEN
AFTER HE HAD BEEN REACTIVATED.
HE DID NOT TRUSTED NOT AS MUCH.
THE LAST TIME THESE TEAMS FACED
OFF IN ST. PETERSBURG, THE
BULLPENS ARE ONE OF THE FEW
PARTS WHERE THEY ARE STILL OUT
ON THE FIELD.
HE LAID OFF OF THE BALL BUT
WITHIN HIS REACH BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T WANT TO GO ON THAT UNEVEN
MOUND.
SARAH: THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING.
WE TALKED LAST YEAR ABOUT HIS
DEFENSE SPECIFICALLY.
ESPECIALLY A COUPLE PLEASE HE
MADE.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE.
IT MAKES SENSE THAT THOSE PARTS
OF YOUR GAME MIGHT BE HAMPERED.
MELANIE: HE'S GOT A 12 COUNT.
TWO MEN ON.
THE ORIOLES TRAILING BY ONE IN
THE THIRD.
57TH PITCH.
SANTANDER SWINGS.
TO SECOND AND FIRST.
DOUBLE PLAY ROLLS UP THE
ORIOLES.
MCCLANAHAN GETS OUT OF IT.
BOTTOM OF THE THIRD.
JOHN MEANS, WHEN WE COME BACK.
RAYS WITH THE LEAD.
♪
>> LINDA ARCIA.
NO POPCORN IN THERE.
IT LEAVES NO DOUBT WHAT HE WAS
AIMING FOR.
>> THERE'S SIX.
THERE'S FOUR.
LOW FOR A.
THERE'S THREE.
THAT'S HOW YOU DRAW IT OUT.
>> IT'S A DOUBLE PLAY THE HARD
WAY.
>> LEFT.
OH MY GOD.
THAT'S AWESOME.
>> DANIEL VOGELBACH IS ON THE
INJURED LIST.
SUN'S OUT, GUNS OUT.
HE'S GOT THE POCKET SQUARE WHICH
I ADMIRE.
THAT'S AS FINE AS IT GETS RIGHT
THERE.
>> UNCLE SAM.
HE WANTS YOU.
♪
MELANIE: WE'VE GOT THE FIRST
RESULTS OF THE YOUTUBE FAN POLL
TONIGHT.
YOUR OFFENSE OF BREAKOUT PLAYER
OF THE YEAR, HOW ABOUT CEDRIC
MULLINS?
43%.
DAVID FLETCHER IS RIGHT BEHIND
HIM.
ADAM FRAZIER INTEGRAL THIS
GARCIA, ALL GREAT SELECTIONS.
YOU COULD ARGUE ANY OF THEM I'M
SURE.
WE'VE GOT RICH HILL.
WE ARE WONDERING, WHO ARE YOU
TAKING FOR YOUR OFFENSE OF
BREAKOUT PLAYER OF THE YEAR >>
-- OFFENSIVE BREAKOUT PLAYER OF
THE YEAR?
>> OF THE YEAR?
MELANIE: THE WHOLE YEAR SO FAR.
>> GEEZ.
I HAVE TO TAKE ONE OF OUR GUYS.
RIGHT NOW, WITH THE WAY OUR GUYS
ARE SWINGING THE BAT, IT HAS
BEEN PRETTY GOOD THIS YEAR.
CAN YOU TAKE A TEAM AS A
BREAKOUT OFFENSIVE TEAM?
MELANIE: OK.
>> YEAH.
MELANIE: I GUESS WE WILL GIVE
YOU THAT ONE FOR NOW.
SOMETHING I'VE ALWAYS LOVED
HEARING, KEVIN CASH EVEN SAID
ABOUT YOU, THOSE FOUR DAYS
BETWEEN STARTS, YOU ARE A FUN
RICH HILL.
AND THEN THAT FIFTH DAY, IT'S A
DIFFERENT STORY.
CAN YOU TELL LESS IN YOUR OWN
WORDS?
>> YEAH.
I'M AN INTENSE COMPETITOR.
OVER THE COURSE OF MY CAREER,
THAT HAS BEEN SOMETHING.
THAT'S A DRIVE TO CENTER FIELD.
THAT'S GONE.
MELANIE: IT'S UP.
RICH HILL CALLS IT.
A HOME RUN.
AROZARENA.
>> WOW.
THERE'S YOUR BREAKOUT OFFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR RIGHT THERE.
RANDY AROZARENA.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE: EXPERT COMMENTARY.
>> YEAH.
JUST THE INTENSITY OVER THE
COURSE OF UNDERSTANDING, NOT
SACRIFICING ANYTHING.
STEPPING BETWEEN THE LINES TO
COMPETE.
THAT IS SOMETHING.
YOU COULD BE A GREAT PERSON OFF
OF THE FIELD.
WHEN YOU GET BETWEEN THE LINES,
YOU WANT TO HAVE THAT INSTINCT,
THAT AGGRESSIVE INSTINCT.
THAT INSTINCT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
DEVELOPED OVER THE YEARS.
I DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR IT.
[LAUGHTER]
I CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT I CAN DO
BETTER.
I'M LEARNING CONSTANTLY EVERY
YEAR THAT I GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PLAY THIS GAME AT THIS LEVEL.
MELANIE: UNDER AN OFFERING FROM
MEANS AND IT DROPS INTO CENTER.
THIS ONE WITHIN REACH IN CENTER
FIELD.
ROOM ON RETIRES.
SARAH: 17 YEARS AGO, IT WAS NO
SMALL FEAT.
HOW DOES THIS TEAM THAT YOU'RE
ON, THIS GROUP OF GUYS, REALLY
COMPARE?
HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE THEM
COMPARED TO THE OTHER TEAMS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ON?
>> ONE THING THAT YOU LOOK BACK
IS LAST YEAR, GOING TO THE WORLD
SERIES AND THAT EXPERIENCE THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO HAVE.
WHAT THEY GAINED IN THAT
EXPERIENCE.
RINGING IT INTO THE 2021 SEASON.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
ASKED REALLY BENEFICIAL COMING
INTO SPRING TRAINING.
SEEING THAT THE GOAL FOR THIS
TEAM THIS YEAR IS TO WIN THE
WORLD SERIES.
HOW WE GET THERE?
THE PROCESS OF GETTING THERE.
HAVING BEEN ON REALLY GREAT
TEAMS, FORTUNATELY IT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO BENEFIT A LITTLE BIT
HERE IN SEEING THAT.
SEEING THE DRIVE.
SEEING THE WORK ETHIC THAT THE
GUYS PUT IN.
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF PLAYERS HERE
THAT I THINK, WE HAVE GUYS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE POTENTIAL
SUPERSTARS.
A LOT OF GUYS ARE JUST GREAT
BASEBALL PLAYERS.
I THINK IF YOU WATCH OUR GAMES,
RAYS BASEBALL, YOU CAN SEE A LOT
OF CONSISTENT QUALITY BASEBALL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
ON A NIGHTLY BASIS WITH PITCHERS
THROWING STRIKES, PLAYS BEING
MADE IN THE INFIELD, HITTING
THAT IS TIMELY, I BALL LEFT
FIELD.
MELANIE: WE ARE GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE MIC FOR THE REST OF THE
NIGHT.
AUSTIN MEADOWS DRIVES IT TO
LEFT.
IT'S THE OTHER AUSTIN HAYS WHO
MAKES THE PICKUP.
TWO OUT FOR THE RAYS.
>> YEAH.
GO AHEAD.
MELANIE: WE'VE GOT SOME COMMENTS
FROM THE FANS.
DR. FILMS, LOVE IT WHEN PLAYERS
GET TO GO HOMERS FOR THEIR
TEAMMATES DURING INTERVIEWS.
>> YEAH.
HOPEFULLY WE GET TO PLAY A WHILE
LONGER.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
GROUND BALL THE SHORT.
MELANIE: WANDER FRANCO GROUNDS
IT OVER TO THE SHORTSTOP RAMON
URIAS.
RICH HILL, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTARY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS ON TONIGHT.
MELANIE: ABSOLUTELY.
THEY YOU SO MUCH.
RAISE ON TOP 3-1 OVER THE
ORIOLES.
A BIG BLAST FROM RANDY AROZARENA
.
PLINY MORE WHEN WE COME BACK
WITH THE FOURTH MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK ON YOUTUBE BY YOUTUBE
SHORTS.
♪
>> A'S DOWN BY 12-2.
HERE COMES CUST.
>> BASE HIT.
RUN NUMBER THREE FOR THE
ATHLETICS.
>> DEEP.
AT THE WALL AND IT'S GONE.
12-5..
HIGH FLY BALL DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
HE DIVES AND CAN'T GET IT.
CABRERA WITH THE DOUBLE.
TWO RUN SCORE.
>> DEEP RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
IT'S AT THE WALL.
IT'S A GRAND SLAM.
>> JACK CUST.
VERY HAIDA CENTER.
A'S LEAD.
>> 14-13 A'S IN THE NINTH.
>> IT'S IN THE DIRT.
IT GETS AWAY FROM SUZUKI.
AROUND THIRD.
THE BALLGAME IS OVER.
THE TWINS CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
♪
MELANIE: RAYS WITH THE LEAD OVER
THE ORIOLES.
HOME RUN FROM RANDY AROZARENA.
DON'T FORGET, YOU CAN ADD TO
THIS UNIQUE VIEWING EXPERIENCE
AND CHECK OUT YOUTUBE'S LIFE
GAME COMMENTARY FEATURING MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL AND A SELECT
GROUP OF YOUTUBE CREATORS.
YOU LIVE COMMENTARY ON YOUR
COMPUTER, MOBILE DEVICE, AND
SMART TV.
WE WILL KEEP AN EYE ON THAT
DISCUSSION THROUGHOUT THE
BROADCAST.
IT HAS CERTAINLY BEEN AN
INTERESTING ONE.
THE RAYS AND ORIOLES HAVE BEEN
TRIPPING BACK AND FORTH AT EACH
OTHER THE ENTIRE NIGHT SO FAR.
CREDIT TO WHOEVER THEY'VE GOT ON
SOCIAL IS IN CHARGE OF THE SMACK
TALK THIS SEASON.
UREAS WITH THE SECOND TIME
SEEING MCCLANAHAN.
HE FOULS OFF AN OFFERING HERE.
ORIOLES DREW A RUN IN THE
SECOND.
SANTANDER DOUBLED.
PEDRO SEVERINO SINGLED TO DRIVE
IT HOME.
THE RAYS JUMPED OUT TO RUNS IN
THE FIRST.
THE BLAST TO CENTER FIELD FOR
AROZARENA IN THE THIRD.
AS CALLED BY RICH HILL.
AGAIN, THINKS TO HIM FOR JOINING
US.
GIVING OUR VOICES ARREST FOR A
BIT.
UREAS STARES AT A BREAKING BALL
STRIKE FROM MCCLANAHAN.
SARAH: I LOVE THE INSTINCT.
I WELL -- LOVE WHEN PLAYERS HAVE
THAT INSTINCT TO CALL IT.
SOME OF THESE INTERVIEWS, THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO OR THEY
CONTINUE WITH THEIR POINT.
THE FACT THAT HE KEPT GOING WITH
HIS POINT AFTERWARDS GET
MELANIE: HE DID NOT LOSE TRACK
FOR EVEN A MINUTE.
FASTBALL MISSES TO UREAS.
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
THAT'S A LOT TO BALANCE AT ONCE.
YOU ARE IN THE GAME.
YOU HAVE ALL YOUR BUDDIES
HANGING OUT WITH YOU THE DUGOUT.
YOU CALLING THAT MAN RIGHT
THERE, SENDING A DEEP ONE RIGHT
OVER ALL-STAR CEDRIC MULLINS
REACH.
MELANIE: 418 FOOT HOME RUN.
FOULS OFF.
WE KNOW THAT YOU GOT TO KNOW
RICH HILL VERY WELL.
WHAT WERE SOME OF THOSE
EXPERIENCES LIKE FOR YOU?
ALANNA: MY GOODNESS.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF CUFFING
HIM IN HIS TIME AS A LOS ANGELES
DODGER.
HE IS FUNNY.
YOU ARE RIGHT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT HIM BEING A JOVIAL GUY ON
THE FOUR DAYS THAT HE'S NOT
PITCHING.
HE'S A COMPLETE LEE DIFFERENT
BEAST WHEN HE STARTS.
WHEN HE'S IN A PARK LIKE THIS
THAT HAS A DOME, HOPEFULLY YOU
BRING YOUR KIDS WITH EARMUFFS.
RICH HILL, WALKER BUEHLER, TYLER
GLASNOW COULD HAVE A CONTEST
ABOUT HOW MANY AFT ARMS -- F
BOMBS THEY DROP.
HE'S A FUNNY GUY.
11 GUY.
HE'S ON THE TEAM CHARTER,
GETTING ON THE AIRLINE PILOTS
FILE -- PA SYSTEM AND MAKING
EVERYONE LAUGH.
MELANIE: THE BALL SKIPS OFF OF
BREW HUNTS GLOVE.
KEVIN KIERMAIER COMES IN WITH
THE PICKUP.
ORIOLES HAVE BEEN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SOME MISCUES HERE
FOR THE RAYS.
RANGING OUT TO HIS LEFT, JUST
OFF OF THE TOP LIP.
SEVERINO STANDS AND.
ONE RUN BELONGS TO HIM.
HE TRIES TO HOLD AND DOES NOT
SUCCESSFULLY.
THE BREAKING BALL FROM
MCCLANAHAN.
0-1.
MCKENNA HAND -- MCCLANAHAN
BATTLE SEVEN PITCHES AGAINST
UREAS.
67.
TAKES THE BOUNCE AND GETS
UNDERNEATH MANAEA.
UP TO SECOND.
IT'S BEEN TOUGH FROM A HAIL ON
SOME OF THE OFFSPEED FROM
MCCLANAHAN.
THAT'S TWO IN A ROW THAT HAVE
TAKEN THAT SAME RICOCHET
UNDERNEATH.
SARAH: DEFINITELY.
GETS INTO THE QUESTION OF
PLAYING EVERYTHING.
HE'S THE EVERYDAY CATCHER HERE.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW MUCH THIS
IS PLAYING IN.
I THINK HE KNEW MAY HAIL WHEN HE
GOT TO THE PARK TODAY.
HE KNEW HE WOULD BE PLAYING
AFTER ZUNINO AFTER THE INJURY
YESTERDAY.
HE COULD BE SOMETHING.
MELANIE: SEVERINO TAKES A
STRIKE.
UREAS REACHES ON AND E4.
HE ADVANCES TO SECOND ON A WILD
PITCH.
THE RAYS DEFENSE IS USUALLY
EXTREMELY SHARP.
IT HAS NOT COST THEM YET.
THE ORIOLES ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE.
THAT'S A 2-2 COUNT FOR SEVERINO.
SARAH: MCCLANAHAN DID NOT THROW
A LOT OF FOUR-SEAMERS.
HE SEEMS TO BE STAYING AWAY FROM
THE FASTBALLS AS WELL.
IT'S INTERESTING.
MELANIE: THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU SAW THE HARD THROWERS.
I RAN INTO A LOT OF INJURIES.
NOW HE'S COMING THROUGH THE
BACKSIDE FOR THE WHITE SOX RIGHT
NOW.
SARAH: HE THREW 100.
THIS SEASON, IT HAS BEEN LOWER.
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE THAT IS TO
MANAGE THE WORKLOAD AND NOT GET
INJURED.
MELANIE: MCCLANAHAN GREW UP IN
BALTIMORE UNTIL THE AGE OF FIVE.
SEVERINO THOUSAND OFTEN STAYS
ALIVE.
GREW UP IN A ROW HOME.
TRADITIONAL HOUSING IN THE CITY
OF BALTIMORE.
YOU CAN'T GO ANYWHERE WITHOUT
SEEING THEM.
CAL RIPKEN JR. ALL OVER HIS
WALL.
THAT WAS THE MAN.
THAT'S WHO HE LOVED.
THEY WERE A HANDFUL OF MINUTES
AWAY FROM ORIOLE PARK IN CAMDEN
YARDS.
WOULD BE WEIRD TO FACE A TEAM
THAT YOU GREW UP LOVING?
HE SAID, THIS IS MY JOB NOW.
FULL COUNT.
HE RINGS UP SEVERINO.
MCCLANAHAN WITH A DEVASTATING
BREAKING BALL.
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
STORYLINES.
THE DOCTORS TRYING TO FIND THAT
SECOND TITLE.
58-30 SIX, SECOND IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
VLAD JR. HAS 78 RBIS, PUSHING
FOR THE TRIPLE CROWN.
SHOHEI OHTANI HOW MANY HOMERS
KENNY HAD THIS YEAR?
FERNANDO TATIS JR. IS LETTING
EVERYBODY UP RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY HIS PLAYS.
AS WE MENTIONED, THAT
ELECTRICITY.
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE IT FROM
PLAYERS.
THAT LEADS US TO OUR YOUTUBE
PHONE POLE NUMBER TWO.
WHICH OF THESE IS MOST LIKELY TO
HAPPEN AT THE END OF THE 2020
SEASON?
DODGERS REPEAT, OHTANI HITS 60,
GUERRERO JR. RICHES THE TRIPLE
CROWN, OR TATIS JR. GOES 4040 ON
THE SEASON.
MAKE SURE TO GET THOSE VOTES IN.
PITCH TO VALAIKA.
MCCLANAHAN COMES INSIDE.
HE FELL BEHIND TO VALAIKA THE
LAST TIME THEY FACED OFF AS
WELL.
HE DREW THE WALK.
SARAH: I LOVE THOSE THINGS.
A LOT OF THOSE ARE NOT THINGS
WE'VE SEEN IN A WHILE.
WE'VE NOT HAD A TEAM GO BACK TO
BACK AS WORLD SERIES CHAMPIONS
SINCE THE YANKEES AT THE 90'S.
IT'S THE LONGEST STRETCH AND
ENTER MAJOR PROFESSIONAL SPORT
WITHOUT A REPEAT CHAMPION.
NBA, NHL, NFL.
TALK ABOUT 4040 FOR FERNANDO
TATIS JR..
TRIPLE CROWN, HE DID IT RECENTLY
BUT IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
OF COURSE, WE HAVEN'T SEEN 60
HOME RUNS 2001.
ANYONE OF THOSE THINGS WOULD BE
REALLY COOL.
MAYBE THEY COULD ALL HAPPEN.
PROBABLY THE 60 AND TRIPLE CROWN
ON TOP AT ONCE.
MELANIE: YOU JUST WANT EVERYBODY
TO WIN.
SARAH: I DO.
MELANIE: WE'VE GOT SOMEBODY ON
THE BROADCAST WITH US WHO'S GOT
SOME HARDWARE THAT SHE GETS TO
WEAR FROM TIME TO TIME.
I THINK THAT'S A WORLD SERIES
RING FOR YOU.
ALANNA: OH YEAH.
I HAD A LOT TO DO WITH IT.
[LAUGHTER]
I SWUNG THE BAT INCREDIBLY WELL.
MY DEFENSE WAS IMPECCABLE.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE A
VERY APPRECIATIVE BENEFACTOR OF
THE 2020 WORLD SERIES RING FROM
THE DODGERS.
I COVERED THEM THE LAST SEVEN
SEASONS.
THE ONE THING THAT THE DOCTORS
HAVE ALWAYS HAD IS DEPTH.
NOT ONLY IN THEIR PITCHING STAFF
BUT ALSO THEIR OUTFIELD.
IT'S AN INTERESTING PROSPECT.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO REPEAT AS A
WORLD SERIES CHAMPION.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, I WONDER IF
THAT IS GOING TO PLAY OUT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SECOND HALF OF
THE SEASON.
KERSHAW IS ON THE IL.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH TREVOR BAUER.
DAVID PRICE GOES IN BETWEEN THE
BULLPEN IN THE STARTING
ROTATION.
TONY GONSOLIN IS MAKING HIS WAY
IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
YOU HAVE TO QUALITY ARMS IN
WALKER BUEHLER AND JULIO URIAS
FOR THE DODGERS.
I KNOW THAT FREEMAN WILL
PROBABLY GO AFTER ANOTHER STRING
PITCHER, ANOTHER ARM.
YOU ARE STILL WAITING TO GET
COREY SEAGER BACK FROM THE IL.
MOOKIE BETTS IS DEALING.
GAVIN LUX JUST WENT ON THE IL.
CODY BELLINGER HASN'T GONE
THINGS GOING OFFENSIVELY.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO REPEAT.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING WHAT THE
DOCTORS DO IN TERMS OF MOVE AT
THE DEADLINE.
MELANIE: WERE YOU SURPRISED BY
EVERYBODY ELSE?
SEE WHAT SAN FRANCISCO HAS BEEN
DOING THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE THE DEFINITION OF THE
DARK HORSE THIS YEAR.
ALANNA: I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF THE
GIANTS ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THAT THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS WERE GOING TO
BE FIRST IN THE NL WEST
WIRE-TO-WIRE SO FAR IN THE
SEASON.
THEY ARE DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB
OF PLAYING.
FOR HANS RED IS NOW THE
PRESIDENT OF THEIR BASEBALL
OPERATIONS.
HE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
MYSELF AND CHRIS RUSSO THE OTHER
DAY ABOUT HOW THIS IS A YEAR IN
WHICH EVERYTHING IS PAYING
DIVIDENDS.
THEY KNEW THAT THEY WERE
REBUILDING.
WHAT THEY ARE GETTING THIS YEAR
IS PROBABLY MORE THAN THEY EVEN
THOUGHT THEY WERE GETTING.
THEY HAVE THE YOUNG TALENT.
THEY HAVE THE VETERAN PLAYERS.
BUSTER POSEY AS WELL AS BRANDON
BELT AND BRANDON CRAWFORD.
THEY ARE PLAYING AS VETERAN
PLAYERS, AS IF THEY WERE YOUNG
AGAIN.
EVAN LONGORIA.
SAN FRANCISCO'S PLAYED
INCREDIBLY WELL.
WILL BE INTERESTING JC -- TO SEE
HOW IT SHAPES OUT IN THAT
DIVISION.
MELANIE: IT IS SPOT ON.
IT REALLY IS.
GUTIERREZ LIFTS ONE INTO THE
GLOVE OF BRANDON LOWE IN RIGHT
FIELD.
NSE.
RAISE ON TOP.
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE FOURTH WE
GO.
♪
>> THIS IS THE STORY OF DAN AND
KEVIN KIERMAIER.
A STORY ABOUT SIBLINGS.
>> RIVALRY.
>> AND RIVALRIES.
>> WE LOVE EACH OTHER.
WE WANTED TO KICK EACH OTHER'S
BUT EVERY DAY.
>> WE FOUGHT EVERY DAY GROWING
UP.
IT TURNED OUT THAT WE BECAME
BEST FRIENDS.
>> LIKE MANNYWOOD MASTERING
CHILDREN, THE KIERMAIER'S LIVED
AND DIED WITH SAMMY SOSA IN THE
CUPS.
THEY FIRST VISITED WRIGLEY
DURING THE HISTORIC SUMMER OF
1998 AMBER HOOKED.
>> IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE EXPOS
VERSUS THE CUPS.
IT WAS LATE AUGUST.
SANDY SOSA HIT HIS 41ST OR 42ND
HOME RUN.
>> YEAR'S LETTER, KEVIN IS
PLAYING ON THOSE BIG LEAGUE BALL
FIELDS.
DAN?
AS FAR AS THE FAMILY IS
CONCERNED, HE'S NOW RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE MOST PERFECT FIELD OF
ALL.
>> ON THE HEAD GROUNDSKEEPER FOR
THE CHICAGO CUBS.
STILL IS SURREAL FOR ME TO SAY
THAT.
>> THEY HAVE ONE MORE DREAM.
SOMEDAY, THE THREE-TIME GOLD
GLOVE WINNER WOULD LIKE A CHANCE
TO LAY OUT FOR A BALL ON A FIELD
PERFECTLY PREPARED BY HIS
BROTHER.
>> THAT WOULD BE AN AMAZING
EXPERIENCE.
THAT WOULD BE A COOL MOMENT FOR
BOTH OF US.
♪
>> LET'S GO.
>> YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT I
NEEDED ONE MORE DEGREE?
MELANIE: I KNOW WE MIKED UP RICH
HILL.
NOW HE MIGHT HAVE TO HAVE
BRANDON LOWE.
THEY WILL TAKE OVER AND CALL THE
GAME.
MY GOODNESS.
HE WAS ALL OVER THE STATS ON
THAT AROZARENA HOME RUN.
HE SWINGS FIRST PAGE FROM JOHN
MEANS.
IT'S SHALLOW CENTER FIELD.
DROPS IN FOR A BASE HIT.
IT'S PUTS THE DEFENSE.
LOWE, A2 FOR TODAY TO START THE
FOURTH WITH A SINGLE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AND SEE IF
LOWE GOT THOSE METRICS CORRECT.
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
AROZARENA LIFTS IT 25 DEGREES,
PROJECTED 418 FEET.
SARAH: HE WAS SO CLOSE.
HE SAID 104 AND 24.
ONE DEGREE.
WE WILL GIVE IT TO YOU.
THE EXIT VELOCITY WAS 104.3.
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR
GUESSING.
MELANIE: HE'S GOT SOME INSIDER
ADVANTAGE METRICS READINGS.
SARAH: THAT IS SO RAISE, RIGHT?
SOMETIMES WE ATTRIBUTE TOO MUCH
TO THE RAYS.
THEY KNOW ALL THE METRICS.
HE PUT THAT ON THE PLAQUE.
MELANIE: THEY'VE TRAINED PLAYERS
TO READ EXIT VELOCITY OFF OF
PITCHES WITH THEIR BARE EYES.
IT MAKES SENSE.
DRIVE INTO LEFT FIELD.
GETTING UP.
IT'S OUT OF HERE.
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
GOODBYE BASEBALL.
THE TWO RUN HOME RUN.
IT'S A 5-1 LEAD FOR THE RAYS.
HIS FOURTH BLAST OF THE YEAR.
SARAH: I WANT TO KNOW IF HE CAN
DO THAT WHILE HE'S ON BASE.
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
MELANIE: THAT'S THE MOST RUNS
MEANS HAS ALLOWED THIS YEAR.
FIVE FOR TAMPA BAY.
AGAIN, A CHANGEUP.
THAT LEAKS A LITTLE BIT HERE.
MEJIA GETS A READ.
TWO HOME RUNS FOR THE RAYS.
A SOLO SHOT FOR AROZARENA.
THE TWO RUN FOR MEJIA.
FIRST PITCH FOR JI-MAN CHOI.
IT'S A STRIKE.
THIS IS WHAT HE DISCUSSED
OVERALL.
HE IS STILL COMING BACK.
HE'S BEEN AWAY SINCE JUNE 5
WHICH IS A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME.
SHALLOW CENTER FIELD.
THREE STRAIGHT HITS FOR THE RAYS
IN THE FOURTH.
CHOI FINDS A SINGLE.
JOHN MEANS IS SOME BUT EXPECTS
THE MOST HIMSELF.
HE'S THE HARDEST ON HIMSELF MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STARTER.
CERTAINLY CARRIES THAT VETERAN
PRESENCE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF I GIVE
UP A HOME RUN, IT IS WHAT IT IS.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT I'M KEEPING
MY TEAM IN THE BALLGAME.
I WANT TO KNOW IF I'M FINISHING
SIX OR SEVEN INNINGS FOR THE
CLUB AND SAVING THAT BULLPEN AS
WELL.
YOU WOULD HELP IN THE SITUATION
THAT THE COACHES HAVE HELPED
TEMPER A LITTLE BIT OF THAT AND
SAID, IF YOU WILL GO OUT THERE,
WE'VE GOT FRESHLY RESTED ARMS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PICK YOU UP.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT YOUR
BACK TODAY.
THEY FOUND A WAY TO TARGET THAT
LOWER SHOULDER TAINT HE HAD BEEN
HAVING AS A RESULT OF GOING TO
HIS CHANGEUP SO MUCH.
HE COMES HOME WITH A STRIKE TO
TAYLOR WALLS.
MELANIE: IT'S INTERESTING YOU
SAY THAT.
I'M SURPRISED BY THIS.
HE HAS ALLOWED MULTIPLE HOME
RUNS.
EIGHT GAMES THIS YEAR WERE HE'S
ALLOWED AT LEAST ONE HOME RUN.
ONLY ONE OF THOSE WAS ONE HOME
RUN.
HE ALLOWED TWO OR MORE IN ALL OF
THE OTHERS GET IT'S INTERESTING
TO THINK OF MAYBE SPIRALING.
SOMETHING ELSE OR A COUPLE BAD
PITCHES AS OPPOSED TO JUST ONE.
MELANIE: HE'S BEEN VERY HONEST
WHEN HE'S KNOWN HE'S MR. PITCH.
AND SIGN WITH A FASTBALL.
SOME OF THE CREATORS CALLING
SOME OF THESE.
BOO SHOCK ALAKA.
A LOT OF BOOMS GOING ON THROUGH
THE YOUTUBE CHAT RIGHT NOW.
MEANS EVENS THE COUNT.
MEANS AGAIN, INCREDIBLE STORIES
AROUND THE LEAGUE.
IF YOU TAKE THE TIME TO GET TO
KNOW THESE PLAYERS.
HE LOST HIS FATHER LAST YEAR.
HE WAS THE CENTERPIECE OF THE
FAMILY.
THEY GOT TO WELCOME IN THEIR
BABY BOY THIS YEAR.
UNDERNEATH THE PITCH.
IT'S A BOUNCE TO VALAIKA.
TECH TEAMS TO UREAS WHO STEPS ON
SECOND.
ELIMINATES JI-MAN CHOI.
THE FIRST OUT FOR THE ORIOLES.
SARAH: TOUGH PLAY.
YOU WANT TO TRY TO TURN TO
THEIR.
NOT REALLY POSITIONED IN THE
RIGHT PLACE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
MELANIE: SHIFTED.
THE PLAY WOULD GO FOR SIX.
VALAIKA PLAYING BEHIND THE
PICKUP.
THE UPPERHAND THROW TO THE
SHORTSTOP.
CHECK BACK.
ONE OUT.
THE RAYS UP BY FOUR IN THE
FOURTH.
FASTBALL AWAY.
KEVIN KIERMAIER.
BALL ONE.
HE HAS BEEN FINDING A GROUP
SINCE THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
.385.
1-3 YESTERDAY.
FLIED OUT TO THE RIGHT IN THE
SECOND.
MEANS COMES OUTSIDE AGAIN.
BALL TWO.
SARAH: HE IS REALLY THE PLAYER
YOU THINK OF, OR AT LEAST I
THINK OF WITH THIS CURRENT RAYS
TEAM.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE OVER THE
LAST FIVE PLUS YEARS.
HE FEELS LIKE THE STALWART
THERE, EVEN THOUGH HE HAS MISSED
SOME TIME WITH INJURY.
MELANIE: MEANS COMES HOME.
KIERMAIER FOULS IT OFF.
2-1.
KIERMAIER LIFETIME AGAINST
MEANS, HE'S 2-8.
AND HE REALLY WAS THE GUY WHO
STEPPED UP.
THE RAYS FANS MOURNED ALMOST THE
LOSS OF EVAN LONGORIA.
KIERMAIER STARTS MAKING DICKEY
LIST PLAYS AT CENTER FIELD.
THE BACK HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN THE
STRONGEST -- BAT HAS NOT ALWAYS
BEEN THE STRONGEST, BUT THAT IS
NOT WHAT HE IS KNOWN FOR.
A GUY WHO ANCHORS THE DUGOUT OFF
THE FIELD.
SARAH: THE GOLD GLOVE DEFENSE.
WE CAN QUANTIFY THAT BY
STATCAST.
HE'S ALWAYS UP THERE WHEN HE IS
HEALTHY ON THOSE LEADER BOARDS.
MELANIE: THE CHECK BACK AT
WALLS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE KIERMAIER
STACKS UP WITHIN THE RAYS
FRANCHISE.
SIXTH IN OVERALL GAMES.
HE OF COURSE IS FIRST IN WINS
ABOVE REPLACEMENT.
A DRIVE INTO LEFT FIELD.
AUSTIN HAYS PLAYS IT BACK TWO
STEPS TO HIS RIGHT AND REELS IT
IN.
EACH WEEK THIS SEASON ON OUR
BROADCAST, WE WILL FOCUS ON A
YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR FEATURED
IN OUR LIVE GAME COMMENTARY
SECTION.
OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT SHINES ON
ARATI PATEL, A CHANNEL WITH OVER
1.5 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
THE CHANNEL NAME IS "THE FUMBLE.
"
IT IS A SPORTS NEWS FOR THE
SUPER FAN WHO CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
I THINK YOU COULD ASSUME THAT
PATEL IS A DODGERS FAN, JUST
LISTING OFF THE FAVORITES FOR
THE BOYS IN BLUE IN L.A.
SARAH: A LOT OF FUN MOMENTS FOR
THAT TEAM LAST YEAR, EVEN IN A
SHORTENED SEASON.
MELANIE: REALLY COOL TO SEE TOO
WITH FANS HAVING A WAY TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES THROUGH
CHANNELS LIKE YOUTUBE.
MEANS COMES HOME TO AROZARENA
AND GETS A CALLED STRIKE.
AROZARENA WITH A NOD BACK AT THE
HOME PLATE UMPIRE.
RUNNER AT FIRST.
TWO AWAY.
RAYS UP 5-1.
MEANS DELIVERS FASTBALL HIGH.
HE AND PEDRO SEVERINO, THIS WAS
THE BATTERY TEAM AGAINST THE
MARINERS.
HE TITLED THE WINNING PHOTOGRAPH
SEVY TIME.
YOU KNOW HE LIKES TO HAVE FUN.
HE TALKS TO EVERYBODY WHO COMES
UP TO THE PLATE.
HE HAS TO HAVE A WORD WITH HIS
FELLOW BACKSTOPS AS WELL.
THE TWO HAVE REALLY GOOD
COMMUNICATIONS.
1-2.
SEVERINO KEEPS IT OUT IN FRONT
OF HIM.
2-2.
SARAH: WE WERE TALKING BEFORE
THE GAME ABOUT THAT FIRST PITCH
STRIKE RATE FOR MEANS.
THAT WAS ON DISPLAY IN THE
NO-HITTER.
HE HAD THE HIGHEST RATE OF FIRST
PITCH STRIKES.
YOU HAVE TO CREDIT YOUR CATCHER
A DECENT AMOUNT FOR THAT.
2-2.
MELANIE: AROZARENA FOULS IT OFF.
LOOKING AT THE DAY JOHN MEANS
MADE HISTORY.
HE DID NOT THINK BASEBALL WAS IN
IT FOR HIM.
WELL, SEATTLE DID NOT HAVE
ANYTHING FOR HIM EITHER THAT
DAY.
AND HE SET ABSOLUTE NUMBERS.
FIRST NO-HITTER FOR THE ORIOLES.
JIM PALMER WAS PART OF THE MASN
BROADCAST CREW THIS YEAR.
HE REACHED OUT TO MEANS LATER.
HE SAID YOUR NO-HITTER WAS WAY
BETTER THAN MINE.
A MAN WITH OVERWHELMING INSIGHT,
HE TOLD US HE CUT TO CERTAIN
MATTERS KNOWING HE HAD A
NO-HITTER INTACT AND DID NOT
KNOW A GUY, SO HE WALKED HIM.
MEANS DID NOT HAVE TO DO THAT.
RANDY AROZARENA CHASES A
CHANGEUP FROM MEANS.
IT'S A BIG TWO SHOT BLAST FOR
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
THE RAYS WITH A 5-1 LEAD AFTER T
BETWEEN THESE TWO.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
♪
>> THAT'S SOMETHING I GOT TO
GET.
I'M NOT TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT.
WHEN IT DROPS, I FEEL TERRIBLE.
>> THAT WAS A TOUGH PLAY.
MELANIE: BRANDON LOWE IS WEARING
THAT ONE HIMSELF, FEELING ALL
THE RESPONSIBILITY, TRYING TO
CHASE EVERY BALL IN THE
OUTFIELD.
WHEREVER HE PLAYS, HE'S MAKING
THE BIG ONES.
GETTING SOME WORDS THERE.
HE HAD A PRETTY IMPOSSIBLE HOP
TO CHASE AFTER.
HIS TEAM IS UP 5-1 ON THE
ORIOLES.
MULLINS TAKES ANOTHER APPEARANCE
AGAINST SHANE MCCLANAHAN TO
START THE FIFTH.
NOT A LOT OF COMMENTARY FROM
LOWE IN THE FIELD, BUT
IMMEDIATELY GETTING THAT
FEEDBACK ONCE HE STEPS OFF SITE.
HE'S GETTING THAT ONE-ON-ONE
COACHING FROM RIGHT.
HE'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
2-0.
IT'S ANOTHER MISS TO CEDRIC
MULLINS.
BALL THREE.
SARAH: IT IS JUST HIS THIRD
START IN RIGHT FIELDER THIS
YEAR.
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE HE IS TAKING
THAT COACHING TO HEART.
THAT IS SOMETHING I LOVE THAT WE
CAN SHOW FANS WITH STUFF, GUYS
BEING MIC'ED UP.
MELANIE: PITCH HOME.
MCCLANAHAN STRAIGHTENS IT OUT
WITH A STRIKE.
SARAH: GETTING A SENSE OF HOW
MUCH OF A TEAM GAME IT IS, THAT
IS IMPORTANT FOR FANS TO HEAR.
MELANIE: ANDREW KITTREDGE
WARMING UP FOR THE RAYS.
AS MULLINS TAKES A SWING.
EVERYONE IS TAKING A LONG LOOK
AT THIS ONE AS IT FALLS FOUL OUT
TO THE LEFT SIDE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE POLL
RESULTS.
FANS, WHAT HAVE YOU GOT MOST
LIKELY TO HAPPEN?
OHTANI, 60 HOME RUNS.
TATIS CAN STILL GO FOR THE
40-40.
VLAD JR., THE TRIPLE CROWN.
NOT A LOT THINKING THE DODGERS
PULL A REPEAT.
WHAT A PACKED TIGHT NL THIS
YEAR.
MULLINS SWINGS.
A BOUNCING BALL TO THE SECOND
BASEMAN.
MULLINS RETIRED.
ONE AWAY FOR THE O'S.
SARAH: I LOVE THE RECOGNITION OF
SHOHEI OHTANI.
HE'S SUCH AN AMAZING STAR FOR
THE SPORT.
WE SAW IT ON DISPLAY IN DENVER
LAST WEEK.
I'M NOT THAT SURPRISED THAT THE
DODGERS OPTION FINISHED LAST
WITH A LOT OF RAYS FANS TUNED
IN.
THEY PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE: FEELING A LITTLE SALTY
AFTER THAT ONE, NOT JUST BECAUSE
THEY ARE DOWN BY THE BAY.
WE HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMMENTING THROUGHOUT THE GAME
ABOUT SHOHEI OHTANI.
AUSTIN HAYS TAKES A STRIKE, 0-1.
JUST HOW TRANSFORMATIVE HE HAS
BEEN FOR THE GAME.
IT GOES BEYOND THAT HE HAS BEEN
THIS SECOND COMING OF BABE RUTH
WHEN IT COMES TO PITCHING AND
HITTING.
IT IS THAT OVERALL LIKABLE
PERSONALITY.
HE GOT CHECKED FOR STICKY
SUBSTANCES AND AFTERWARDS GIVES
A SMILE AND PAT ON THE BACK TO
THE UMPIRE.
SOMEBODY THAT INTERNATIONALLY --
FOR JAPAN TO SHOW THE ALL-STAR
FESTIVITIES THIS YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 25 YEARS, THAT
SPEAKS WORLDS OF WHAT HE IS
DOING FOR THE SPORT.
SARAH: DEFINITELY.
THE PERSONALITY, THE FACT THAT
WE SEE THAT ON A BROADCAST.
MELANIE: AND AUSTIN HAYS GETS
FOOLED.
HE CHASES WAY OUT OF THE ZONE
FROM MCCLANAHAN.
AND ANOTHER STRIKEOUT FOR SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
TWO AWAY.
WANDER FRANCO HAS BEEN HOLDING
IT DOWN AT THIRD BASE THIS
EVENING.
HE DID NOT PLAY YESTERDAY.
ALANNA: IT'S JUST  THAT
DIVERSITY OF HIM BEING ABLE TO
MOVE ALL OVER THE FIELD TO KEEP
HIS BAT IN THE LINEUP AND GLOVE
IN THE FIELD.
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH HIM
AND CASH, THAT HE BURST ONTO THE
SCENE AS ONE OF THE TOP
PROSPECTS IN BASEBALL, BUT THAT
HAS SLOWED DOWN.
HE IS LEARNING.
HE SAID I CAN'T REMEMBER A TIME
WHEN THERE WAS MORE HYPE FOR A
PLAYER COMING OUT OF THE BIG
LEAGUES OTHER THAN VLADIMIR
GUERRERO JR. AND BRYCE HARPER.
KEVIN CASH WAS IN THE ALL-STAR
GAME AND HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH VLADIMIR GUERRERO ABOUT
WHAT TYPES OF ADVICE HE WOULD
GIVE TO WANDER FRANCO WITH THE
HYPE.
HE SAID, LIMIT THE FACT OF THE
NOISE IN YOUR EAR, ALL
DISTRACTIONS TALKING, LIMIT THE
PRESSURE YOU PUT ON YOURSELF.
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH WANDER
EARLIER TODAY IN SPANISH.
HE SAIAD THE BIGGEST THING --
SAID THE BIGGEST THING IS
KNOWING THE PITCHERS AT THIS
LEVEL ARE SO MUCH BETTER AND
HAVING PATIENCE WITH MYSELF.
THAT WILL BE BIG.
MELANIE: I CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW
HOME HE FE -- HOW AT HOME HE
FELT.
PITCH HOME TO TREY MANCINI.
HE SENDS IT TO RIGHT.
BUT BRANDON LOWE NOT FOOLED THIS
TIME.
RIGHT INTO HIS GLOVE AS HE
TRACKS IT DOWN TO THE DEPTHS.
1-2-3 GO THE ORIOLES IN THE
FIFTH.
THEY TRAIL TAMPA BAY 5 FLASHING.
A HANDFUL OF STARTS IN OUTFIELD
FOR LOWE, BUT COMING UP BIG.
PLENTY MORE GAME OF THE WEEK ON
YOUTUBE WHEN WE COME BACK.
♪
>> NOW THE 0-1 TO LOWRIE ON ITS
WAY.
TAKES IT TO SECOND HIMSELF.
THE RAYS ARE GOING TO THE WORLD
SERIES!
THIS INCREDIBLE SEASON HAS
ANOTHER CHAPTER TO IT.
>> NOT ONCE IN THEIR FIRST 10
YEARS HAVE THE TAMPA BAY RAYS
HAD A WINNING SEASON.
NOW IN A STUNNING REVERSAL OF
FORTUNE, THEY WERE IN THE WORLD
SERIES.
♪
WITH LIGHTNING QUICK SPEED, DEEP
YOUNG PITCHING STAFF, AND A
MANAGER WHO TAPPED INTO THE
POTENTIAL, THE RAYS DEFIED
EXPECTATIONS.
♪
>> POP THE CORK AND THE
CHAMPAGNE.
>> THE RAYS ARE GOING TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
>> IN THE DIVISION SERIES, THEY
ELIMINATED THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX
IN FOUR GAMES.
>> IN THE POSTSEASON FOR THE
FIRST TIME, THE RAYS ARE HEADING
TO THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES.
>> WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE TO GET
PAST THE DEFENDING CHAMPION RED
SOX ONCE AGAIN.
THE CONFIDENCE THEY DEVELOPED BY
BEATING THEM FOR THE DIVISION
TITLE SERVED THE RAYS WELL IN
THIS TENSE SEVEN-GAME SERIES.
>> THE TAMPA BAY RAYS WON THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE PENNANT.
THEY ARE GOING TO THE WORLD
SERIES.
♪
MELANIE: RAYS WITH A 5-1 LEAD
OVER THE ORIOLES AS WE HEAD TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE FIFTH INNING.
WHO IS YOUR MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME?
WADE MILEY TOOK THE LAST ONE
AFTER INNATE INNING PERFORMANCE
AGAINST THE BREWERS.
WHO BETWEEN THE ORIOLES AND RAYS
IS GOING TO BE THE ONE TO BRING
IT HOME?
FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
AND COMPUTERS CAN VOTE FOR WHICH
PLAYER WILL ULTIMATELY TAKE HOME
THAT TROPHY.
JOHN MEANS BACK OUT FOR THE
FIFTH.
FIRST PITCH TO VIDAL BRUJAN.
FOULS A FASTBALL BEHIND HIM.
0-1.
BRUJAN, A 1-2 DAY.
UP AND INSIDE.
MEANS WITH A FASTBALL, 1-1.
THAT IS NOT INTENTIONAL.
THIS IS SOMEONE TRYING TO GET
BACK IN THE SWING OF THINGS.
IT HAS BEEN A DISCUSSION
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON, BUT MEANS
AT THE TIME HE HIT THE INJURED
LIST, YOU COULD STILL HAVE
SUNSCREEN.
HE'S COME BACK TO A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT ERA OF BASEBALL.
THAT IS SOMETHING HE HAD TO
RECALIBRATE AS HE WORKED THROUGH
REHAB.
SARAH: IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
FOUR-SEAMER AND THE BREAKING
PITCHES SO FAR TONIGHT, THEY ARE
DOWN A NOTICEABLE AMOUNT.
I THINK FANS ARE INCLINED TO
THINK THAT IS SOME AWFUL BELLS
RINGING OR SOMETHING, BUT THE
RULES HAVE CHANGED.
IT'S OKAY, BUT THERE ARE
DEFINITELY SOME NOTICEABLE
DIFFERENCE THERE.
MELANIE: A FOULED OFF FASTBALL
FOR BREW ON AGAIN.
-- BRUJAN AGAIN.
HE JUST EXCEEDED 70 PITCHES HIS
LAST REHAB APPEARANCE AT AAA NOR
FOLK.
2-2 TO BRUJAN, HIT LOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT MEANS' THREE
REHAB APPEARANCES.
5.63 E.R.A. THROUGH EIGHT
INNINGS TOTAL.
STRIKEOUT TO WALK RATIO 9:3.
THE SPIN AND THROW IS IN TIME.
OH MY GOODNESS.
GUTIERREZ WAS NOT GIVEN A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR HIS DEFENSE WHEN HE
CAME OVER TO BALTIMORE, AND HE
HAS ABSOLUTELY SHOWN OUT LITTLE
FLASH OF THE LEATHER IN FRONT OF
SHORTSTOP RAMONA MARIA'S --
RAMON URIAS.
SARAH: YOU LOVE A PLAY WHERE
EVERYONE IS SMILING AFTER AN
OUT, EVEN THE GUY WHO HIT INTO
IT.
MELANIE: BRUJAN KNOWS THAT
GUTIERREZ HAS USED ALL OF THAT
6'2" FRAME ON THE PLAY, THE BIG
WINGSPAN.
70TH PITCH.
IT IS A STRIKE TO AUSTIN
MEADOWS.
SARAH: THAT IS ANOTHER PLAY,
WHERE I AM SITTING AT HOME OR IN
THE BALLPARK, I AM STARING AT MY
COMPUTER.
I NEED TO KNOW HOW FAST THAT
THROW WAS.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL GET THAT
TRACKED.
83.8 MILES AN HOUR.
I WANT TO SAY INFIELDER THROWS
-- JOEY GALLO THREW A BALL 97
MILES AN HOUR YESTERDAY.
THAT WAS ALL OF THOSE 83.8 MILES
AN HOUR.
MELANIE: KELVIN GUTIERREZ COMING
UP BIG FOR BALTIMORE ON THE
FIRST OUT IN THE FIFTH.
MEADOWS CHASES AN OFFSPEED.
SENDS IT FOUL.
THE COUNT IS EVEN.
SARAH: SOMETIMES WE GET
DISTANCES ON FOUL BALLS AND THEY
DON'T END UP ANYWHERE.
THAT WAS A 360 FOOT FOUL BALL.
I JUST LOVE KNOWING THAT.
MELANIE: I THINK THE MAN WITH
THE BABY AND THE BALL WILL
REMEMBER THAT.
MEADOWS CHASES A FASTBALL OUT OF
THE ZONE.
IT IS RIGHT TO CEDRIC MULLINS.
LAYS INTO LEFT CENTER FIELD TO
RETIRE.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER
OF BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM.
THE ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
HAPPY WIFE, HAPPY MAN, HAPPY
BABY THAT IS NOT GIVING UP A
FOUL BALL.
MAYBE ONE DAY THEY WILL GROW UP
AND GIVE THE STORY, YEAH, YOU
CAUGHT THAT.
YOU WERE A COUPLE MONTHS OLD AND
WE KNEW YOU HAD THOSE COLD GLOVE
HANDS.
-- GOLD GLOVE HANDS.
SARAH: THESE GAMES ARE ARCHIVED
ON YOUTUBE.
THEY COULD GO BACK AND FIND THAT
PICTURE.
I HAVE A WHOLE IDEA OF A
SCRAPBOOK IN MY HEAD ALREADY.
MELANIE: YOU DON'T KNOW ME, BUT
I WANT TO GIVE YOU THIS
DOCUMENTATION OF YOUR CHILD.
FUTURE ALL-STARS EVERYWHERE.
A 1-1 COUNT TO WANDER FRANCO.
SARAH: SOMETHING I WANT TO
MENTION ABOUT FRANCO, HIS AT-BAT
WAS SO QUICK TO START -- HE IS
THE YOUNGEST GUY IN RAYS HISTORY
TO HIT CLEANUP IN A GAME.
20 YEARS, 141 DAYS OLD.
MELANIE: HE GETS UNDERNEATH THE
BREAKING BALL FROM MEANS.
THIS ONE TO THE BACK OF THE
INFIELD PATH.
VALAIKA WITH A POP-UP.
HE WILL HAVE PLENTY MORE TO
DEVELOP FOR THIS STRAIGHT FOR JS
THROUGH FIVE.
THE RAYS LEAD 5-1.
YOU ARE WATCHING ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
>> SEPTEMBER 6, 1995.
TONIGHT THE IRONMAN WILL PASS
THE IRON HORSE.
♪
>> ALWAYS ON THE FIELD EVERY
GAME.
>> I THINK IT IS JUST A DESIRE
TO PLAY.
I CAN'T STAND TO SIT ON THE
SIDELINES AND WATCH.
>> BATTING FOURTH, NUMBER
EIGHTH, CAL RIPKEN.
>> I GO INTO EACH SEASON
THINKING I'M GOING TO PLAY.
THERE IS NO PRESSURE.
I'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE DOING IT AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE.
>> TAKEN FOR GRANTED WE SEE HIM
DAY AFTER DAY.
HE'S ALMOST LIKE A MACHINE.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY SECRETS.
>> HE DOES NOT HOLD BACK AT ALL
FROM THE MYRIAD OF WAYS HE CAN
GET HURT.
YET HE CONTINUES TO PLAY.
>> I TRIED TO MAINTAIN THE SAME
APPROACH AND DON'T WORRY ABOUT
TOMORROW UNTIL IT GETS HERE.
>> WHETHER YOUR NAME IS LOU
GEHRIG OR RIPKEN, YOU ARE
CHALLENGED BY THE GAME OF
BASEBALL TO DO YOUR VERY BEST
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
AND THAT'S ALL I'VE EVER TRIED
TO DO.
♪
MELANIE: MLB ORIGINALS SEASON
TWO IS LIVE ON YOUTUBE WITH NEW
EPISODES EVERY WEEK.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
AND STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
COMPETE ONLINE AND CRUSH DINNERS
IN MLB HOME RUN DERBY.
-- DINGERS IN MLB HOME RUN
DERBY.
PLAY FOR FREE TODAY.
THAT MAY BE THE ONE AREA I CAN
BE ATHLETIC, A DIGITAL
PERFORMANCE.
WE CAN HIT HOME RUNS OFF OF OUR
PHONES.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU ASK FOR?
KITTREDGE TO START THE SIXTH
INNING.
MCCLANAHAN'S DAY IS DONE.
FIVE INNINGS AND SEVEN
STRIKEOUTS FOR MCCLANAHAN.
HE LIMITED THE ORIOLES TO FOUR
HITS AND ONE RUN.
KITTREDGE FACES RYAN
MOUNTCASTLE.
FIRST PITCH STRIKE.
SARAH: KITTREDGE, YOU WILL SEE
SINKER, SLIDER, FOUR-SEAMER,
CHANGEUP.
USES THAT SINKER AND SLIDE UP
ALMOST INTERCHANGEABLY.
FOUR-SEAMER AND CHANGEUP NOT
QUITE AS MUCH.
MELANIE: 31-YEAR-OLD.
HE GETS MOUNTCASTLE TO TIP A
BALL BACK FIRST STRIKE -- BACK F
OR STRIKE TWO.
SARAH: FOR SONY GUYS IN TODAY'S
-- FOR SO MANY GUYS IN
TODAY'S GAME, HIS BEST STUFF HAS
BEEN HIS SLIDER.
GETTING GOOD MOVEMENT ON A
SLIDER AND GETTING THOSE SWINGS
AND MISSES.
MELANIE: HE'S PART OF A BULLPEN
COME OF THE MOST USED IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, AND YET THE
BEST E.R.A.
YOU SIT AND SCRATCH HER HEAD AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT IS
POSSIBLE AND STILL MAINTAINING
LOW PAYROLL.
SARAH: I'M SURE THE RAYS FANS
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IT
AGAIN, BUT WITH THE REMOVAL OF
BLAKE SNELL AND EVERYTHING ELSE,
I WANT TO SAY FOR THE RECORD FOR
EVERYONE LISTENING THAT THIS IS
HOW THE RAYS DO THIS.
REMOVING HIM WAS NOT THE WRONG
MOVE.
MAYBE THE PITCHER WHO CAME IN
HAD NOT LOOKED GOOD THAT
POSTSEASON.
IF ANYTHING, THE THING THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN DONE DIFFERENTLY
WAS WHICH RELIEVER CAME IN.
THAT GETS TO WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
HERE, PUSHING EVERY SINGLE
THREAT BUTTON.
MELANIE: HE PUSHES ALL THE
CORRECT ONES THERE.
HE GETS RYAN MOUNTCASTLE TO
CHASE AND GETS RUNG UP.
ONE AWAY.
ALANNA, WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
RAYS BULLPEN, I THINK WE CAN
PICK KEVIN CASH'S BRAIN ABOUT
THIS FOR DAYS.
YOU HAD A COUPLE PINPOINTED
NOTES ABOUT WHERE THEY ARE
FINDING SUCCESS.
ALANNA: SINCE THEY DON'T HAVE
BLAKE SNELL, CHARLIE MORTON, AND
TYLER GLASNOW, THE BURNING STAFF
HAS STRUGGLED, BUT THE BULLPEN
PICKED UP THE PIECES FOR THE
RAYS TEAM.
KEEP IN MIND AND THEY ARE
WITHOUT KEY ARMS IN THE BULLPEN.
NICK ANDERSON IS OUT.
OLIVER DRAKE IS OUT.
CHAZ ROE IS OUT.
NICK ANDERSON HAD ANOTHER
SESSION TODAY IN TRYING TO GET
BACK ON THE FIELD.
HE HAD A 20 PITCH BULLPENS US IN
TODAY WITH LIVE BP.
THE SECOND ONE HE HAS HAD SO
FAR.
THE NEXT WILL PROBABLY BE IN THE
FLORIDA COMPLEX.
THEY ARE MISSING SOME KEY ARMS
IN THE BULLPEN.
YET THE BULLPEN STILL DOING WHAT
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO AS THEY TRY
TO GET TYLER GLASNOW BACK IN THE
STARTING ROTATION.
THE RAYS ARE IN A TOUGH DIVISION
IN THE AL EAST, YET THEY DO IT
WITH VETERAN TALENT AND AN
INFUSION OF YOUNG TALENT.
MELANIE: SANTANA IS TRYING TO
BEAT OUT -- SANTANDER IS TRYING
TO BEAT OUT A SHORT PLAY.
BRUJAN LAID OUT TO PICK OFF
ANDREW KITTREDGE.
HE GETS THE THROW OFF IN TIME.
AND A PHOTO FINISH THROUGH FIRST
BASE FOR SANTANDER.
CHOI AND NEELY RETURNED TO COVER
-- CHOI IMMEDIATELY RETURNED TO
COVER THE BAG.
SARAH: ALL THESE ROOKIE
INFIELDERS MAKING SPECTACULAR
PLAYS.
I KNOW THERE WAS THE ERA BEFORE,
BUT -- ERROR BEFORE, BUT THIS
MORE THAN MAKES UP FOR THAT.
MELANIE: SANTANDER ROLLED INTO
A DOUBLE PLAY IN THE LAST
INNING.
YOU LOOK BACK AT A ROOKIE CLASS
OF RAYS INFIELDERS.
RAMON URIAS BENDS AWAY.
BALL ONE.
URIAS REACHED ON THE ERROR BY
BRUJAN IN THE FOURTH.
A RARE TWO ERROR DAY FOR RAYS
DEFENSE.
THERE IS A STRIKE AND THE COUNT
EVENS AGAINST URIAS.
URIAS HAS STEPPED UP FOR THE
ORIOLES SINCE HIS RETURN.
THEY INITIALLY HAD FREDDY GALVIS
AND MAIKEL FRANCO AT THE
SHORTSTOP-THIRD BASE COMBO.
THEY ARE BOTH OUT WITH INJURIES
RIGHT NOW.
URIAS HAS BEEN A BIG PART OF
THAT.
AS THE FASTBALL COMES INSIDE.
A 2-1 COUNT.
HE AND THE ACQUISITION OF KELVIN
GUTIERREZ.
PAT VALAIKA HAS MOVED AROUND AS
WELL WHERE THEY NEED HIM.
IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
INFIELD FOR THE ORIOLES.
2-1.
URIAS WHIFFS.
SARAH: AND URIAS HAS DEFINITELY
PLAYED A BETTER SENSE HE HAS
BEEN PLAYING EVERY DAY.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE CASE.
HE GOT ON BASE EARLIER.
I KNOW IT WAS AN ERROR, BUT JUST
GETTING ON BASE SEEMS TO BE PART
OF GETTING INTO THAT RHYTHM.
MELANIE: A TAP ON THE HELMET AS
HE'S TRYING TO CONVINCE HIMSELF
HE HAS TO GET IN THE RHYTHM.
HE SET UP AWAY.
PITCH COMES AWAY.
HE GOLFS IT.
A SHORT DROP TO WANDER FRANCO.
RAYS DEFENSE CAN'T BEAT THIS
ONE.
URIAS GOES GOLFING.
AND HE COMES UP.
SARAH: TWO PLAYS WHERE HE REALLY
PUT PRESSURE ON THEM TO GET ON
BASE.
IT IS NOT THE SAME AS I HOME
RUN, BUT GETTING ON BASE,
HELPING THE TEAM IN THAT WAY.
MELANIE: THE SINGLE FOR RAMON
URIAS.
STARTING TO PICK UP AGAIN.
HE HAS HIT IN FOUR CONSECUTIVE
GAMES.
REACHES OUT AND SLAPS ONE
TOWARDS FRANCO.
ONE ON AND TWO OUT FOR PEDRO
SEVERINO.
ORIOLES TRAIL BY FOUR IN THE
SIXTH.
KITTREDGE COMES IN LOW TO
SEVERINO.
A SINKER.
BALL ONE.
SARAH: 28.1 FEET PER SECOND ON
THE SPRINT SPEED.
I'M GOING TO MENTION IF WE GET
THOSE PLAYS AT FIRST AGAIN, 27
IS LEAGUE AVERAGE.
HE'S NOT SPECIFICALLY KNOWN FOR
HIS SPEED, SO THAT'S PRETTY
GOOD.
IT GOT THE JOB DONE FOR SURE.
MELANIE: KITTREDGE GETS THE CALL
THAT TIME.
SEVERINO WITH A BIT OF A CHECK
ON A SINKER.
SEEMED TO TAIL AWAY FROM THE
ZONE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A ZONE ADJACENT
PITCH.
HOME PLATE UMPIRE BRIAN O'NORA
WILL GIVE IT TO HIM.
1-1 FOR SEVERINO.
AND THERE IS NOTHING ADJACENT
ABOUT THAT.
HE COMES INSIDE.
BALL TWO.
SARAH: WE HAD A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS IN THE LAST GAME I
CALLED WITH BRIAN KENNY AND MARK
DEROSA ABOUT HOW THAT LITTLE BOX
ON THE SCREEN HAS CHANGED THE
WAY WE VIEW UMPIRE CALLS.
I DON'T MEAN FOR THE WORSE OR
THE BETTER.
IT'S JUST INTERESTING HOW YOU
CAN SIT AT HOME AND DEVELOP A
VERY PROVEN OPINION BASED ON THE
FACT THAT IT IS THERE.
MELANIE: AN ARMCHAIR UMPIRE.
IT'S A 2-2 COUNT.
SOMETHING INTERESTING AS WELL,
WE HAVE BEEN PRETTY OPEN WE WANT
TO KEEP THE HUMAN ELEMENT THERE,
BUT WATCHING THE AUTOMATED
STRIKE ZONE, I GOT THE TALK TO A
COUPLE LEAGUES ABOUT IT.
IT IS NOT THE ONE-DIMENSIONAL
ZONE.
AS LONG AS YOU PLATE THAT PITCH
UPFRONT, IT DOES NOT MATTER
WHERE IT LANDS.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE PITCHERS
TRYING TO ADJUST TO THAT.
TIME CALLED AS KITTREDGE TRIES
TO GO INTO MOTION.
SEVERINO IS BACKING UP INTO THE
DUGOUT AT THIS POINT.
SARAH: CONCERNED OF A LITTLE
COLLISION THERE.
MELANIE: HE'S GOING TO GO INTO
THE MAN IN THE ON-DECK CIRCLE,
PAT VALAIKA.
INFIELD SHIFTED TO THE LEFT
AGAINST SEVERINO.
JI-MAN CHOI HOLDS DOWN RAMON
URIAS.
2-2.
SEVERINO CAUGHT LOOKING.
KITTREDGE FREEZES HIM WITH THE
SLIDER AND GETS OUT OF IT AGAIN.
THE RAYS LEAD THE ORIOLES 5-1.
YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
>> RAYS GET THEIR THIRD RUN OF
THE INNING.
♪
>> AND THERE IT IS.
BALL GONE DEEP TO LEFT.
GONE!
LONGORIA HITS A LONG ONE.
A THREE RUN SHOT.
AND NOW IT'S A ONE RUN BALLGAME.
>> BOTTOM OF THE NINTH INNING,
THE YANKEES LEAD THE RAYS 7-6.
THE RAYS JUMPED BACK INTO THIS
GAME WITH A SIXTH RUN EIGHTH.
2-2 AGAIN.
JOHNSON HITS IT DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
THAT BALL IS GOING TO BE FAIR.
AND GONE!
JOHNSON DOES IT AGAIN.
A PINCH HIT HOME RUN TO TIE THIS
GAME IN THE BOTTOM OF THE INNING
AGAINST NEW YORK.
>> BOTTOM OF THE 12, 7-7
BALLGAME HERE.
2-2.
A LINED SHOT DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE.
THAT BALL IS GONE!
AND THE RAYS WIN IT!
A LINE DRIVE HOME RUN BY EVAN
LONGORIA.
AND THE RAYS STORM THE FIELD.
♪
SARAH: WHAT A DAY FOR SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
A CAREER-HIGH IN PITCHES, THE
DEEPEST WE HAVE SEEN HIM GO, 93
PITCHES.
LOOK AT THESE SWINGS AND MISSES.
HE GOT 22 WHIFFS TODAY, THE MOST
OF ANY GAMES IN HIS CAREER.
HE THREW THE MOST PITCHES.
HE BROKE IT BY FIVE OR SIX.
IF YOU LOOK WHERE THESE SWINGS
AND MISSES ARE, WHAT STANDS OUT
IS A LOT OUTSIDE THE ZONE.
YOU SEE THE ORIOLES EXPANDING.
THE ORIOLES HAVE THE
SECOND-HIGHEST CHASE RATE IN THE
MAJORS AT SWINGS ON OUT OF ZONE
PITCHES.
YOU SEE THAT ON DISPLAY HERE.
GREAT OUTING FROM SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
WILL HE SETTLE DOWN MORE LIKE A
SEASONED VETERAN?
HE REALLY DID.
THE ONLY HAD A 1-2-3 INNING
AFTER THAT.
HE SEEMED TO MUCH MORE IN
CONTROL AFTER THE TRAFFIC IN THE
SECOND.
MELANIE: JUST HIS ABILITY TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE SITUATIONS,
NOT SHOWING THE ABILITY TO BE
FAZED AS A ROOKIE.
ON THE POLAR OPPOSITE END, IN
COMES CESAR VALDEZ, THE CHANGEUP
SPECIALIST, WHO TAKES OVER FOR
JOHN MEANS.
HE GETS BRANDON LOWE SWINGING
OUT OF THE GATE.
JOHN MEANS IS DONE.
HIS FIRST GAME BACK COMING OFF
OF AN IL STINT GOING BACK TO
JUNE 5.
HE DID NOT ALLOW A WALK AND
STRUCK OUT TWO.
OVERALL A GOOD BODY OF WORK.
A LOT OF FIRST PITCH STRIKES.
THAT WAS SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO
SEE.
SARAH: DEFINITELY.
THERE IS SOME WORK TO BE DONE
WITH HIM IN TERMS OF GETTING
BACK INTO THAT RHYTHM AND BEING
BACK.
BETTER THAN THOSE FIVE RUNS
INDICATE.
MELANIE: VALDEZ COMES HOME.
ANOTHER STRIKE.
LOWE CAN DO ANYTHING AGAINST IT.
1-2.
SARAH: MEANS MISSED WITH A
HANDFUL OF PITCHES UP, WHICH IS
A CONCERN.
OVERALL SEEING THE FIRST PITCH
STRIKES AND THAT CONTROL WAS
GOOD IN THIS FIRST OUTING
BACK.
MELANIE: INSIDE.
THE COUNT EVENS.
VALDEZ WAS ASSIGNED OUT OF THE
MEXICAN LEAGUE LAST WINTER AND
BECAME SOMEONE EVERYONE FELL IN
LOVE WITH.
HE THROWS A PITCH CALLED THE
DEAD FISH.
HE HAS ABOUT FIVE DIFFERENT
CHANGEUPS.
PEDRO SEVERINO CAN SIGNAL A
CHANGEUP, BUT HE DOES NOT KNOW
WHICH CHANGEUP IS COMING HOME.
A 2-2.
A SWING TO THE KNEE FOR BRANDON
LOWE.
CESAR VALDEZ BATTLING HERE.
LOWE TAPS JUST A PIECE OF IT.
HE ALTERS THE ARM ANGLE ON THE
CHANGEUP.
THAT GIVES HIM THAT DIFFERENT
VARIETY.
FIVE DIFFERENT CHANGEUPS AS YOU
SEE HERE.
I SAID, SEVERINO, HOW DO YOU
KNOW WHAT IS COMING HOME?
HE SMILED AND SAID I DON'T, I
JUST HOPE I AM MOBILE.
SARAH: TO THE POINT YOU WERE
MAKING EARLIER ABOUT PEDRO
SEVERINO AND WHAT IT IS TO CATCH
THIS PITCHING STAFF, THIS IS NOT
ONE OF THE YOUNG PITCHERS WE
WERE REFERRING TO BEFORE.
IT IS ONE OF THE LIST SEASONED
-- LESS SEASONED PITCHERS AT THE
MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL.
MELANIE: LOWE CHASES AFTER A
CHANGEUP AMONG BUT POPS IT FOUL.
SARAH: THIS IS THE PERFECT PITCH
ER TO DROP THE SEQUENCE ON.
WHOEVER DECIDED WE NEED TO DROP
THAT HERE, CESAR VALDEZ THROWS
HIS CHANGEUP 77% OF THE TIME,
WHICH IS REALLY FUN.
THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF ON THE
SCREEN RIGHT NOW, BUT HE'S
PRETTY MUCH JUST THROWING YOU
THAT CHANGEUP.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT ONES, BUT
77% OF THE TIME CHANGEUPS.
MELANIE: LOWE RIPS A PITCH.
SHIFTED, PAT VALAIKA SENDS IT TO
MANCINI.
YOU JUST SAW BRANDON LOWE THERE.
YOU LOVE TO HEAR HIM MIC'ED UP.
WE GOT A LITTLE MORE ON HIM.
>> IF YOU PUT IT ON A GRAHAM
CRACKER, IT TAKES UP THE WHOLE
GRAHAM CRACKER.
>> HE PUT LIKE SIX IN HIS
MOUTH.
>> I APOLOGIZED, SORRY YOU GUYS
HAD TO LISTEN IN ON THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> I HAD A HEATED ARGUMENT ABOUT
MARSHMALLOWS.
27 YEARS OLD.
MELANIE: 27 YEARS OLD, WHAT ELSE
WILL YOU ARGUE ABOUT DURING THE
GAME EXCEPT HOW MARSHMALLOWS FIT
ON A GRAHAM CRACKER?
BUT HERE'S THE OTHER THING TOO.
BRANDON IS MARRIED TO ANOTHER
FORMER MARYLAND TERRAPIN AND HIS
WIFE.
SHE HAS A BAKERY.
MAYBE HE IS DOING RESEARCH FOR
HER, SHE HAS SOME KIND OF
MARSHMALLOW CONVECTION.
I HEAR THEY ARE AMAZING, BY THE
WAY.
MEJIA FOULS OFF THE OFFERING
FROM VALDEZ.
HE HAS EVERYTHING.
SELF ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
OUTFIELD, HITTING ADVICE, HE'S
READING METRICS.
YOU HAVE TO GO INTO YOUR S'MORES
COVERAGE.
SARAH: I'M HUNGRY NO END WANT A
-- HUNGRY NOW AND WANT A S'MORE.
THESE ALL GET ARCHIVED.
YOU CAN WATCH THIS ON YOUTUBE.
I THINK IT COMES OUT THE NEXT
MONDAY.
OUR AWESOME MLB SOCIAL TEAM PUTS
IT TOGETHER.
MELANIE: AND A CHOPPED BALL BACK
TO TREY MANCINI BY FRANCISCO
MEJIA.
TWO RETIRED FOR IT SEES ARE
VALDEZ.
SARAH: OUR MLB SOCIAL TEAM PUTS
THIS ALTOGETHER.
SO MUCH MORE YOU ARE NOT HEARING
NOW THAT YOU WILL HEAR WHEN YOU
GO ONTO YOUTUBE.
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
THERE ARE SUBTITLES SO YOU CAN
KEEP TRACK OF EVERYTHING.
THEY TELL THE STORY OF THE GAME
AS YOU PLAY EVERYTHING.
IT'S SO AWESOME.
CHECK THOSE OUT THAT ARE ALREADY
THERE FROM PAST GAMES.
DEFINITELY LOOK OUT FOR THIS ONE
NEXT WEEK.
MELANIE: MIC'ED UP HAS BEEN A
FAN BELOVED THING THAT HAS COME
INTO SPORTS LATELY.
I AGREE, IT'S SUCH A COOL
CHANNEL TO CHECK OUT.
ANOTHER FIRST PITCH STRIKE FROM
CESAR VALDEZ, THIS TIME TO
JI-MAN CHOI.
VALDEZ HAD A ROUGH FINISH TO THE
FIRST HALF OF THE SEASON.
HIS LAST 14 OR SO OUTINGS HAVE
NOT BEEN GREAT.
THEIR FIRST GAME AGAINST THE
ROYALS TO START THE SECOND HALF
OF THE SEASON, HE DID THROW
THREE INNINGS AGAINST A YOUNG
KEEGAN AKIN.
HE DID NOT ALLOW ANY RUNS TO
SCORE OFF HIM.
SARAH: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW
MUCH HE USES THE CHANGEUP, WHICH
IS FREQUENTLY, 77%.
GUYS HAVE HIT .328 AGAINST IT,
SO NOT NECESSARILY WHAT YOU WANT
TO SEE.
MELANIE: 1-1 TO CHOI.
HE GOES DOWN TO A KNEE AFTER A
CHANGEUP.
HE DOES HAVE OTHER PITCHES,
SINKER, FASTBALL AND SLIDER.
NOTHING THAT TOUCHES THE 90'S.
HE'S A STARTER IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC.
AND AN ELECTRIC ONE THAT -- ONE
AT THAT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT RIPPING HIS
JERSEY AFTER DELIVERING A
PERFORMANCE IN FRONT OF A
SCREAMING STAND OF FANS.
THE BULLPEN WITH THE ORIOLES,
THEY ADORE HIM.
THEY KEEP IT LOOSE.
THEY PLAY GAMES IN THE BULLPEN
BEFORE THE GAME STARTS.
A LOT OF YOUNG GUYS HAVE GLEANED
A LOT FROM CESAR VALDEZ.
SARAH: YOU GET THE SENSE HE IS
ONE OF THOSE FUN PLAYERS.
I FEEL LIKE PEOPLE ARE SO
EXCITED WHEN HE MADE THIS ROSTER
FOR THAT REASON.
ANYONE WITH A PITCH THAT IS
CALLED DEAD FISH YOU WANT TO BE
SEEING.
YOU KNOW THERE IS SO MUCH
PERSONALITY THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT.
MELANIE: HE IS ONE OF THE OLDEST
ON THE ORIOLES TEAM.
THEIR POSITION PLAYERS ARE
AMONGST THE YOUNGEST IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
FULL COUNT TO CHOI.
CLEAN INNING, CESAR VALDEZ.
RAYS WITH A 5-1 LEAD OVER THE
ORIOLES.
WE HEAD TO THE SEVENTH.
YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB ON YOUD
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
♪
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> HIGH FLY BALL CENTER FIELD.
IT'S DEEP.
BACK, BACK, BACK.
AND OUT OF HERE.
MOUNTCASTLE.
TOUCH THEM ALL, RYAN.
A LINE DRIVE DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE.
THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
JUST GOT OUT.
THERE'S A SHOT DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
HE HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
RYAN MOUNTCASTLE WITH THREE HOME
RUNS.
>> 1-2 PITCH.
A BASE HIT INTO CENTER FIELD.
>> THEY BE A HOME RUN.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
CEDRIC MULLINS HAS LEFT THE
BUILDING.
>> MULLINS WITH A SHOT DEEP
RIGHT.
IS IT ENOUGH?
YES IT IS.
HE HAS GOT HIMSELF ANOTHER HIT.
A FOUR HIT DAY FOR CEDRIC
MULLINS.
HE'S 5-5.
CEDRIC MULLINS, THEY CAN'T GET
HIM OUT.
♪
MELANIE: WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
THE RAYS AND HOW EFFECTIVE THEIR
BULLPEN HAS BEEN DESPITE BEING
ONE OF THE MOST USED ACROSS
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
SOME GUYS OUT IN THE TANK TODAY.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS
ACROSS THE BOARD.
GUYS AMONGST DIEGO CASTILLO,
ANDREW KITTREDGE AND PETE
FAIRBANKS.
THAT 3.20 E.R.A. COLLECTIVELY
FOR THE TEAM LEADS THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
33 WINS ALSO PICKED UP BY THE
BULLPEN AS WELL.
AN ABSOLUTE DOMINATING
PERFORMANCE AT A TIME WHEN THAT
IS EVERY OTHER TEAM'S ACHILLES
HEEL, THE BULLPEN IS BEING SO
USED AND BREAKING DOWN AND
LOSING BECAUSE OF IT.
SARAH: THEY ARE ON A DIFFERENT
LEVEL WITH HOW THEY MANAGE THIS
BULLPEN.
AS WE LOOK AT CONTENDERS, MOST
CONTENDERS NEED A RELIEVER, BUT
THIS CONTENDER DOESN'T.
THEY ARE DOING IT COMPLETELY
RIGHT.
INTERESTING TO SEE.
MELANIE: JEFFREY SPRINGS TAKES
OVER, THE LEFT-HANDED PITCHER
AFTER ANDREW KITTREDGE TOSSES
FOR JUSTIN INNING.
FIRST PITCH STRIKE TO PAT
VALAIKA.
ALANNA, THIS RAYS BULLPEN IS A
TOUGH ONE TO AVOID TALKING
ABOUT.
ALANNA: THEY HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY STRONG.
THEY LEAVE THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
WITHIN EARNED RUN AVERAGE.
EVEN WITH KEY ARMS WE TALKED
ABOUT BEING INJURED, YOU LOOK AT
THE WAY THEY PUT THINGS TOGETHER
AND SOME NOTABLE RELIEVERS, YOU
LOOK AT THE SALARIES OF THIS
GUY.
COLLIN MCHUGH IS THE HIGH MAN
ROLLING AT $1.8 MILLION.
THEY ARE FINDING WAYS TO MAKE IT
WORK, DEALING WITH INJURIES AND
THE PAYROLL.
MELANIE: SOMETHING TOO WE HAVE
HEARD IS WHEN YOU GET A MIX OF
GUYS LIKE THIS, THEY ARE PRETTY
AMICABLE TO GOING TO ANYWHERE
YOU NEED THEM.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
HE RINGS UP PAT VALAIKA.
JEFFREY SPRINGS FREEZES VALAIKA
IN HIS TRACKS.
THE FIRST MAN HE COMES ON TO
FACE IN THE SEVENTH, IT'S A
STRIKEOUT.
SO HE WORKS SINKER, SINKER,
SINKER, AND SINKER.
AND PAT VALAIKA DOES NOT PICK UP
ON IT.
SPRINGS IS A SINKER, SLIDER, AND
CHANGEUP COMBINATION.
CAME THROUGH AS A STARTER IN THE
TEXAS RANGERS SYSTEM.
ALANNA: JUST TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, THAT IS WHAT MAKES A
GOOD TEAM, WHEN THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MOVE OVER THE FIELD.
NOT JUST DEFENSIVELY, BUT ARMS
WILLING TO COME IN ANY TIME THE
PHONE RINGS.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
ROLES IN THE BULLPEN.
THE RAYS HAVE DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY FOR A LONG TIME WITH
THEIR PAYROLL AND HOW DIFFICULT
THIS DIVISION IS.
THE BOSTON RED SOX, WHO NOBODY
THOUGHT THEY WOULD BEAT.
TEMPO GETS IT DONE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY.
-- TAMPA GETS IT DONE IN A
LOOK AT THE WALKIE BREWERS DOING
IT DIFFERENT AS WELL IN THE
POSTSEASON.
THEY START TRENDS AND IT IS
EFFECTIVE FOR THEM.
MELANIE: THEY ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE WAY BASEBALL
CHANGES.
THIS STEM TO BACK SEVERAL YEARS.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE SHIFT
TO FIND A WAY TO GET WINS
AGAINST THOSE BIG GLOVES AND IT
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR THEM.
1-2.
GUTIERREZ ARGUES HE DID NOT GO,
BUT THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
HE DID.
BACK-TO-BACK STRIKEOUTS FOR
JEFFREY SPRINGS.
LET'S LOOK AT HOW THIS
BREAKDOWN -- THIS BREAKS DOWN.
SINCE 2008, HIGHEST WINNING
PERCENTAGE ACROSS MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL, DODGERS, YANKEES,
CARDINALS, RED SOX, YOU EXPECT
THOSE.
THE TAMPA BAY RAYS, 5.41 WINNING
PERCENTAGE AND $61 MILLION
PAYROLL, LESS THAN THE
TOP-SEEDED DODGERS.
ALANNA: IT WAS FUNNY BECAUSE
WHEN WE WERE TALKING TO THE
ORIOLES SKIPPER, HE LAUGHED AND
SAID WE DON'T HAVE A HIGH
PAYROLL.
THESE TEAMS ARE COMPARABLE IN
THAT YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET THE
SUPERSTAR PLAYERS, BUT YOU HAVE
GUYS THAT HAVE MORE OF A
WILLINGNESS TO MOVE AROUND TO
DIFFERENT POSITIONS TO KEEP THEM
IN THE LINEUP.
I GUARANTEE THEY WOULD RATHER
PAY ANY -- PLAY ANY POSITION IN
THE MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL THAN BE A
SHORTSTOP IN AAA.
THESE TWO TEAMS ARE GOING IN
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS THIS YEAR,
BUT YOU HAVE TO APPRECIATE HOW
THEY GO ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS.
MELANIE: YOU CAN ARGUE IT IS
EXPECTED TO SEE THEM GO IN
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
IT IS JUST A MATTER OF THE
BUILDING THE BLUEPRINT AND THE
RAYS HAVE BUILT A GOOD ONE.
AND THE ORIOLES ARE VERY MUCH
INSTEP WITH EACH OTHER IN THE
PLAN THAT IS AT HAND.
BRANDON HYDE'S CONTRACT IS NOT
BASED ON WINS AND LOSSES THIS
YEAR, IT IS BASED ON DEVELOPMENT
OF OVERALL TALENT.
MULLINS IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
PRODUCTS.
BRANDON HYDE SAID WE KNEW THE
POWER WAS THERE, BUT THE
CONSISTENCY -- THIS IS A GUY
THAT NOT ONLY GOT SENT DOWN FROM
THE BIG LEAGUES, HE WENT TO
DOUBLE-A IN THE SAME YEAR HE HAD
HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT.
YOU TALK ABOUT HAVING TO FIND
SOMETHING IN YOURSELF TO BRING
YOURSELF BACK TO THE BIG STAGE.
ONE OF THE TOP THREE WINS ABOVE
REPLACEMENT FOR ALL AMERICAN
LEAGUE POSITION PLAYERS.
SARAH: IT'S FASCINATING TO HEAR
THAT BRANDON HYDE SAY THEY KNEW
THE POWER WAS THERE.
HE HAS A 40% HARD-HIT RATE THIS
YEAR.
MELANIE: WE WILL GET BACK TO
THAT THOUGHT.
HE GOES AFTER AN ELEVATED
FASTBALL FROM JEFFREY SPRINGS,
WHO STRIKES OUT THE SIDE IN THE
SEVENTH.
TO THE STRETCH.
THE RAYS HAVE A 5-1 LEAD ON THE
ORIOLES.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> THERE'S A LITTLE LIFE TO THE
RAYS NOW.
HE SWINGS.
HITS IT HIGH AND DEEP AND GONE.
HOME RUN.
FRANCO'S FIRST OF THE BIG
LEAGUES WILL TIE THIS GAME.
FIRST BIG LEAGUE HOME RUN.
TIE GAME.
CURTAIN CALL.
>> SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE DEEP
TO LEFT FIELD.
ON ITS WAY, HIS FIRST BIG-LEAGUE
HIT.
THREE RUN HOMER.
5-5.
>> WANDER FRANCO MAKING HIMSELF
AT HOME IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
A THREE RUN HOMER.
AND IT IS A BRAND-NEW GAME.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
♪
MELANIE: YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES.
WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING WHAT
THEY ARE BUILDING BENEATH.
IT IS A FORCE TO BE RECKONED
WITH.
THEY HAVE THE NUMBER ONE OVERALL
CATCHING RANKED PROSPECT IN
ADLEY RUTSCHMAN.
THEY HAVE READY IN LEFTY PITCH
ERS WHO ARE ALSO -- RIGHTY AND
LEFTY PITCHERS WHO ARE ALSO TOP
RANKED.
GUNNAR HENDERSON.
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
NAMES RANKED TOP SEVEN BY
BASEBALL AMERICA, TOP FIVE BY
OTHER COMPONENTS AS WELL.
WHAT THEY HAVE BUILT IS JUST
AMAZING TO SEE.
THEY HAVE REOPENED THEIR
INTERNATIONAL PIPELINE WITH
EXPECTATIONS THEIR DOMINICAN
ACADEMY WILL BE OPEN AND
OPERATING IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
TAYLOR WALLS SWINGS ON AN 0-1
INTO ANTHONY SANTANDER'S GLOVE
INTO RIGHT FIELD.
TWO PITCHES.
WALLS RETIRED BY CESAR VALDEZ.
AND IT'S A 5-1 BALLGAME.
THOSE PREGAME ODDS BY FANDUEL
SPORTS BOOK, THE OVER-UNDER AT
7.5.
SARAH, YOU HAVE A SMIRK ON YOUR
FACE.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH: I TOOK THE UNDER AND IT
DID NOT LOOK GOOD.
NOW IT LOOKS MAY BE A LITTLE
BETTER.
PITCHING SETTLED DOWN ON BOTH
SIDES.
MELANIE: YOU ARE IN THE DAY FOR
FLETCHER ZONE AGAIN OF
PRODUCTIONS.
-- DAVID FLETCHER ZONE AGAIN OF
PREDICTIONS.
VALDEZ DELIVERS TO KIERMAIER.
RIGHT BACK TO VALDEZ.
HE TAKES A LOOK AT IT AND
FINALLY DISPOSES OF IT.
KIERMAIER RETIRED.
TWO AWAY.
ALANNA, YOU HAVE STUFF ON THIS
ORIOLES FARM SYSTEM.
ALANNA: YOU HEARD TREY MANCINI
SAY EARLIER TODAY THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF YOUNG GUYS ON THIS
CURRENT TEAM.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET
REINFORCEMENTS.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE LAST TIME
THIS ORIOLES TEAM THAT WAS
RELEVANT IN 2016.
BASEBALL AMERICA HAD THEM RANKED
AS THE 27TH FARM SYSTEM OUT OF
30.
YOU COME TO 2021, THEY ARE
RANKED AS SEVENTH IN TERMS OF
THEIR UPCOMING PROSPECTS.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST RANKING
BASEBALL AMERICA HAS EVER GIVEN
THE ORIOLES IN THEIR 30 YEAR
HISTORY.
REINFORCEMENTS ARE CERTAINLY
COMING FOR THIS CLUB.
MELANIE: THEY HAVE BEEN FUN TO
WATCH.
AROZARENA SMACKS THE BALL TO
GUTIERREZ.
THE THIRD-BASE MAN TOSSES ACROSS
THE DIAMOND.
CESAR VALDEZ IS ROLLING.
THROUGH TWOCLEANED.
WE HEAD TO THE EIGHTH.
YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> CAL, AS YOU KNOW, THE
BASEBALL GAME WILL BECOME
OFFICIAL IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
INNING WITH THE ORIOLES HAVING
THE LEAD.
ANY THOUGHTS IN YOUR MIND AS YOU
TAKE THE FIELD?
>> NO, I WISH I HAD A GREAT
STORY FOR YOU.
IT SEEMED LIKE THE ATTITUDE WAS
MORE LIKE A NO-HITTER.
YOU DID NOT WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
IN CASE YOU ARE GOING TO JINX
IT.
WE ALL WANTED TO KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN FOR WEEKS
BEFORE.
IN THE FIFTH INNING, THEY
STARTED DROPPING THE NUMBER ON
THE WAREHOUSE.
THE SONG THAT WOULD BE PLAYED,
THAT SURPRISED ME.
I WASN'T IN ON ANY PLANNING
SESSION.
WHAT IS THAT?
I GO OH, THAT IS WHAT THAT
MEANS.
IT IS A COUNTDOWN, OR COUNT UP.
THERE WERE A COUPLE TIMES WHEN
YOU STARTED TO THINK ABOUT YOUR
WHOLE CAREER AND HOW YOU GOT TO
THIS POINT.
IT STARTED TO GET YOU A LITTLE
CHOKED UP.
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT YOUR MOM
AND DAD AND EVERYONE THAT WAS
HELPFUL TO THIS POINT.
IT WAS LIKE RELIVING YOUR CAREER
STANDING AT THE FIFTH INNING A
WEEK BEFORE.
WE GOT CONDITIONED BY THE MUSIC
AND DROPPING BY THE NUMBER.
WHEN IT BECAME OFFICIAL, I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN THEN.
MELANIE: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
TO POWER STATCAST WITH A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF DATA POINTS, TAKING
YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME THAN
EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
SOME EAGER FANS.
I HOPE THEY ARE GETTING A
SOUVENIR.
SHE'S GOT THE HELMET ON AND
READY FOR IT.
RAYS HAVE NOT ALLOWED ANYTHING
INTO THE STANDS LATELY.
FIVE OF THE LAST SEVVEN BATTERS
THAT HAVE BEEN RETIRED HAVE BEEN
BY WAY OF THE STRIKEOUT.
ANDREW KITTREDGE WITH TWO OF HIS
OWN.
JEFFREY SPRINGS FANS THE SIDE IN
THE SEVENTH.
AND ANOTHER NEW PITCHER ON THE
MOUND, JP FEYEREISEN TO FACE
AUSTIN HAYS.
HE COMES UP INSIDE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A MISFIRE.
SARAH: ONE OF THE PITCHERS THEY
GOT IN THE ADAMES TRADE, WHICH
IS PROBABLY WORKED OUT BETTER
FOR THE BREWERS, SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER SINCE THEY GOT ADAMES,
BUT FEYEREISEN A GOOD PITCHER.
FOUR-SEAMER, CHANGEUP.
FOUR-SEAMER AVERAGING 93.
HE'S NOT THROWING SUPERDUPER
HARD.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT WITH TWO OF
THE RELIEVERS FROM THE RAYS.
THEY HAVE SOME GUYS WHO ARE
GETTING IT DONE WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT VELOCITY THIS YEAR.
MELANIE: YOU ARE SEEING EMOTION
BACK INTO THAT, OF NOT HAVING TO
HAVE TRIPLE DIGITS ON EVERY
PITCH.
A 1-1 AT HAYS.
SMACKS A BREAKING BALL FOUL.
YOU MENTIONED THAT TRADE.
ONE OF THE BIGGER ONES EARLY IN
THE SEASON TO MOVE WILLY ADAMES.
TREVOR RICHARDS GOES ALONG WITH
HIM.
THEY ACQUIRE GP FEYEREISEN AND
DREW RASMUSSEN.
TWO RIGHT-HANDED PITCHERS OUT OF
THE BULLPEN COMING TAMPA BAY'S
WAY.
THAT WAS MAY 21 OF THIS YEAR.
HAYS SLAPS OUT AGAIN.
THIS ONE A LOW SHOT TO WANDER
FRANCO.
THIS ONE TICKS OFF INTO THE
BULLPEN.
HAYS JOGS IN SAFELY.
A LONG LOOK BACK.
THE DEFENSE THIS EVENING DESPITE
THE RAYS OUTHITTING THE
ORIOLES, ALLOWING MORE BASE
RUNNERS THAN WHAT WOULD BE.
FRANCO CAME IN WITH A LOW SCOOP
OFF THAT PITCH.
JUST AIR MAILS IT OVER CHOI'S
HEAD.
SARAH: YOU DO WONDER.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
VERSATILITY, THE FACT THAT HE
PLAYED THREE POSITIONS SINCE HE
CAME UP.
THE MAJORITY OF HIS EXPERIENCE
WAS AT SHORTSTOP.
YOU DO WONDER IF SOME OF THIS IS
THAT UNFAMILIARITY ON THAT
PARTICULAR THROW.
MELANIE: HAYS AT SECOND.
MANCINI CHASES.
HAYS OFFICIALLY REACHES SECOND
BASE.
THAT IS A STRAIGHT UP THROWING
ERROR CHARGED TO WANDER FRANCO.
THIRD ERROR OF THE GAME FOR THE
RAYS.
FEYEREISEN DELIVERS.
MANCINI FOULS IT OFF.
0-2.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT MANCINI HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
THE MAN DOES NOT PULL A LOT.
HE LIKES TO SEND EVERYTHING TO
THE DEAD CENTER OF THE BALLPARK.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
HEARTBREAKING MOMENTS WHERE HE
THOUGHT HE HAD IT AND IT CAME AN
INCH SHY IN THESE BIGGER PARKS.
SARAH: YOU CAN SEE HIS SECOND
HIGHEST RATE OF NON- PULL BELT
RUNS WITH A MINIMUM OF 10 RUNS.
REALLY NOT GOING THERE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE'S HITTING FOR
POWER.
MELANIE: CAMDEN YARDS IS A
LITTLE MORE FRIENDLY TO HIS
POWER WHEN YOU COMPARE IT TO
PLACES LIKE TROPICANA FIELD AND
CITI FIELD.
THEY ARE BIG SPACES TO OCCUPY.
SARAH: ONLY JD MARTINEZ AHEAD OF
HIM IN TERMS OF NON-PULL RATE ON
HOME RUNS.
TWO RED SOX ON THERE.
THEN YOU HAVE TOMMY PHAM AND
RYAN ZIMMERMAN.
ALL OF THEM 80% PLUS.
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
NON-PULLED HOME RUNS.
MELANIE: MANCINI WOULD LIKE TO
DRIVE ONE HOME HERE.
HE LIFTS IT OUT TO RIGHT FIELD.
LOWE IS BACK IN FRONT OF THE
WALL AND COMES UP WITH IT.
AUSTIN HAYS TAGS.
HE WILL ADVANCE TO THIRD.
MANCINI SENDS IT TO RIGHT, BUT
NOT DEEP ENOUGH.
ONE OUT FOR THE ORIOLES AND A
MAN AT THIRD FOR RYAN
MOUNTCASTLE.
SARAH: I WANT TO GET BACK TO THE
DEFENSE.
YOU MENTIONED THE THREE ERRORS.
THE LAST TIME THE RAYS, AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THEIR DEFENSE,
A TEAM THAT PLAYS GOOD
FUNDAMENTAL BASEBALL -- THE LAST
TIME THEY HAD THREE OR MORE A
WAS IN A GAME WAS MAY 2019.
I KNOW IT IS ONLY AUGUST, JULY
RIGHT NOW -- I DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT APPARENTLY.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THEY HAVE
DONE IN A WHILE.
AND NOT THE ONLY GAME WHERE THEY
HAD MORE THAN TWO ERRORS SINCE
THE START OF 2019.
SO VERY UNCOMMON MAYBE TO BE
EXPECTED.
MELANIE: LAST YEAR, WHEN THE
RAYS CAME UP TO BALTIMORE, THE
ORIOLES PUSHED SEVERAL ERRORS
AGAINST THEM AS WELL.
IT IS ALSO THEIR FIRST TIME
PLAYING OUTSIDE OF THE TROPICANA
ZONE.
1-1 COUNT FOR RYAN MOUNTCASTLE.
HE HAS STRUCK OUT THREE TIMES
THIS EVENING.
FEYEREISEN DELIVERS AND PUTS HIM
ON THE ROPES.
1-2.
AGAIN, MOUNTCASTLE, WE HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT THE VISIBILITY --
THE VERSATILITY.
MOUNTCASTLE HAS BEEN MOVED ALL
OVER FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
HE HAS HAD A SIGNIFICANT TIME IN
LEFT FIELD FOR THE ORIOLES.
NOW HE IS A LITTLE BIT AT HOME.
HE STARES AT A PITCH OUTSIDE.
IT IS A TO BE TO COUNT.
A ROOKIE WHO HAS HAD TO MAKE --
IT IS A 2-2 COUNT.
A ROOKIE WHO HAS HAD TO MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
87 GAMES.
14 R.B.I.S, THAT IS SECOND.
HE IS IN THE TOP FIVE FOR
ORIOLES.
BRANDON LOWE IS GETTING HIS WORK
IN.
AUSTIN HAYS SCORES WITH EASE.
ORIOLES CUT THE LEAD TO 5-2 IN
THE EIGHTH.
AS YOU MENTIONED, LOWE STILL
ADJUSTING TO THE OUTFIELD.
RAYS: DEFINITELY.
WE HEARD HIM BEFORE GETTING SOME
ADVICE.
IT IS DEFINITELY INTERESTED TO
SEE THE ERROR EARLIER BY WANDER
FRANCO, AND WE HAVE THIS AS
WELL.
IN THAT GAME I MENTIONED IN MAY
2019, THEY HAD FOUR ERRORS.
THAT IS THE HIGH WATERMARK AT
LEAST OVER THESE PAST THREE
SEASONS.
MELANIE: NOT EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WANT TO SEE IF YOU ARE THE RAYS.
FEYEREISEN OUTSIDE TO SANTANDER.
THAT WILL GO IN AS AN E-9,
CHARGED TO LOWE.
TWO ERRORS HERE IN THE EIGHTH
INNING.
FEYEREISEN FIERS.
IT IS FOULED OFF.
SANTANDER, WE HAVE GOT TO GIVE
SOME LOVE TO THE INTERNATIONAL
FAN BASE AS WELL.
THE U.K. FAN BASE LOVES ANTHONY
SANTANDER.
I KNOW WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
SHOHEI OHTANI AND HOW JAPAN HAS
LOVED FOLLOWING HIS CAREER.
BUT I HAVE NOT REALLY SEEN
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT A NATIVE OF
THE COUNTRY HAVE SUCH A BIG
FOLLOWING AS MUCH AS U.K. FANS
LOVE SANTANDER.
KIERMAIER COMES UP WITH IT.
MOUNTCASTLE IS CHARGING.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE IS SHORT.
MOUNTCASTLE COMES HOME TO SCORE
FROM FIRST.
SANTANDER SENDS IT INTO THE RAYS
TANK.
THEY GET TO WATCH IT FALL RIGHT
IN FRONT.
THEY LONG DOUBLE, ANTHONY
SANTANDER.
ORIOLES FINDING LIFE HERE IN THE
EIGHTH.
RAYS: THIS IS NOT WHAT WE
EXPECTED FROM THE RAYS BULLPEN.
IT REALLY DOES SHOW WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO PLAY GOOD DEFENSE.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS SUPER SIMPLE.
EVERYONE IS SAYING, OF COURSE.
PLEASE SEE BOTH OF THOSE FRONTS
COMING AROUND TO SCORE -- BUT
YOU SEE BOTH OF THOSE RUN'S
COMING AROUND TO SCORE AFTER
THOSE ERRORS.
MELANIE: FIRST BASE COACH
ANTHONY SANDERS SAID YOU LOOK AT
MOUNTCASTLE AND HE ACTUALLY HAS
DECEPTIVE SPEED.
PUTTING IT ON DISPLAY.
SANTANDER, HIS 17TH DOUBLE OF
THE SEASON.
HIS SECOND THIS EVENING.
RAYS: TO YOUR POINT ON -- SARAH:
TO YOUR POINT ON THAT SPEED.
THAT IS RIGHT THERE AT THE MLB
AVERAGE, WHICH IS WHAT IS
EXPECTED OUT OF RYAN
MOUNTCASTLE.
THAT IS WHERE YOU TAKE THOSE
EXTRA BASES.
MELANIE: WITH A RUNNER AT SECOND
AND ONE AWAY, THE ORIOLES HAVE
RALLIED FOR TWO RUNS IN THE
INNING SO FAR OFF OF JP
FEYEREISEN, AND TWO ERRORS.
URIAS CHASES AFTER THE PITCH
FROM FEYEREISEN.
0-1.
PICKED UP A SINGLE AND THE
FIFTH, REACHED ON AN ERROR IN
THE FOURTH.
A GREAT COMMENT RIGHT NOW ON THE
CHAT GOING ON ON THE YOUTUBE
PITCH.
SPICY.
THINGS ARE GETTING INTERESTING.
0-1.
IT GETS AWAY.
SANTANDER ADVANCES TO THIRD.
HE IS IN THE HEAD OF THE THROW.
URIAS WITH THE 1-1 COUNT.
SANTANDER NOT WITH THE QUICKEST
BREAK TO GET INTO THIRD.
FRANCISCO MEJIA SLID OUT TO HIS
LEFT.
IN SAFELY ALL THE SAME.
BALL TWO.
PETER FAIRBANKS IS WARMING UP
FOR THE RAYS.
A GUY WHO WAS TEAMMATES OF THE
TEXAS SYSTEM.
SPRINGS SAID, THOSE EYES YOU ARE
SEEING, HE HAS ALWAYS DONE THAT.
IT IS VERY INTIMIDATING.
2-1.
WHIFFS AT A FASTBALL.
SARAH: THIS IS SOMETHING THE
INTERNET NOTICED POSTSEASON LAST
YEAR.
I REMEMBER THAT COMING UP.
IT IS FUN WHEN THERE ARE LITTLE
THINGS LIKE THAT TO BE ABLE TO
PICK UP ON.
MELANIE: IT IS UP TO FEYEREISEN
FOR NOW.
2-2 COUNT.
IT IS OUTSIDE.
FULL COUNT.
21 PITCHES FOR JP FEYEREISEN.
E-5, FLY OUT, E-9, AND A DOUBLE.
IN FIELDS DRAWN -- INFIELD DRAWN
IN WITH SANTANDER AT THIRD.
ORIOLES HAVE CUT THE DEFICIT TO
TWO RUNS.
YOU CAN GO BEHIND THE SCENES,
WATCH EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEWS,
HIGHLIGHTS, AND MORE ON THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
HEAD TO YOUTUBE.COM/ORIOLES AND
SUBSCRIBE TODAY.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF COOL STUFF
GOING ON.
A LOT OF PLAYERS WITH SOME
AMAZING BACKGROUND STORIES.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF FUN WITH IT.
PAYOFF AGAIN AND URIAS DOES NOT
TAKE.
IT IS A WALK.
MEN ON THE CORNERS FOR THE
ORIOLES HERE IN THE EIGHTH.
THAT WILL BRING OUT MANAGER
KEVIN CASH.
THAT DOES IT FOR J.P. FEYEREISEN
.
TO THE BULLPEN, THE RAYS GO.
YOU ARE WATCHING MLB'S GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
>> I AM TYLER GLASNOW, PITCHER
FOR THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
>> WHERE DID TYLER GLASNOW GO TO
HIGH SCHOOL?
>> I WENT TO PART HIGH SCHOOL.
-- I WENT TO HEART HIGH SCHOOL.
BOB WALKER, PITCHER FOR THE
PIRATES.
WHERE DID TYLER GLASNOW GO TO
COLLEGE?
>> I DIDN'T.
I AM JUST A STUPID JOCK WHO
THROWS HARD.
WHERE IS TYLER GLASNOW FROM?
I AM FROM SANTA CLARITA,
CALIFORNIA, A LITTLE BIT NORTH
OF LOS ANGELES.
WHERE IS TYLER GLASNOW NOW?
I AM RIGHT HERE.
I AM IN ST. PETE, GETTING READY
FOR SPRING TRAINING.
MELANIE: MLB AND T-MOBILE ARE
BRINGING A NEW DERBY EXPERIENCE
DEFENSE.
THIS ON ENTERED REALITY APP
PROVIDES UNPRECEDENTED 3D VIEWS
AND BALL TRACKING FOR THE HOME
RUN DERBY.
DOWNLOAD TODAY AT MLB.COM/AR.
A LOT COOL FEATURES HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT OUT IN RECENT YEARS BY
TECHNOLOGY.
THE RAYS UTILIZING ALL OF THEM
TO HAVE AN EFFECTIVE BULLPEN.
PETE FAIRBANKS.
FEYEREISEN ISSUED A DOUBLE TO
SANTANDER, A WALK TO URIAS.
HERE COMES THE MAN WITH THE MOST
INTENSE STARE IN BASEBALL.
SARAH: YOU WILL SEE FOUR-SEAMER,
SLIDER, THAT'S IT.
HE THREW A COUPLE OF SINKERS
LAST YEAR.
LITERALLY NINE.
AROUND 97 ON AVERAGE ON THAT
FOUR-SEAMER.
MELANIE: 27-YEAR-OLD FROM
MISSOURI.
HE WILL START WITH A SLIDER TO
PEDRO SEVERINO.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS FOR THE
ORIOLES.
THEY HAVE SCORED TWO HERE IN THE
EIGHTH.
IT IS A 5-3 GAME FOR THE RACE --
FOR THE RAYS RIGHT NOW.
SEVERINO SINGLED IN THE SECOND,
HAS STRUCK OUT TWICE SINCE.
SANTANDER JUST UP THE LINE.
0-1.
98, FASTBALL, STRIKE TWO.
SARAH: BRINGING HIM AND HERE
GETS TO WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ABOUT JUST HOW
INTERCHANGEABLE THESE RAYS
PITCHERS ARE.
HE HAS MOSTLY GOTTEN CLEAN
INNINGS.
BUT, KEVIN CASH IS CONFIDENT,
BRINGS HIM IN WITH TWO GUYS ON,
WHICH IS NOT A SITUATION HE HAS
BEEN IN ALL YEAR.
MELANIE: IT IS INTERESTING GOING
INTO THE MIND OF A RELIEVER,
HAVING SOME THRIVE ON BEING A
FIREMAN, AND OTHERS DOING BETTER
IN THE CLEAN INNINGS.
SARAH: THOSE THREE INHERITED
RUNNERS, NONE OF THEM SCORED, SO
THAT IS THE FULL CONTEXT YOU
HAVE GOT ON THIS SEASON.
MELANIE: FAIRBANKS, READY.
0-2.
SEVERINO TAKES A FASTBALL,
STRIKE THREE AT 99 INSIDE.
SEVERINO NOT MOVING ON THAT
PITCH.
NOT A LOT YOU CAN DO WITH 99
COMING IN THAT TIGHT.
NOW WE WILL BE A PINCH HITTER
FOR THE ORIOLES, D.J. STEWART,
THE FLORIDA STATE SEMINAL, --
THE FLORIDA STATE SEMINOLE,
COMES ON TO PINCH-HIT FOR PAT
VALAIKA.
LEFTY BETTER FACING THE RIGHTY
IN PETE FAIRBANKS.
STUART HAS BEEN A HUGE PART OF
THIS ORIOLES OUTFIELD AS THEY
HAVE MANAGED INJURIES THIS YEAR.
HE HAS NEVER FACED A DEFICIT.
STILL RYAN MOUNTCASTLE.
THEY OPTIONED RYAN MCKENNA
TODAY.
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
FAIRBANKS COMES HOME, SLIDER,
STRIKE ONE.
STEWART BECAME REALLY WELL NOT
FOR HITTING HOME RUNS.
HE HAS SEVEN ON THE YEAR.
HE SAID, LOOK, I AM NOT A HOME
RUN GUY.
I KNOW YOU GUYS LOVE THEM.
I AM A BASE HIT, LINE DRIVE KIND
OF GUY.
THEN HE WILL GO ON A TEAR WHERE
HE JUST RIPS OFF HOME RUNS.
SARAH: LINE DRIVES ARE STILL
BATTED BALLS IN THE AIR.
THOSE STILL TURN INTO HOME RUNS
A LOT.
MELANIE: BACK-TO-BACK SLIDERS
FOR FAIRBANKS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT JUST DIES.
SARAH: AVERAGING 97, GETTING UP
TO 99 ON THAT FOUR-SEAMER.
MELANIE: PETE FAIRBANKS, TRYING
TO BAIL OUT JP FEYEREISEN.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS, TO OUTS.
D.J. STEWART, 0-2 COUNT.
RAYS LEAD BY TWO.
FASTBALL JUST OUTSIDE.
STEWART WILL SEE ANOTHER PITCH.
SARAH: YOU WERE SAYING, WITH
THAT PITCHED SEVERINO, WHAT DO
YOU DO WITH THAT?
THAT WAS HIS SECOND-FASTEST
REGULAR SEASON STRIKEOUT HE HAS
HAD.
HE HAD A COUPLE OF 100
MILE-PER-HOUR STRIKEOUTS IN THE
POSTSEASON LAST YEAR, REALLY PUT
HIM ON THE MAP.
MELANIE: HE IS FEELING THE
LEVERAGE RIGHT NOW.
THE PITCH.
IT IS A BOUNCE IN THE DIRT.
SHARP AT 99.
GOOD FOR MEJIA, NOT GETTING
OVERTAKEN.
2-2.
DEFENSIVE -- ABOUT AS DEFENSIVE
OF A BLOCK AS YOU WILL SEE FROM
A CATCHER.
SARAH: AFTER SOME OF THOSE
EARLIER PITCHES FROM MCCLANAHAN
THAT WENT TO THE BACKSTOP, GOOD
TO SEE THOSE IN THIS MOMENT
ESPECIALLY.
MELANIE: TWO OUTS.
FAIRBANKS DELIVERS.
AND, BOTTOM ZONE, SLIDING
STRIKE.
PETE FAIRBANKS IS FEELING
HIMSELF RIGHT NOW.
BACK-TO-BACK STRIKEOUTS LEAVES
THE ORIOLES STRANDED ON THE
CORNERS.
THE RAYS ON TOP 5-3.
PAINTING IT.
♪
>> NOW TO THE BOTTOM OF THE 12.
>> THE RAYS AFFORD THEMSELVES
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PUSH ONE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> BASE HIT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
THE RAYS WIN IT IN 12.
BASE HIT INTO CENTER.
AROUND THIRD, THE RAYS WIN IT.
>> DEEP TO RIGHT FIELD, WAY
BACK, AND GOODBYE, HOME RUN!
A WALKOFF HOME RUN PINCH-HIT.
>> A TIEBREAKER IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
>> AN OUT AWAY.
>> BOUNCER TO SHORT.
THE RAYS ARE IN THE POSTSEASON.
DAVID PRICE GOES THE DISTANCE.
>> THE RAYS AND INDIANS, THE
WINNER HEADED TO BOSTON.
>> BIG FLY TO LEFT.
>> JUMPING ON THE FIRST PITCH.
ON THE LINE, TWO-R.B.I. DOUBLE.
>> THE COUNT TO CHOOSE AND HOME.
>> THE TAMPA BAY RAYS ARE MOVING
ON.
THEY WIN THE WILD-CARD GAME.
MELANIE: YOU CAN WATCH ALL OUT
OF MARKET REGULAR SEASON GAMES
LIVE OR ON-DEMAND, PLUS MLB
BEGINNING.
-- MLB BIG INNING.
VISIT MLB.TV FOR DETAILS.
ORIOLES WITH SOME DEFENSIVE
MOVES.
DOMINGO LEYBA TAKES OVER FOR PAT
VALAIKA AT SECOND BASE.
HE WAS PINCH-HIT FOR BY D.J.
STEWART.
SHAUN ANDERSON WILL TAKE OVER ON
THE MOUND FOR CESAR VALDEZ.
TWO INNINGS OF WORK, A
STRIKEOUT, NO RUNS.
BACK-TO-BACK REALLY SOLID
PERFORMANCES HERE.
SHAUN ANDERSON, JUST HIS SEVENTH
GAME OF THIS SEASON.
ANOTHER NEWCOMER FINDING HIS WAY
WITH THE ORIOLES.
HE WILL FACE VIDAL BRUJAN ON.
-- HE WILL FACE VIDAL BRUJAN.
SARAH: ANDERSON, A SMALL SAMPLE
SIZE, BUT MOSTLY HAS GONE TO HIS
SLIDER THUS FAR THIS YEAR.
FOUR-SEAMER.
A COUPLE OF OTHER PITCHES.
A FEW SINKERS, CHANGEUPS,
CURVEBALL.
PRETTY MUCH, SLIDER AND
FOUR-SEAMER.
>> .333 OPPONENT BATTING AVERAGE
AGAINST.
A FLORIDA PRODUCT.
1-1.
HE SMACKS A FASTBALL FAN.
1-2.
SARAH: HE WAS A STARTER IN 2019
FOR A BIT WITH THE GIANTS.
I COVERED A GAME AT CITI FIELD
WHEN HE WAS FACING THE METS.
PETE ALONSO, OFF TO A GREAT
START WITH HIS ROOKIE YEAR.
THEY WERE TEAMMATES ON THE
FLORIDA GATORS I BELIEVE.
MELANIE: THE 2016 FLORIDA GATORS
ROSTER IS ONE OF THE MOST PER --
ONE OF THE MOST PROLIFIC.
1-2.
IT IS A SHARP SHOT.
HE CAN'T COME UP WITH IT.
BRUJAN REACHES SAFELY TO START
THE EIGHTH INNING.
SO, DOMINGO LEYBA IMMEDIATELY
COMES INTO THE GAME AND GETS A
ROCKET BACK AT HIM.
SARAH: THAT IS HOW BASEBALL
GOES.
YOU HAVE TO BE READY FROM THE
MOMENT YOU SET FOOT.
101 MILES PER HOUR OFF THE BAT.
THAT IS NOT EASY WHEN IT IS
COMING AT YOU.
MELANIE: POSITION WELL OFF OF
HIS HOP.
BUT ANYTHING OVER 100 MILES PER
HOUR.
SARAH: NO THANK YOU FROM ME.
MELANIE: I THINK WE COULD SPEAK
FOR BOTH OF US SAYING THAT IS
NOT HAPPENING.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
AUSTIN MEADOWS, BASE HIT.
VITO BRUJAN VIDAL --VIDAL BRUJAN
WILL HOLD UP AT SECOND BASE.
FOR MEADOWS, HIS FIRST OF THE
SERIES, HE HAD BEEN 0-11.
SARAH: THIS IS WHY BASEBALL IS
SO FUNNY.
HE GETS ON BASE WITH A SINGLE.
NOT EVEN A HARD-HIT BATTED BALL,
YOU HAVE TO GET TO 95.
IT IS ALL THE SAME, YOU ARE
STANDING ON FIRST BASE.
MELANIE: SARAH SAYS, IT DOESN'T
COUNT.
95 OR BETTER.
BRANDON LOWE HAS ALL OF THOSE
METRICS IN HIS HEAD.
WANDER FRANCO, 0-3.
DOES HAVE A SACRIFICE FLY.
RAYS ON FIRST AND SECOND.
SHAUN ANDERSON GOES INTO MOTION.
A SPIN MOVE.
ANDERSON COLLECTS.
THE PITCH, STRIKE ONE.
SARAH: THE LAST GUY AS YOUNG AS
WANDER FRANCO TO HIT CLEANUP WAS
VLAD GUERRERO JR..
BECAUSE OF A LATE LINEUP CHANGE,
MOVED TO THE CLEANUP SPOT.
MELANIE: 0-1.
COMES IN SOUTH OF THE ZONE, 1-1.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHO KEVIN CASH
GAVE THAT FANFARE TO.
UP THERE WITH THE VLAD JR.'S,
BRYCE HARPERS.
ANTICIPATED ROOKIE TALENT.
DIEGO CASTILLO, YOUNG ROOKIE
PITCHER FOR THE RAYS, IS WARMING
UP.
HE HAS BEEN A SHUTDOWN MAN FOR
TAMPA BAY.
FRANCO SWINGS, SHALLOW LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
CEDRIC MULLINS.
THAT WAIST-HIGH CATCH.
THERE IS NOT MUCH THAT CEDRIC
MULLINS CAN'T GET TO.
HE SPOILS WANDER FRANCO.
IT HOLDS RUNNERS AT FIRST AND
SECOND.
SARAH: I REALLY THINK, WHAT
ALANNA WAS TALKING ABOUT, AND
WHAT WE HEARD FROM KEVIN CASH
ABOUT VLAD JUNIOR, THAT
COMPARISON, IT IS JUST SO
IMPORTANT PEOPLE MAY HAVE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED IN VLAD JR. AFTER
THOSE FIRST TWO YEARS.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE BUT
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN.
NOW HE IS AN M.V.P. CANDIDATE
AND IF NOT FOR SHOHEI OHTANI, HE
WOULD BE THE SLAMDUNK CHOICE.
IT IS TOUGH ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
COME UP AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE.
WANDER FRANCO, I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT HE WAS NOT
BROUGHT UP TO SAVE THE RAYS
OFFENSE.
HE WAS BROUGHT UP BECAUSE HE WAS
READY.
MELANIE: HE CERTAINLY PROVED
THAT.
HAD SEVERAL BIG SMASHES IN AAA.
LOWE SENDS IT TO THE LEFT.
1-1 HERE.
RAYS AT FIRST AND SECOND AGAINST
CEDRIC MULLINS.
THE MORE IMPRESSIVE THING IS HOW
EASY HE MAKES THAT LOOK FOR
BEING 5'8".
SARAH: THAT ALL PLAYS INTO WHERE
HE CAUGHT IT, NEXT TO HIS WAIST
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
HIS DEFENSE HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD.
IT IS THE RAYS OUTFIELDERS, THEN
HIM IF YOU LOOK AT OUTS ABOVE
AVERAGE.
MELANIE: YOU KNOW HE WAS FEELING
A LITTLE BIT RESPONSIBLE.
HE CHASED DOWN SOME HARD-HIT
BALLS FOR THE RAYS.
HE HAS BEEN TRYING TO FIND SOME
HITS THIS EVENING AS WELL.
KEVIN KIERMAIER.
HE AND CEDRIC MULLINS GO TOTO IN
-- GO TOE TO TOE IN A LOT OF
THINGS.
SARAH: A SKILLS COMPETITION, I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THAT.
MELANIE: SPRINT SPEEDS PUT ON
DISPLAY.
SARAH: THE PITCH SEQUENCE, WE
REALLY WILL JUST SEE SLIDERS AND
FOUR-SEAMERS FROM HIM.
THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE SO FAR.
TRUE TO THE SCOUTING REPORT THUS
FAR.
MELANIE: ANDERSON WITH THE FLOW
HELD UP BY A HEADBAND.
BRANDON LOWE TAKES A WALK.
BASES-LOADED OF RAYS HERE IN THE
EIGHTH.
YOU CAN GET EXCLUSIVE CONTENT
AND HIGHLIGHTS FROM YOUR
FAVORITE TEAM, THE TAMPA BAY
RAYS.
HEAD OVER TO YOUTUBE.COM/RAYS
AND HIT THE SUBSCRIBE BUTTON.
YOU CAN SEE GUYS LIKE THIS ONE,
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
RIGHT NOW, IT IS THE PITCHING
COACH TAKING A WALK OUT HERE TO
TALK TO ANDERSON AND SEVERINO.
AGAIN, MEJIA, 1-3 ON THE DAY BUT
HIS ONE WAS A BIG ONE.
ANOTHER LOOK AT THE LONG DRIVE
FOR FRANCISCO MEJIA OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
412 FEET.
26 DEGREE LAUNCH ANGLE.
WE HAVE TO HEAR IF HE WAS ABLE
TO GET THOSE NUMBERS CORRECT OR
NOT.
SARAH: THE OTHER WAS 25 AND HE
SAID 24.
SIMILAR KIND OF LAUNCH ANGLE
ZONE.
MELANIE: TAMPA BAY HAS A TWO-RUN
LEAD.
BASES FULL OF RAYS.
SIGN FROM SEVERINO.
THE PITCH HOME, IT IS FOULED
OFF.
SLIDER.
0-1.
SEVERINO OPTED TO STAY ELEVATED
FOR THAT CATCH.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE GOT TO
DISCUSS WITH MANAGER BRANDON
HYDE BEFOREHAND.
THERE HAS BEEN A TREND OF GOING
DOWN TO ONE KNEE FOR CATCHERS
ACROSS THE LEAGUE.
RUSSELL MARTIN WAS REALLY ONE OF
THE FIRST TO START TAKING THAT
TO HIS ADVANTAGE.
0-1.
MEJIA SCOOPS A BALL INTO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
CEDRIC LENTZ IS DIVING.
HE WON'T GET TO IT.
THE BALL RICOCHETS OFF THE WALL.
COMING INTO SCORE IS BRUJAN.
MEADOWS.
HE WILL WAVE AROUND BRANDON
LOWE.
IT IS A BASES-CLEARING TRIPLE.
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
THE RAYS HAVE PUSHED THEMSELVES
AWAY AGAIN.
8-3.
SARAH: THIS IS HOW THEY GET THAT
REPUTATION.
FRANCISCO MEJIA IS ONLY PLAYING
BECAUSE MIKE ZUNINO GOT HURT
LAST NIGHT.
HERE HE IS WITH A CAREER-HIGH
FIVE R.B.I.S.
FIVE OF THE SEVEN RUNS THEY HAVE
SCORED HAVE BEEN DRIVEN IN BY
HIM.
BACKUP CATCHER, NOT NECESSARILY
THE PLAYER YOU EXPECT.
CEDRIC MULLINS, HIS DEFENSE HAS
BEEN SO GOOD.
THAT IS NOT A CATCHABLE BALL.
MELANIE: ANDERSON TRYING TO WORK
HERE.
A RUNNER AT THIRD.
MEJIA, DID HE EVER COME OUT WITH
A TROT AROUND THAT?
A LITTLE BIT OF A SLOW INTO
FIRST BASE.
THEN, ABSOLUTELY TURNS ON THE
JETS ONCE HE TOUCHES SECOND.
MEJIA, A BASES-CLEARING TRIPLE.
JI-MAN CHOI FACES A -- CHASES A
FASTBALL.
ANDERSON, A LITTLE UPSET
ALLOWING THAT TRIPLE.
SARAH: OBVIOUSLY, A TRIPLE TO
THE CATCHER.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SPRINT
SPEED.
26.5 FEET PER SECOND.
THAT IS BELOW THE MLB AVERAGE.
BUT THIS IS A CATCHER.
MOST CATCHERS DO NOT RUN THAT
WELL.
OTHER THAN THE J.T. REALMUTO,
JORGE ALFARO, GOT THE JOB DONE,
GOT THAT TRIPLE.
MELANIE: JI-MAN CHOI, 1-3.
THE RAYS HAVE RE-EXTENDED THEIR
LEAD ANOTHER FIVE RUNS.
2-1.
CHOI LACES ONE INTO RIGHT FIELD,
A BASE HIT.
IT IS 9-3 TAMPA BAY.
TOUGH SLEDDING HERE FOR
ANDERSON.
AS YOU MENTIONED, STILL PRETTY
FRESH THIS SEASON.
JUST 26 YEARS OLD OVERALL.
LET'S THAT FASTBALL COME INSIDE
TO CHOI'S PLANE OF DRIVE.
A LITTLE ROUGHED UP IN KANSAS
CITY AS WELL.
THREE RUNS THROUGH TWO INNINGS.
HE DID HAVE A BETTER OUTING
AGAINST THE WHITE SOX.
AS THIS PITCH GETS UNDER
SEVERINO, CHOI WILL ADVANCE TO
SECOND.
HE KEEPS THE FEET MOVING.
HE CROSSES OVER AND HAS A LITTLE
RUNNING MAN GOING.
JI-MAN CHOI IS READY TO GO.
SARAH: ONE THING WITH ANDERSON,
HE HAS ALLOWED A LOT OF HARD
CONTACT THIS YEAR.
JUST ABOUT HALF THE TIME WHEN HE
ALLOWS A BATTED BALL ENTERING
TONIGHT, IT IS HARD-HIT.
WE HAVE SEEN CERTAINLY SOME HIGH
EXIT VELOS ON A COUPLE OF THESE
BATTED BALLS SO FAR.
THAT IS MAYBE WANT TO BE
EXPECTED HERE.
MELANIE: THE ORIOLES, WHO
EXCELLED WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION LAST SERIES.
1-11 THIS EVENING.
THE RAYS BATTING .500.
1-0 COUNT.
ANDERSON MADE HIS DEBUT IN 2019.
CAME TO BALTIMORE THIS YEAR FROM
MINNESOTA.
1-0.
INSIDE, BALL TWO.
HE REACHED ON A FORCE OUT IN THE
FOURTH.
2-0.
WALLS SCOOPS A FASTBALL, PICKED
UP BY DOMINGO LEYBA, THE SECOND
BASEMAN, WITH A QUICK THROW OVER
TO FIRST.
THAT RETIRES WALLS, THE SECOND
OUT.
CHOI MOVES OVER TO THIRD.
SO, 4-3 PUT OUT.
HERE COMES KEVIN KIERMAIER, ALSO
HITLESS THIS EVENING.
ANDERSON DID NOT MAKE HIS
PROFESSIONAL DEBUT UNTIL 2016.
CAME UP TO THE BIG LEAGUES IN
2019.
THAT IS LOW.
DIFFERENT TRACKS FOR DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND DIFFERENT
PLAYERS OBVIOUSLY, AS WE HAVE
THE DISCUSSION OF WANDER FRANCO.
1-0.
KIERMAIER DRIVES A SLIDER.
CEDRIC MULLINS CALLING EVERYONE
OFF.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE WAY TO THE
ALL-STAR TO MAKE THE PLAY.
THAT DRAWS THE EIGHTH TO A CLOSE
BUT NOT BEFORE THE RAYS TACK ON
FOR MORE RUNS.
WE HEAD TO THE NINTH.
>> POPPED HIM UP.
MANY ALEXANDER INTO RIGHT FIELD.
>> THAT WAS THE MOST I HAVE SEEN
ANY CALL FOR THE BALL.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE
GRABBED THAT BALL.
IT WAS PRETTY COOL.
>> NEW RECORD, 2131 CONSECUTIVE
GAMES.
>> MY POPS.
CAMDEN YARDS HAD A SPECIAL
FEELING, THAT BASEBALL HAD BEEN
PLAYED THERE FOR 100 YEARS.
IT WAS A GOOD BASEBALL
ENVIRONMENT.
I TOOK MY JERSEY OFF FOR THE
SOLE PURPOSE OF SHOWING MY KIDS
THAT I WORE THE T-SHIRT THEY
GAVE ME BEFORE THE GAME.
THAT TURNED INTO THE SORT OF
JERSEY CELEBRATION TIME.
AND THAT WAS A COOL THING.
I THINK I SHOOK EVERYBODY'S HAND
IN THE WHOLE BALLPARK THAT
NIGHT.
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK, LIVE ON
YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE
SHORTS.
TRY SHORTS IN THE YOUTUBE APP ON
YOUR PHONE.
I AM MELANIE NEWMAN ALONGSIDE
SARAH LANGS AND ALANNA RIZZO.
THE ORIOLES WITH A DOMINANT 6-1
WIN LAST NIGHT.
THE RAYS HAVE FOUGHT BACK.
THAT LEADS US TO THE QUESTION.
WHO IS YOUR YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME?
SHANE MCCLANAHAN, FRANCISCO
MEJIA, RANDY AROZARENA, OR
BRANDON LOWE?
ALL OF THEM, YOU COULD ARGUE,
HAVE THEIR OWN RIGHT TO TAKE ON
THAT YOUTUBE HARDWARE.
SARAH: I AM EXCITED TO SEE WHO
THE FANS PICKED BECAUSE IT KIND
OF TELLS US WHAT THE FANS VALUE
MOST.
DO YOU VALUE THAT BASES CLEARING
TRIPLE AT HOME RUN, OR DO YOU
VALUE THE STRONG EFFORT BY THE
STARTER?
MELANIE: YOU BROUGHT UP A REALLY
GOOD POINT.
GETTING THAT FAN INSIGHT INTO
WHAT IT IS THAT ENDEARS THEM
TOWARD BASEBALL.
DIEGO CASTILLO TAKES OVER.
PETE FAIRBANKS GOT THE FINAL TWO
OUTS OF THE EIGHTH INNING.
HE COMES HOME TO KELVIN
GUTIERREZ.
HE MISSES LOW.
BALL ONE.
SARAH: CASTILLO, YOU WILL SEE
MOSTLY SLIDER.
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE PULP, HE A
LOT OF GUYS THROW A PITCH LIKE
70% OF THE TIME.
HE IS NO EXCEPTION.
A LITTLE BUT OF A FOUR-SEAMER.
MELANIE: THE 1-0 TOP GUTIERREZ.
HE IS STICKING SLIDER AS YOUR
REPORT SAYS.
SARAH: HE WILL AVERAGE AROUND 95
ON THE SINKER.
PRETTY STANDARD, GOOD RELIEVER
IN THIS DAY IN AGE.
MELANIE: I THINK THE RAYS WILL
BACK YOU UP ON THAT.
HE SENDS IT OUTSIDE.
FASTBALL.
SARAH: HE IS A COYOTE MADE A LOT
OF THOSE STARTS WHEN THEY WERE
KIND OF DASHING IS A GUY WHO
MADE IT -- HE IS A GUY WHO MADE
A LOT OF THOSE STARTS WHEN
THEY WERE KIND OF TRANSITIONING.
MELANIE: GUTIERREZ REACHES OUT,
OFFSPEED, DRIVES IT INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
BRANDON LOWE IS THERE.
ONE AWAY.
CASTILLO, A BIG GROUNDBALL
PITCHER.
YOU SEE THAT POP UP A LOT, YOU
CAN'T REALLY BLAME THEM ONE
TRADITIONALLY THE DEFENSE -- THE
ERRORS TONIGHT ARE AN ANOMALY.
SARAH: IT IS A GREAT TEAM TO BE
A GROUNDBALL PITCHER ON FOR
SURE.
ON HIS STATCAST PITCH, THERE IS
A LOT OF RED.
RED MEANS GOOD.
QUALITY OF CONTACT, VERY GOOD
FOR HIM.
VERY BAD QUALITY FOR THE HATERS.
>> CEDRIC MULLINS, FASTBALL
INSIDE.
SARAH: THAT ALSO MATCHES UP AT
GETTING A LOT OF GROUND BALLS
BECAUSE THOSE WON'T BE HIT HARD.
MELANIE: MULLINS SINGLED IN THE
FIRST.
CASTILLO, FASTBALL AND A STRIKE,
WORKING INSIDE ON ORIOLES
BATTERS, CARRYING THROUGH THOSE
RAYS ARMS.
MULLINS LINES IT BACK UP PAST
FIRST BASE.
JI-MAN CHOI RECOVERS, SCOOPS,
AND BEATS MULLINS TO THE BAG.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
SARAH: JUST TALKING ABOUT HOW
GREAT JI-MAN CHOI IS TO WATCH,
HOW FUN.
THIS IS WHERE I WISH I COULD GET
THE SPRINT SPEED ON THIS.
MELANIE: HE HAS THAT HUSTLE HIM
A QUICK STEP AS CEDRIC MULLINS
WAS CHARGING DOWN THE LINE.
SARAH: AND A SMILE.
MELANIE: A NOD BACK TO DIEGO
CASTILLO.
THE ORIOLES TRAILED BY SIX IN --
TRAIL BY SIX IN THE NINTH.
CASTILLO CAME ON YESTERDAY AND
STRUCK OUT THREE IN A CLEAN
INNING.
FIRST PITCH TO HAYS, FASTBALL UP
AND IN, STRIKE ONE.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL SHAPE UP
TO BE A RUBBER MATCH BETWEEN
THESE TWO TEAMS TOMORROW.
AGAIN, JUST GOING BACK TO WHAT
AN INTERESTING AL EAST IT IS.
BACK TO BACK FASTBALLS FOR
CASTILLO.
SARAH: DEFINITELY NOT.
I DID NOT SEE IF THAT RED SOX
GAME GOT RESCHEDULED TO A
DOUBLEHEADER TOMORROW BUT AT
SOME POINT, THE RED SOX-BLUE
JAYS SERIES WILL FEATURE A
DOUBLEHEADER WHICH IS A CHANCE
TO POTENTIALLY MAKE UP A GAME.
MELANIE: CASTILLO, TWO OUTS.
0-2.
HAYS SPOILS THE SLIDER.
SARAH: THIS IS NOT A SAVE
SITUATION OF COURSE.
BUT, JUST TO GET ONE MORE POINT
ON HOW VERSATILE THIS PEN IS.
THE RAYS HAVE SIX DIFFERENT GUYS
WHO HAVE AT LEAST ONE SAVE THIS
YEAR.
PETE FAIRBANKS HAS FIVE.
I BELIEVE THEY SET A RECORD LAST
YEAR FOR THE MOST DIFFERENT
PITCHERS GETTING A SAVE FOR
THEM.
THERE ARE MELANIE: -- THERE ARE
NO DEFINED ROLES.
MELANIE: AND HE GETS THE
STRIKEOUT.
HAYS GOES DOWN ON THE SLIDER.
DIEGO CASTILLO CLOSES THE DOOR.
THE RAYS TAKE IT 9-3.
WE HAVE GOT AND EVEN SERIES ON
THIS MLB GAME OF THE WEEK ON
YOUTUBE.
AND, THE RAYS LINING UP IN THAT
VICTORY FORMATION.
THE POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE COMING UP.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PRESENTED
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
KEVIN CASH, IT IS A HIGH-FIVE
DAY.
HE SAID HE DID NOT WANT HIS
HITTERS TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
10 HITS OFF OF THE ORIOLES
DESPITE A VERY RARE FOUR-ERROR
NIGHT FOR THE RAYS AS WELL.
AGAIN, INTERESTING
BACK-AND-FORTH SERIES.
HE NEVER REALLY KNOW WHAT IS
GOING TO TURN OUT.
A YOUNG ROOKIE IN SHANE
MCCLANAHAN.
JOHN MEANS.
A VERY YOU NANYANG CONCEPT FOR
STARTERS.
SARAH: IT WAS GREAT TO SEE SHANE
MCCLANAHAN COME OUT AND HAVE ONE
OF THE BEST STARTS OF HIS
CAREER.
HE CALMED DOWN AFTER THAT SECOND
INNING AND SHOWED A LOT.
SEE IF THEY CAN STRETCH.
CAN THEY GET HIM INTO THAT
100-PITCH ECHELON AT SOME POINT
TOWARD OCTOBER AND FUTURE
STARTS?
MELANIE: YOU CAN OVERLOOK WHAT
FRANCISCO MEJIA DID TODAY.
MIKE ZUNINO HAS BEEN THAT ANCHOR
AS A BACKSTOP AND AT THE PLATE
AS WELL.
HE COMES OUT TONIGHT AND
ABSOLUTELY CONNECTS TO PICK UP
THIS RAYS CLUB.
NOT THAT THEY WERE IN DIRE
STRAITS BUT HE WAS THAT LIFE ON
THE OFFENSE.
SARAH: AGAIN, THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO PROBABLY ENTERING YESTERDAY
DID NOT KNOW IF HE WOULD BE
PLAYING TODAY.
WE SEE THIS TIME AND AGAIN.
WE SEE IT FROM BACKUP PLAYERS
ALL THE TIME.
IT IS SOMETHING I LOVE ABOUT
BASEBALL IN GENERAL.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS ON DISPLAY
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE RAYS
TONIGHT.
MELANIE: HE IS THE MLB YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
GOT TO FIND A PLACE TO PUT THAT
LITTLE TROPHY.
ABSOLUTELY BLASTED A HOME RUN IN
THE FOURTH INNING OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
HE WAS NOT DONE, FACING AGAIN
OFF OF ANDERSON, MORE LIFE IN
THE EIGHTH INNING AFTER THE
ORIOLES HAD CUT IT WITHIN TWO
RUNS, DRIVING IT OUT, CLEARS THE
BASES WITH A TRIPLE.
THREE RUNS OF INSURANCE COME
HOME FOR TAMPA BAY AND THEY
CEMENT THE VICTORY OVER THE
ORIOLES.
HE WAS JUST AS DOMINANT IN THE
WIN AS HE WAS IN THE POLLS.
60% OF YOU VOTED FOR THE RAYS'
BACKSTOP.
HE JOINS US NOW WITH HIS
TRANSLATOR.
FRANCISCO MEJIA, PLAYER OF THE
GAME, HAVE YOU EVER TAKEN HOME
AN AWARD THE FIRST WEEK AFTER
THE BREAK?
FRANCISCO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: IT IS THE FIRST TIME
I HAVE SEEN ANY KIND OF AWARD
LIKE THIS ONE.
MELANIE: YOU FOUND OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GAME THAT YOU HAD
TO TAKE OVER FOR MIKE ZUNINO
YESTERDAY.
HOW DID YOU CHANGE THAT MINDSET?
FRANCISCO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: WITH THIS TEAM,
KNOWING I AM THE BACKUP CATCHER,
I KNOW I KNOW HAVE TO BE READY
AT ANY TIME.
THERE ARE ONLY TWO OF US.
SARAH: YOU GUYS ARE JUST A GAME
BEHIND THE RED SOX.
THE RED SOX DID NOT PLAY TODAY.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING HEADING INTO
THE SECOND HALF, LOOKING TOWARD
THE SEPTEMBER PLAYOFF PUSH,
POTENTIALLY TOWARD OCTOBER?
TRANSLATOR: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
FRANCISCO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: THEY ARE A VERY
COMPETITIVE TEAM.
THIS IS ALSO A TEAM FOR US THAT
WE WILL KEEP ON GRINDING UNTIL
WE GET THE RESULTS THAT WE NEED.
SARAH: WHAT HAS CHANGED FOR YOU
THIS YEAR?
HITTING THE BALL HARDER, MAY BE
GETTING SOME MORE PLAYING TIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS DIFFERENT
WITH YOUR SWING OR APPROACH?
FRANCISCO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: I THINK THE
CONFIDENCE.
THIS TEAM AND EVERYONE HERE HAS
HELPED ME BE MORE RELAXED AND
CALM.
MY THINK THAT HELPS WITH MY
CONFIDENCE ON THE FIELD.
MELANIE: HOW MUCH FUN ARE YOU
HAVING WITH THIS TEAM?
WHERE ARE YOU PUTTING THE
TROPHY?
FRANCISCO: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: I AM NOT SURE WHERE
I AM TO PUT IT YET.
I KNOW MY KIDS ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO LOVE IT.
I AM GLAD WE HAVE A TEAM THAT
COMPETES AND HAS FUN HERE.
MELANIE: WE LOVE TO HEAR IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU AND THE RAYS TAKING A BIG
ONE TODAY AND YOU GET THE
TROPHY.
WE WANT TO KNOW JUST ONE MORE
THING.
IF YOU ARE VOTING FOR A TEAMMATE
TO TAKE HOME A TROPHY, WERE YOU
GIVING IT TO?
TRANSLATOR: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TRANSLATOR: -- FRANCISCO:
[SPEAKING SPANISH] TRANSLATOR: I
WOULD VOTE FOR RANDY.
MELANIE: RANDY CERTAINLY GOT A
LITTLE ROWDY TODAY AS WELL.
FRANCISCO, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
VERY WELL DESERVED.
I HOME RUN, A BASES CLEARING
TRIPLE TO BOOT.
.
AGAIN, THE RAYS WITH A BIG WIN.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT R.B.I. BY
RAYS CATCHERS IN A SINGLE GAME
IN THE PAST 20 SEASONS.
FRANCISCO MEJIA JUST IN THE
SECOND SPOT.
TRAVIS D'ARNAUD AMONG THE
LIGHTS.
SIX AND FIVE, THAT IS THE
HIGHEST THEY HAVE REACHED AND HE
IS PUSHING TO BE THE NEXT ONE TO
TAKE THE TOP STOP -- TOP SPOT.
KNOCKOFF THE
ORIOLES 9-3.
WE WILL RETURN WITH MORE.
YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN AHEAD OF US.
I COULD PROBABLY TAKE A GUESS
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW.
I THINK WE CAME INTO THIS WITH
12 OR SO PLAYERS UNDER SERIOUS
DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE DEFINITELY NARROWED THAT
DOWN.
TIME FOR THE FIFTH OVERALL
SELECTION.
THE O'S ARE UP NEXT.
>> WITH THE FIFTH PICK OF THE
DRAFT, THE ORIOLES SELECT COLTON
COWSER, AN OUTFIELDER FROM SAM
HOUSTON.
>> COLTON COWSER FOR US WAS
PROBABLY THE BEST PURE HITTER IN
THE DRAFT THIS YEAR.
HE HITS FOR AVERAGE, POWER, AND
HAS PLUS SPEED.
SOMEBODY WHO WILL BRING PLUS
DEFENSE AND PLUS OFFENSE TO OUR
TEAM.
WE HAVE BEEN BUILDING ONE OF THE
ELITE FARM SYSTEMS IN THE GAME
AND THIS IS A BIG PART OF THAT.
TO GET A HIGH-IMPACT, DOMINANT
COLLEGE PLAYER'S ANOTHER ELITE
BAT INTO OUR FARM SYSTEM.
WE HAVE OUR SLEEVES ROLLED UP
FOR THE REST OF THE DRAFT AND WE
WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE SHORTS.
TRY SHORTS IN THE YOUTUBE APP ON
YOUR PHONE.
TAMPA BAY RAYS TAKE OUT THE
ORIOLES 9-3.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
HIGHLIGHTS.
AND, FOR ALL OF THE WOMEN WHO
ARE OUT THERE COVERING THE GAME
FOR US, WHO OPENED UP THE DOOR
COVERING -- OPENED UP THE DOOR
FOR MYSELF, SARAH, AND ALANA.
AN AWESOME DAY.
SARAH: IT HAS BEEN SO GREAT TO
BE PART OF THIS, ALL OF THE
ENERGY, POSITIVE VIBES.
THE GREAT THING IS, THIS IS NOT
THE LAST.
ALANNA: I THINK THE BIGGEST
THING IS THAT WE WERE THE FIVE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE CHOSEN TO DO
THIS BROADCAST.
DOING
WHAT WE ARE DOING IN THIS
INDUSTRY FOR SUCH A LONG TIME.
THERE ARE SO MANY WOMEN NOW HAVE
THE RESUMES WHO CAN ABSOLUTELY
DO THIS BROADCAST.
MELANIE: JOHN MEANS, HIS FIRST
START BACK OFF THE IL.
SARAH: ABSOLUTE RAPADA.
-- ABSOLUTE BREAKOUT.
MELANIE: THIS ONE GOES INTO THE
LEFT-FIELD SPOT.
AROZARENA ROUNDING OUT AS HE
HEADS IN FOR SECOND.
HE GETS THINGS STARTED IN A.B.
GUAY IN THE FIRST.
IT IS A PITCH DRIVEN INTO LEFT
FIELD.
IT WILL SPLIT THE DEFENSE.
RANDY AROZARENA HELD IT OFF.
THE THROW IS SHORT.
THE RAYS JUMP OUT, 1-0 LEAD OFF
A VIDAL BRUJAN R.B.I..
>> ONE OUT, COMING HOME TO
WANDER FRANCO.
THE FASTBALL, AND IT IS A DRIVE
RIGHT.
THE PLANT THE PLATE IS NOT IN
TIME.
V DELL PUT ON THE WHEELS.
--BRUJAN PUT ON THE WHEELS.
PEDRO SEVERINO SMACKS A BALL,
LINE DRIVE, BASE HIT.
SANTANDER SCORES EASILY.
THEY HAVE CUT THE LEAD TO 2-1 IN
THE SECOND.
>> HE GETS MULLINS TO CHASE AN
ELEVATED FASTBALL.
>> THAT HAS BEEN SOMETHING --
THAT IS GONE.
>> IT IS UP AND RICH HILL CALLS
IT.
A HOME RUN.
RANDY AROZARENA.
>> THERE IS YOUR BREAKOUT
OFFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR
RIGHT THERE, RANDY AROZARENA.
MELANIE: A DRIVE INTO LEFT
FIELD.
IT IS OUT!
FRANCISCO MEJIA.
GOODBYE, BASEBALL.
TWO-RUN HOME RUN.
IT IS A 5-1 LEAD FOR THE RAYS.
MEJIA'S FOURTH BLAST OF THE
YEAR.
ANDREW KITTREDGE.
SHANE MCCLANAHAN'S DAY IS DONE.
BRUJAN ABSOLUTELY LAID OUT TO
PICK UP ANDREW KITTREDGE.
A PHOTO FINISH THROUGH FIRST
BASE HERE FOR SANTANDER.
CHOI RETURNED TO COVER THE BAG.
EVERYONE IS LAYING OUT ON THIS
ONE.
WHAT A PLAY FOR BRUJAN.
TOP OF THE EIGHTH INNING, JP
FEYEREISEN TAKES OVER FOR TAMPA
BAY.
AUSTIN HAYS DRILLS IT.
REACHES ON AN ERROR.
THIRD BASEMAN WANDER FRANCO, AS
HE AIRMAILS THIS OVER.
WANDER FRANCO NOT TOO HAPPY WITH
HIMSELF.
MANCINI AT THE PLATE.
HE DRIVES ONE OFF OF FEYEREISEN.
AUSTIN HAYS TAGS UP AND ROLLS
INTO THIRD PLACE -- INTO THIRD
BASE.
RYAN MOUNTCASTLE, THE ROOKIE,
SEND ONE TO RIGHT FIELD, BRANDON
LOWE BOBBLES IT, PICKS UP THE
ERROR.
THE ORIOLES CUT THE LEAD 5-2.
ANTHONY SANTANDER ALREADY HAS A
DOUBLE UNDER HIS BELT.
LET'S PUT THAT ONE ON REPEAT.
DEEP RIGHT CENTER FIELD, HE WILL
PICK UP HIS SECOND DOUBLE OF THE
DAY.
SCORING SAFELY, IT IS NOW 5-3,
RAYS STILL WITH THE LEAD.
WILD PITCH FROM FEYEREISEN.
RAMON URIAS TRYING TO KEEP
THINGS GOING.
PATIENCE WORKS JUST AS FINE.
HE PICKS UP A WALK OF JP
FEYEREISEN.
PETER FAIRBANKS COMES OVER.
PEDRO SEVERINO RUNG UP ON
STRIKES.
PETE FAIRBANKS ONLY NEEDED THREE
PITCHES TO DO IT.
D.J. STEWART.
FAIRBANKS DID IT AGAIN.
HOW DO YOU LIKE THAT?
PETE FAIRBANKS, A LITTLE BOBBLE
AS YOU WALK OFF THE MOUND.
SHAUN ANDERSON CAME ON.
PLAYER OF THE GAME, FRANCISCO
MEJIA.
CEDRIC MULLINS ON AN ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE PLAY, CAN'T COME UP
WITH IT.
BRANDON LOWE WRAPS IT UP.
A BASES CLEARING TRIPLE,
FRANCISCO MEJIA WITH THE
INSURANCE FOR THE RAYS.
DIEGO CASTILLO ON IN THE NINTH
INNING, LOOKING FOR BACK-TO-BACK
CLEAN PERFORMANCES, AND HE
DELIVERS.
THE ORIOLES GO DOWN 1, 2, 3 TO
DIEGO CASTILLO.
WE DON'T ABOUT BRANDON LOWE
BEING THE LAST MAN TO SCORE ON
THAT -- WE TALKED ABOUT BRANDON
LOWE BEING THE LAST MAN TO SCORE
ON THAT TRIPLE.
HE JOINED ALANNA RIZZO DOWN ON
THE FIELD.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
HAS HAD TO REALLY CATCH UP,
REALLY TAKING TIME AWAY FROM HIS
STUFF AT THE PLATE.
ALANNA: HE DID HAVE A NICE
DEFENSIVE PLAY IN THE OUTFIELD
OFF OF THAT TREY AT BAT.
GOT ON BASE THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES IN THIS GAME.
WE EXPECT THIS FROM A VETERAN
GUY WHO HAS KNOWN THIS GAME UP
IN DOWN.
FRANCISCO MEJIA COMES IN FOR THE
INJURED MIKE ZUNINO.
WHAT DOES HE DO?
FIVE R.B.I.S.
NOT BAD FOR HIM.
I ASKED BRANDON LOWE IF IT IS
JUST THAT NEXT MAN UP AND TELL
IT?
BRANDON: IT IS WHAT YOU EXPECT
FROM A GUY WHO WORKS HIS BUTT
OFF BEHIND THE SCENES.
ALANNA: MCCLANAHAN COMES IN HERE
AND GOES UP AGAINST HIS HOMETOWN
TEAM.
THE FIRST CAREER START HE HAS
AGAINST BALTIMORE.
WHAT WERE YOU NOTICING?
BRANDON: THE SAME SHANE.
THE SAME COMPETITIVE FACTOR.
HE IS OUT THERE TRYING TO
EXECUTE WITH EVERYTHING HE CAN.
WHEN HE IS MISSING A SPOT, HE IS
TELLING HIMSELF EVERYTHING HE
NEEDS TO DO TO GET BACK IN THE
GROOVE.
ALANNA: DESPITE BALTIMORE'S
STRUGGLES THIS YEAR, YOU KNOW
THEY ARE A TEAM THAT CAN HIT.
THE TREY MANCINI PLAY IN THE
FIFTH, WHAT WAS YOUR READ OFF
THE BAT?
BRANDON: MY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT TREY CAN DO.
HEARD THE POP OFF THE BAT, HE
HIT IT WELL.
JUST TRYING TO DO WHATEVER I
COULD TO MAKE A PLAY.
ALANNA: TAMPA BAY DOES THINGS A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT DOES THINGS
RIGHT.
YOU GUYS ARE ALWAYS IN THE
COMPETITIVE DIVISION IN THE AL
EAST.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST FOCUS YOU
WANT IN THE SECOND HALF?
BRANDON: JUST PLAYING OUR
BASEBALL.
DON'T LET THAT KIND OF DRAG IN.
COME OUT EVERY DAY AND PLAY OUR
BASEBALL, AND WE WILL BE HAPPY
WHERE WE ARE AT THE END OF THE
YEAR.
ALANNA: 2-3 WITH A WALK, WHAT
WORKED FOR YOU AT THE PLATE?
BRANDON: TRYING TO PUT A SOLID
SWING ON THE BALL, OBVIOUSLY GET
ON BASE.
LET HIM DRIVE ME AND A COUPLE
MORE TIMES.
ALANNA: RUBBER MATCH TOMORROW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
CONGRATS ON THE WIN.
YOU HEAR IT ALL THE TIME, DON'T
DO TOO MUCH.
LESS IS MORE.
IT PAID DIVIDENDS.
BALTIMORE CAN SLEEP QUICKLY.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO.
THE RUBBER MATCH OF THIS
THREE-GAME SERIES AT 12: 10
TOMORROW.
MELANIE: THAT IS A REALLY TIGHT
TURNAROUND.
HOW BIG IS THAT, THAT IN THAT
RUBBER MATCH, YOU TOOK GAME TWO?
ALANNA: I THINK YOU HAVE TO.
TAMPA BAY HAS A LOT TO PLAY FOR.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT A DIFFICULT
THIS DIVISION IS.
WHILE NOBODY OUTSIDE THE RED SOX
PROBABLY THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE
WHERE THEY ARE, THEY WILL BE
TOUGH THE REST OF THE WAY.
THE NEW YORK YANKEES ARE
STRUGGLING.
I DON'T THINK THE YANKEES WILL
MAKE THE POSTSEASON.
BUT THEY ARE STILL THE NEW YORK
YANKEES.
THEY STILL ARE A FORMIDABLE
OPPONENT.
TAMPA BAY HAS A LOT TO PLAY FOR.
THEY PROBABLY STILL HAVE A SOUR
TASTE IN THEIR MOUTHS AFTER LAST
YEAR'S WORLD SERIES.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE, GET
ANOTHER ONE.
THESE TEAMS GOING IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
SARAH: HE TALKS TO US DURING THE
BROADCAST ABOUT HOW MUCH THIS
BULLPEN HAS REALLY STUDIED THE
TEAM.
HOW MUCH DID YOU SEE FROM THE
BULLPEN AND HOW MUCH THAT SET
THE TONE FOR THE WIN?
ALANNA: I THINK THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAN ON THAT BULLPEN
AND THEY HAVE TO.
THREE OF THEIR BIGGEST STARTERS
FROM LAST YEAR'S WORLD SERIES
RUN TEAM ARE REALLY NO LONGER
WITH THEM.
CHARLIE MORTON IS NOT HERE.
BLAKE SNELL IS WITH THE PADRES.
I DON'T THINK THAT TAMPA BAY
MADE A MISTAKE IN LETTING HIM
GO.
TYLER GLASNOW IS WORKING HIS WAY
BACK FROM THAT INJURY.
THEY ARE RELYING ON THOSE
BULLPEN ARMS AND KEEPING IT
GOING.
THE BEST BULLPEN E.R.A. IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
THEY STILL HAVE SOME KEY ARMS IN
THE BULLPEN THAT ARE INJURED AS
WELL.
THE 20 PITCHER LIVE BP SESSION,
ANDERSON.
HE WILL GO ON A REHAB START.
THEY STILL HAVE SOME KEY GUYS
THAT ARE WANTING TO COME BACK.
BUT SOMEHOW, THEY ARE GETTING IT
DONE.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF PUZZLE PIECES TO
REMAIN COMPETITIVE.
MELANIE: THEY HAVE THE PUZZLE
ALL THE OTHER KIDS WANT.
EVEN BEING SHORT, THEY STILL
DON'T COME UP SHORT.
WE WILL CATCH UP WITH YOU LATER.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE JUST YET.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INSET -- THAT
INSIDE.
THIS 9-3OVER
THE ORIOLES.
GAME TWO ON THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
>> JUST POUNDED BY THE BAT OF
BETTS.
SWING AND GOOD PITCHER BY
GLASNOW.
HERE IS A SHOT INTO RIGHT.
AT THE WALL, IT IS GONE!
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> BE CAREFUL.
YOU SAY NO?
HE SAID NO?
I HAD TO DO IT BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO.
>> YEAH.
>> WATCH OUT, MAN.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOING TO SIT NEXT TO YOU
THE WHOLE GAME.
>> LET'S GO.
LET'S GO, BABY.
>> I DID UPPER TODAY.
I DID PUSH-UPS TODAY TOO.
>> THANKS.
IF I CAN COUNT ON ANYBODY TO BE
NICE, IT IS YOU.
>> IN THE SHOWER AFTER YOUR
HAIRCUT.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT ME, IT IS
LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
DON'T GO TO CENTER.
MAKING FUN OF ME BECAUSE I DID
NOT HIT MY BALL TOMORROW FEET
AND RANDY DID.
IT IS A BLAST WATCHING YOU IN
THE DERBY.
HOW WAS IT?
IT LOOKS EXHAUSTING.
>> I WAS SO TIRED.
ESPECIALLY AT THE ALTITUDE AND
EVERYTHING.
MELANIE: MLB GAME OF THE WEEK.
THE LAST 15 MEETINGS HAVE NOT
EXACTLY GONE THE ORIOLES WAY.
THE RAYS HAVE TAKEN 13 OF THEM.
85-46, THAT RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
25 HOME RUNS FOR THE RAYS, 10
FOR THE ORIOLES.
THE ONLY LOSS FOR TAMPA BAY SO
FAR THIS SEASON WAS LAST NIGHT'S
GAME.
SARAH, WE JUST GOT TO HEAR FROM
THE PLAYERS WHO WERE MIC'D UP.
I THINK I HAVE TO GIVE A LITTLE
BIASED KELVIN GUTIERREZ, WHO
SAID, THIS IS THE FIRST GAME
THAT IT HAS BEEN ENTIRELY WOMEN.
I THINK THAT IS JUST A REALLY
TRANSCENDENT MOMENT WHEN YOU
HAVE GOT THE PLAYERS TALKING
ABOUT THE BROADCASTERS.
ALANNA: NO QUESTION.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO GREAT, SO
MANY PLAYERS CAME UP TO ME AND
KNEW THAT IT WAS AN ALL-FEMALE
CREW.
WHEN THE PLAYERS ARE PAYING
ATTENTION, LET'S BE HONEST, THEY
HAVE A LOT TO THINK ABOUT WHEN
IT COMES TO PLAYING THIS GAME.
BUT THEY WERE AWARE OF IT.
THE COACHES MENTIONED SOMETHING
TO ME.
ALL OF US HAVE BEEN ASKED TO DO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
INTERVIEWS, WHICH HAS BEEN
GREAT.
IN THE 16 YEARS I HAVE BEEN
DOING SPORTS BROADCASTING AND
TELEVISION, I HAVE RECEIVED MORE
INTEREST FOR THIS GAME THAN ANY
OTHER EVENT I HAVE COVERED.
I AM GLAD IT IS RECEIVED SO
POSITIVELY AND I AM GLAD THE
REACH HAS BEEN THERE AND
HOPEFULLY WE CHANGE SOME LIVES
OF SOME YOUNG GIRLS TONIGHT.
MELANIE: ABSOLUTELY.
SARAH, YOU WERE IN THE HEART OF
NEW YORK, AROUND BASEBALL 24/7,
RIGHT OUTSIDE OF SUZYN WALDMAN'S
DOOR, SOMEONE WE HAVE ALL TALKED
ABOUT, HOW MUCH OF A PILLAR SHE
HAS FOR US.
BUT YOU SEE EVERY SINGLE GAME
EVERY DAY, WHICH STILL BLOWS MY
MIND.
WHAT A FUN DAY.
SARAH: SO FUN.
ANY DEBRIS GET TO CALL A
BASEBALL GAME IS SUCH A FUN DAY.
TO DO IT WITH THE TWO OF YOU.
I AM LOOKING AT ALANA.
SHE CAN'T REALLY SEE ME.
BUT THIS WAS SO MUCH FUN.
I LOVE THAT THE PLAYERS WERE
AWARE OF IT.
I THINK WE HAVE ALL SET AT SOME
POINT THAT ULTIMATELY WE ARE
HERE DOING OUR JOBS.
BUT IT IS NICE TO SEE THAT
RECOGNITION.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
PLAYERS RECOGNIZE, COACHES,
MANAGERS.
THAT HELPS MAKE THIS THE NORM
GOING FORWARD.
THAT REALLY IS THE POINT OF US
DOING THIS RIGHT NOW OTHER THAN
JUST CALLING THE BASEBALL GAME.
MELANIE: WE GOT TO RECOGNIZE
SOME WOMEN EARLIER.
BUT THERE ARE JUST SO MANY MORE
WHO NOT ONLY HAVE COME BEFORE US
BUT ALSO COMING UP BEHIND US AS
WELL.
ROBIN ROBERTS.
AGAIN, WOMEN YOU JUST CAN'T WRAP
AROUND HOW IMPRESSIVE THEY HAVE
BEEN.
LINDA COHN.
MARY CARILLO AS WELL.
DORIS BURKE, A LEGEND IN THE
BASKETBALL WORLD.
BETH MOWINS, SHE IS NOT ONLY
DOING FOOTBALL, BUT EXTENDING
INTO BASEBALL GAMES.
SOME STRONG WOMEN HAVE COME
BEFORE US BUT WE ARE AMONGST
STRONG WOMEN NOW.
THERE ARE SO MANY MORE WHO ARE
NOT YET IN THE SPOTLIGHT BUT OUR
BUILDING AND COMING THIS WAY.
ALANNA: AGAIN, WE WERE THE FIVE
WHO WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
ASKED TO DO THIS BROADCAST BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY WOMEN WHO HAVE
RESUMES THAT ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSIVE WHO COULD HAVE EASILY
TAKEN A RESPONSE.
I THINK SUZYN WALDMAN SAID IT
BEST EARLIER IN AN ARTICLE SHE
DID, IF WE ONLY DO THIS ONE
TIME, WHAT IS THE POINT?
MOVING FORWARD, I HOPE IT
HAPPENS MORE OFTEN, WHERE IT
DOES BECOME COMMONPLACE, WHERE
YOU CAN TAKE GENDER OUT OF A JOB
DESCRIPTION.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
MENTION THAT THERE ARE SOME
WOMEN ON THE CREW THAT ARE
BEHIND THE SCENES AS WELL.
THEY HAVE DONE SO MUCH TO BE
ABLE TO PUT THIS TOGETHER AND I
WOULD ALSO BE REMISS IF I DID
NOT ALSO SAY, IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR WOMEN TO SUPPORT WOMEN WE
ARE OUR BIGGEST CHEERLEADERS.
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF MEN WHO
SUPPORT US AS WELL.
ALSO, WHEN OUR MALE COUNTERPARTS
AND COLLEAGUES ARE JUST AS
EXCITED FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES, AND
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW UNIQUE IT IS
AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
MELANIE: SARAH, I KNOW YOU HAD
TO GET A TEXT IN TO MOM EARLIER.
BUT WHAT IS THAT DRIVING
CATALYST FOR YOU?
SARAH: MY MOTHER WAS A HUGE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS FAN AND SHE HAS
TOLD MANY TIMES, SHE JUST DID
NOT SEE AT THE TIME WHEN SHE WAS
YOUNGER THAT IT WAS REALLY
POSSIBLE.
SHE DID NOT TELL ME THAT UNTIL I
WAS WELL INTO THIS INDUSTRY.
IT IS JUST SO AMAZING TO GET A
CHANCE TO LIVE OUT THAT DREAM
FOR HER AND TO GET A CHANCE TO
DO OUR JOBS EVERY DAY.
I WANT TO 100% AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ALANA SAID, ABOUT MEN
SUPPORTING US IN ADDITION TO
WOMEN SUPPORTING WOMEN.
YOU NEED THAT TO GET THE CHANGE
DONE AND FOR THINGS TO HAPPEN IN
THE FUTURE.
MELANIE: IT IS A TEAM EFFORT FOR
HUMANKIND TO MAKE OMENS LIKE
THIS NOT ONLY HAPPENED, BUT TO
MAKE IT NORMAL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SO MANY OF
THOSE MOMENTS AS WE MOVE ALONG
NOT ONLY THROUGHOUT THIS
BASEBALL SEASON BUT IN THE
BASEBALL HISTORY BOOKS.
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT THE LAST
TIME THIS WILL BE HAPPENING AND
WE CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE REST OF
THE TALENT COMING UP ALONG THE
WAY.
ON THE BACK OF SARAH LANGS,
ALANNA RIZZO, A BIG THANK YOU TO
HEIDI WATNEY AND GARDENER -- AND
LAUREN GARDENER.
THIS HAS BEEN THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK.
THE NEXT GAME, AUGUST 11, WHITE
SOX AT THE TWINS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS ANY OF
IT.
ON BEHALF OF OUR ENTIRE CREW,
HAVE A GREAT ONE AND THANKS SO
MUCH FOR BEING A PART OF HISTORY
TONIGHT.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]